BEFORE WE GO GET IT GO AHEAD GET
STARTED OUT OF WE HAVE SEVERAL
MEMBERS ON THEIR WAY.
APPROPRIATIONS MEETING THIS
MORNING AND THERE A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENING AROUND THE
BUILDING SO PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY
WILL BE COMING IN AND OUT BUT I
WILL BE HERE -- TO THE BITTER
END.
AND I DO BUT JUST VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE AND AND FOR FOR DEAN AND
LARA AND AND AND YES IN IN MARIN.
LAURA FRIEDMAN JUST TEXTED ME
AND IS UNDER WAY -- BUT HERE I
SEE EXAMPLES SO BY THE END LARA
AND HAVE DONE A GREAT JOB OF
PULLING TOGETHER A WONDERFUL
HEARING TODAY WE'RE GONNA BE
TALKING SHOP ABOUT A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT ISSUES RELATING TO THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY GROWTH.
CHALLENGES AND BUILDING AT
EDUCATIONAL EQUITY INTO THE JOBS
PIPELINE THIS IS GOING TO GIVE.
pPOWER OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY IN
OUR STATE WE HAVE -- THIS SORT
OF HEARING.
HI ABOUT ONCE A YEARBUT WE'RE
GOING TO BE TAKING A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT FOCUS THIS YEAR AND
AND I THINK YOU'LL ENJOY A THAT
ONE OF OUR PANELISTS THAT WE'VE
BROUGHT TOGETHER -- WE'RE GONNA
LOOK AT THE ROLE THAT ARTS
EDUCATION PLAYS IN CREATING
OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR YOUTH IS A
TRANSITION FROM SCHOOL TO THE
CREATIVE WORKFORCE -- AND I WILL
SAY THAT -- THAT THIS YEAR'S --
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
REPORT ON THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
HAS SOME PRETTY INTRIGUING
ECONOMIC IMPACT NUMBERS AND AND
MISTER KLEIN NIGHTS WILL -- WILL
BE -- GIVEN OPPORTUNITY TO TO TO
SHARE THOSE -- THOSE DATA WITH
US AND HE'S GOING TO BE A PART
OF OUR FIRST PANEL.
THERE'S CERTAINLY A LINK BETWEEN
OUR POLICY DECISIONS INCLUDING.
FUNDING OF THE ARTS PUBLIC BY IN
IS SO IMPORTANT IN SUPPORT FOR
THE GREATER ECOSYSTEM OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY INCLUDING THE
MANY SMALLER NON PROFITS WHICH-BUILD.
CULTURAL VIBRANCY DIRECTLY TO
OUR COMMUNITIES AT SOME OF THE
THINGS WE'RE GONNA BE TALKING
ABOUT -- WE ALSO HAVE ARTS
ORGANIZATIONS IN TEACHING
ARTISTS WHO SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS
WITH ARTS PROGRAMS BUILDING
SKILL.
I BRING SKILL BUILDING AND
EDUCATION EQUITY ONTO CAMPUS WE
ALSO COURSE -- INCREASING --
THEY THEY'RE ABLE TO INCREASE
AWARENESS FOR STUDENTS IN
UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS OF THE TYPES
OF CREATE JOBS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
WHICH IS PART OF THE ART SAID
OPPORTUNITY EQUATION YOU KNOW
THEY'RE THEY'RE LIKE KIDS JUST
DON'T KNOW OF ALL THE WONDERFUL
THINGS OUT THERE BECAUSE OF OF
DIMINISH SOCIAL CAPITAL.
IN THEIR SCHOOLS AND PART OF
WHAT A GOOD ARTS EDUCATION DOES
IS IS PROVIDE THEM WITH INSIGHTS
INTO NEW THINGS THAT THEY CAN
MOVE INTO.
CAREER WISE THAT THEY MAY NOT
HAVE KNOWN ABOUT.
I CERTAINLY IS A LEGISLATURE
WE'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY HARD --
WITH THROUGH THE BUDGET PROCESS
AND IT'S IT'S HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW AS AS WE SPEAK -- I HOPE
THAT MY COLLEAGUES I SHARE MY
SUPPORT FOR THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED TEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
PERMANENT INCREASED FUNDING FOR
THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL IS
PRESENTED IN THE MAY REVISED --
THIS WILL BRING FUNDING LEVELS
UP TO AN ESTIMATED TWENTY SIX
MILLION WHICH IS REALLY.
NOT HIGH ENOUGH BUT CERTAINLY IF
THOSE OF US WHO KNOW THE RECENT
HISTORY KNOW HOW MUCH HIGHER.
THAT WAS THAT IS THEN THAT IN
PREVIOUS YEARS.
I AND SO I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT A COUPLE KEY THINGS WITH ONE
TEN JOBS IN OUR STATE.
AND NOTING THE VALUE IN
EXAMINING OUR OUR STATE I
CREATED A CONNIE TODAY'S HEARING
WILL BE A WAY TO STAY CURRENT
MAIL BE OPPORTUNITY FOR MEMBERS
TO ASK QUESTIONS OF EXPERTS AND
DELVE INTO THE NUMBERS
UNDERSTANDING WHAT IT COULD BE A
QUARTERLY INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
PIECE OF THE ECONOMY -- ARE ARTS
INCREDIBLE COMING OUR WE ALSO
LOOKING TO LOOK INTO ANY
INTERESTING TRENDS WE COULD SEE
IF THERE ARE SEGMENTS OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY THAT ARE
STRUGGLING.
MAYBE THERE'S SOME THINGS THAT
WE CAN BE THINKING ABOUT TERMS
OF POLICIES TO HELP THOSE WHO
ARE -- WHO ARE OR IN TROUBLE NAY
MAYBE LOOK ALSO AT THE EXTENT TO
WHICH OUR STATE POLICIES ARE
LAWS REGULATIONS MAYBE HELPING
OR HURTING -- SO THERE MAY BE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO TO
LEARN ABOUT POTENTIAL BILLS ARE
POLICY CHANGES THAT COULD BE
MADE.
AND HIGHLIGHTING THE TIMELINESS
OF THIS HEARING FROM THE ARTS
EDUCATION PERSPECTIVE WE ALSO --
FOLKS HERE MAY KNOW THAT WE HAVE
NEWLY UPDATED VISUAL PERFORMING
ARTS STANDARDS WHICH INCLUDE
STANDARDS FOR MEDIA ARTS.
AND WE LOOK FOR TO PRESENTATIONS
ON SOME SAMPLE PROGRAMS BUT ALSO
HOW WERE ACTUALLY TRACKING IN
EVALUATING ATS EDUCATIO.
SO THE HOW THE WEAR AND AND AND
WHAT GRADES ART IS BEING OFFERED
AND WHAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IN
OUTCOMES I'M I'M LOOKING FORWARD.
TO GETTING AN UPDATE -- AS TO
WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING.
ON THE VAPID STANDARDS SPACE SO
THAT WILL BE LOOKED AT IN PANEL
TWO SO OUR FIRST PANEL IS A
CREATIVE ECONOMY UPDATE OUR
SECOND ANEL BE FOCUS ON ARTS
EDUCATION AND LOOKING AT THE
PIPELINE IN.
EVALUATING THE CURRENT PIPELINE
AND THEN OUR THIRD PANEL WILL
BRING TOGETHER LOOKING
SPECIFICALLY AT AT MENTORING
CONNECTING INSPIRING YOUTH
THROUGH THE ARTS.
AND SO -- GOT SOME WONDERFUL
SPEAKERS AND SOME WONDERFUL
PALACE IN A LOT OF EXPERTISE IN
THE ROOM AND AS YOU KNOW --
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE CAPITAL
VETERANS MEMBERS WILL BE COMING
IN AND OUT THROUGH THE COURSE OF
THE DAY BUT WE HAVE OUR TOWN
IT'S STAFF HERE A LOT OF PEOPLE
TUNING IN.
ON OUR ON OUR TV'S AND TAKING A
LOT OF NOT SO WE DO APPRECIATE
ARE ONCE PARTICIPATION.
AND I KNOW OUR OUR OUR OUR CHAIR
OF THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
HIS WAY BUT SO NUMBER IF YOU IF
YOU LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT OR
TWO YOU'RE VERY WELCOME ARE ALSO
CAN GET STARTED.
COLIN BUT THE THIS IS SO
IMPORTANT AREA SO WHILE I'M HERE.
AND I HOPE.
I CAN LEARN FROM HERE.
THANK YOU.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT SOME
MEMBER CHOI AND WE APPRECIATE
YOU.
BEING IN YOUR PARTICIPATION SO.
I WHEN WE GET STARTED AND WITH
PANEL NUMBER ONE THIS IS A
CREATIVE ECONOMY UPDATING SO
WE'LL ASK -- WE'RE GONNA ASK
GEOFFREY PERKINS AND BROWN
CRAWFORD ROBERT KLEIN HANSON IN
ALMOST TO HIDE IT TO COME
FORWARD AND AND CROWD HERE.
ON OUR BECAUSE THE LITTLE LITTLE
DIVE.
NOW THIS THIS PANEL MOST
DIRECTLY FOCUS ON THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY AND ITS ECONOMIC IMPACT
FROM A HIGHER LEVEL ON DOWN TO
THE CURRENT NUMBERS.
SEXUAL PERFORMANCE AND TRENDS.
WE'RE ALSO GONNA LOOK IT
PERSPECTIVES FROM OTIS -- WE
COURSE WHICH IS THE THE GREAT
INSTITUTION -- THAT YEAH THAT
THAT THAT LOOKS AT THESE.
AS THESE TRENDS AND THERE IT'S
AN ARTS COLLEGE A TRAINS ARTISAN
CREATIVES FOR JOBS BUT THEY WORK
VERY CLOSELY WITH -- YEAH LA
COUNTY -- AND OTHERS TO TO TO
TRACK THE CREATIVE ECONOMY --
WE'RE GONNA HERE OF COURSE FROM
THE C. A. C. TOUGH ARTS COUNCIL
WHICH SPONSORS AND HELPS GUIDE
THE REPORT.
AND AND WE'RE ALSO GOING TO
HIGHLIGHT SOME INNER SEXUALITY
IN THEIR WORK AND THEN ENDEAVOR
WHICH REPRESENTS THE TOP
CREATIVE INDUSTRY EMPLOYMENT
SECTOR -- YOU KNOW ANY
ENTERTAINMENT ON ON THE ON THE
ON THE AGENCY SIDE AND ON
CRITTER PRESENTATION SIDE SO
LET'S START WITH GEOFFREY
PERKINS IS VICE PRESIDENT.
OF OTIS COLLEGE OF ART AND
DESIGN YOU'RE VERY WELCOME AND
AND I WILL SAY THAT.
JEFFREY WORKS IN ONE OF THE
FINDS PLACES IN THE STATE.
TWENTY SIX SENATE DISTRICTS ARE
YOU.
ONE THANK YOU CENTER ISLAND --
AND MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS AND
INVITED GUESTS AND THANK YOU FOR
THE OPORTUNITY TO SHARE SOME
THOUGHTS -- AT THIS HEARING.
BEFORE WE HEAR FROM OTHERS --
WITH PERSPECTIVES AND INSIGHTS
ON THE STATE WIDE CRATER ECONOMY.
I'D LIKE TO SHARE SOME OF THE
BROADER CONTEXT OF THE LOTUS
REPORT ON THE CRAVE ECONOMY AND
ITS EVOLUTION AS A CRITICAL TOOL.
FOR UNDERSTANDING THE WAYS IN
WHICH THE LARGER ECONOMY IS
INTRICATELY CONNECTED TO A
CREATIVE.
ONE THIS REPORT HAS BEEN
CHRONICLING THE GROWTH AND
BREADTH OF THE CRATER ECONOMY
OVER THE LAST TWELVE YEARS AND
IT WAS STARTED BY A FORMER
PRESIDENT SAMUEL H<c.cyan>.</c>
WHO WANTED TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
THE TRUE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF A
CREATIVE ECONOMY?
THE COMMISSION THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
CORPORATION TO BENCHMARK MEASURE
AND ASSESS TRENDS IN THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY IN THE LOS
ANGELES AND ORANGE COUNTY REGION.
THE RESEARCH FOCUSED ON SPECIFIC
CREATIVE SECTORS.
IN ART DESIGN ENTERTAINMENT AND
ARTS EDUCATION I MEASURE THEIR
DIRECT INDIRECT IN INDUCED
ECONOMIC IMPACT.
FOLLOWING SUPPORT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL THIS
ECONOMIC ANALYSIS WITH EXTENDED
BEYOND LOS ANGELES TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA LONG LONG
RECOGNIZED AS A GLOBAL LEADER
FOR CREATIVITY AND INNOVATION.
THIS YEAR WE HAVE NEW QUESTIONS
AND COMMISSION BEGIN ECONOMICS
TO RESEARCH AND WRITE THE REPORT
AND YOU'LL SOON HEAR FROM ROBERT
KLEIN HANDS ABOUT THE NEW
FINDINGS.
THIS REPORT HAS BEEN DOWNLOADED
BY PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE
UNITED STATES AND THIRTY SEVEN
OTHER COUNTRIES INCLUDING
AUSTRALIA ARGENTINA CANADA CHINA
COLOMBIA ESTONIA FRANCE GONNA.
INDIA INDONESIA IRAN.
RUSSIA SOUTH AFRICA AND THAILAND
TO NAME JUST A FEW IT'S FAIR TO
SAY THAT CALIFORNIA AND ITS
CREDIT ECONOMY ARE FRONT AND
CENTER IN A GLOBAL CONVERSATION.
GIVE YOU A BROADER CONTEXT AND
SET LIGHT ON WHY OTIS BECAUSE OF
OUR DESIGN WOULD COMMISSION THIS
REPORT I FIRST.
I SHOULD FOR SHARE SOME KEY
INFORMATION ABOUT THE COLLEGE.
THIS YEAR WE CELEBRATE OUR
CENTENNIAL THAT'S A HUNDRED
YEARS OF EDUCATING ARTISTS AND
DESIGNERS AND LOS ANGELES.
IT WAS BEGUN AS A COUNTY
INSTITUTION AND AND AND IS NOW A
PRIVATE NONPROFIT COLLEGE.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO PREPARE
DIVERSE STUDENTS OF ARE DESIGNED
TO ENRICH OUR WORLD THROUGH
THEIR CREATIVITY SKILL AND
VISION.
OUR ALUMNI AND FACULTY ARE
FULBRIGHT MACARTHUR GUGGENHEIM
GRANT RECIPIENTS OSCAR AWARD
THESE LEGENDARY COSTUME
DESIGNERS LEADERS OF
CONTEMPORARY ART MOVEMENTS
ENTREPRENEURS ARTISTS AND
DESIGNERS.
APPLE PICKS ARE MET MATTEL NIKE
AND DISNEY TO NAME A FEW.
THIS WEEKEND WE GRADUATED OVER
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY STUDENTS
FROM SEVEN BFA PROGRAMS IN
ARCHITECTURE LANDSCAPE INTERIORS
GREAT.
COMMUNICATION ARTS DIGITAL MEDIA
FASHION FINE ARTS PRODUCT DESIGN
TôI DESIGN AND FROM THREE
GRADUATE PROGRAMS AND FINE ARTS
AND ON THE EVE OF COMMENCEMENT
WE HOLD OUR ANNUAL EXHIBITION
WHEN WE INVITE THE PUBLIC
RECRUITERS ALUMNI AND FAMILIES
THE CAMPUS FOR TWO DAYS. TO MEET
OUR GRADUATING STUDENTS TO SEE
THEIR CULMINATING WORK AND TO
LEARN MORE ABOUT THEIR
EXPERIENCE.
I TOOK THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
THEM THEIR THOUGHTS ON THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE NEWEST MEMBERS OF IT THE
ONES THAT WE'VE MOST RECENTLY
TRAIN TO GO OUT INTO IT.
WE KNOW THAT WITHIN A YEAR 92%
OF THEM WILL HAVE A WILL BE
EMPLOYED IN THEIR CHOSEN FIELD
OF STUDY.
THE QUESTION I POSED TO EACH OF
THE STUDENTS WAS WHETHER THEY
KNEW THEIR FUTURE FIELD EXISTED
WHEN THEY WERE IN HIGH SCHOOL.
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY
SAID NO.
MOST HAD LIMITED EXPOSURE FROM
HIGH SCHOOL ART COURSES AND
PAINTING AND DRAWING ONLY THOSE
STUDENTS READ PARENTS IN
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES NEW THESE
CRAZY EXISTED.
AND THEN I ASKED WHAT THEY WISH
THEY HAD KNOWN. ONE STUDENT AND
IN PRODUCT DESIGN TOLD ME SHE'D
TAKEN NO FORMAL ART COURSES IN
HIGH SCHOOL BEFORE ENROLLING IN
OTIS.
AND UNDER STANDING OF THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES WERE LIMITED
TO FINE ARTS AND GRAPHIC DESIGN.
SHE TOLD ME IN HIGH SCHOOL I
WISH I KNEW THAT EVERYTHING
AROUND US WAS DESIGNED.
BY SOMEONE THAT THE WORLD IS
BUILT ON DESIGN.
A SIMILAR SENTIMENT WAS SHARED
BY ERICA AND TOY DESIGN WHO
ALWAYS LOVE TOY STORES BUT NEVER
THOUGHT OF THE PEOPLE BEHIND
THEM DESIGNING THE TOYS.
THAT LINED THE SHELVES.
WHEN I AS LUKE AND DIGITAL MEDIA?
HE TOLD ME I WISH I'D KNOWN
THERE WAS AN INDUSTRY FOR WHAT I
WAS INTERESTED IN DOING OR
MATTHEW HIS COLLEAGUES WHO SAID
MORE SPECIFICALLY I WISH I KNEW
THAT MOTION DESIGN EXISTED.
AND WITHIN MOTION DESIGNED THAT
THERE IS A DIVERSITY OF STYLES
TO WORK WITH AND WHEN I ASKED
WHAT THEY WANTED ME TO TELL YOU
QUINCY AND COMMUNICATION ARTS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND EARLY THAT OUR IS NOT
LIMITED TO SHOWING IN A GALLERY.
OR IN THE WHO SUGGESTED DESIGN
COURSES BE OFFERED IN HIGH
SCHOOL.
WE HAVE ANSWERED THE QUESTION OF
WHETHER THE CREATIVE ECONOMY AS
ECONOMICALLY SIGNIFICANT IT IS.
NOW WE MUST ASK HOW WE'RE
PREPARING YOUNG PEOPLE FOR IT
THESE INCREASINGLY IMPORTANT NEW
ROLES.
NOT ONLY TO UNDERSTAND HOW WE
CAN SUPPORT MORE ARTS EDUCATION
IN SCHOOLS.
BUT TO LOOK EVEN DEEPER INTO HOW
WE'RE TEACHING DIVERSE PROBLEM
SOLVING DESIGN PRINCIPLES AND
HOW WE'RE HELPING PARENTS
UNDERSTAND THE MANY PROFESSIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THEY MAY NEVER
HAVE IMAGINED FOR THEIR CHILDREN.
IF PARENTS DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT
THEIR ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITIES AND
CREATIVE FIELDS HOW CAN THEY
SUPPORT THEIR CHILDREN IN
SEEKING THEM.
AND IMAGINE ALL THE CREATIVE
MINDED STUDENTS WHO HAVE LEFT
THE ARTS BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
THAT THERE'S A FUTURE FOR THEM
THERE.
WE KNOW CALIFORNIA LEADS THE
NATION IN ITS CREATIVE ECONOMY
NOW WE HAVE TO ASK WHETHER IT
WILL BE THE NATION PREPARING OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE FOR A TRULY
REMARKABLE CAREER OPPORTUNITIES.
THANK YOU TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL WHO HAVE HELPED US WITH
THE STATEWIDE ANALYSIS.
AND THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THIS HEARING.
I WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM -- AND
BROWN CRAWFORD IS THE DIRECTOR
OF COVER ARTS COUNCIL AND YOU'RE
SO WELCOME.
WE'RE EXCITED ABOUT THE SUMMER
FUNDING.
AS WE ALL ARE.
YEAH -- GOOD MORNING. TO ALL OF
YOU.
APPEAR -- THANK YOU FOR
CONVENING THIS HEARING TODAY AND
FOR FRAMING AND THE WAY THAT
IT'S FRAMED.
AND AND FOR ALL THAT YOU DO TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN
BENEFIT.
FROM THE POWER OF CREATIVE
EXPRESSION AND THE ARTS I'M AND
BOUND CRAWFORD EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL.
AT THE ARTS COUNCIL WE SAY
CREATIVITY IS CALIFORNIANS.
WE SAY THIS BECAUSE ARTS AND
CULTURE ARE CENTRAL TO WHAT
MAKES SAYS CALIFORNIANS CENTRAL
TO OUR IDENTITIES TO OUR
COMMUNITY VIBRANCY.
INTO OUR RESILIENCE AS A PEOPLE
LIVING IN SOCIETY TODAY WITH ALL
OF ITS CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITY.
WE ALSO SAY CREATIVITY IS
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE WERE
PRIVILEGED TO LIVE IN A STATE
WITH ELECTED LEADERS WHO DEEPLY
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF THE ARTS.
AND TO UTILIZE THE ARTS AS A
TOOL TO SERVE OUR STATE.
THANK YOU.
THE FIRST ARTIST REPORT
STATEWIDE ASSESSMENT WAS FUNDED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ARTS COUNCIL
FIVE YEARS AGO.
THE REGIONAL AND STATEWIDE DATA
FROM THAT OTIS REPORT FEATURES
AND ECONOMIC ANALYSIS THAT
RESONATES WITH POLICYMAKERS
COMMUNITY ACTIVISTS AND OTHER
FUNDERS WHO PROVIDE CRUCIAL
SUPPORT TO CALIFORNIA'S CULTURAL
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE DATA IS INVALUABLE WHEN
SHARED HAND IN HAND WITH STORIES
OF CHANGE PRESERVATION AND
RESILIENCE FOR OUR COMMUNITIES.
AS WE WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO EXPERIENCE IN TODAY'S HEARING.
WHEN THE FIRST STATEWIDE
CREATIVE ECONOMY REPORT WAS
PUBLISHED FIVE YEARS AGO OUR
STATE GOVERNMENT INVESTED JUST
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN THE ARTS?
AS YOU KNOW THAT NUMBER HAS
GROWN BY MILLIONS EACH YEAR
SINCE AND HOPEFULLY -- KEEP
GROWING.
I JUST THROW THEM -- QUANTIFYING
THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
CALIFORNIA'S CREATIVE ECONOMY
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE CATALYST FOR
THIS LONG AWAITED RESURGENCE IN
STATE ARTS REPORT SUPPORT.
CALIFORNIA'S CREATIVE ECOSYSTEM
IS UNLIKE THAT OF ANY OTHER
STATE OR NATION.
WE KNOW THAT LIKE ANY ECOSYSTEM
OUR CREATIVE ECOSYSTEM THRIVES
BECAUSE OF ALL COMMUNITIES IN
THE STATE.
OUR CITIES ARE HUBS OF
INNOVATION AND CREATIVE
RESILIENCE WHERE THE ARTS ARE
USED AS A TOOL TO PRESERVE THE
PLACE OF ARTISTS AND CULTURAL
COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR RAPIDLY GROWING URBAN
ENVIRONMENTS.
AND OUR RURAL COMMUNITIES ARE
KNOWN INCUBATORS OF CREATIVE
IDEAS AND TODAY THEY ARE A PLACE
WHERE SOME ARTISTS AND CREATIVE
INDIVIDUALS PURSUE A MORE
ATTAINABLE QUALITY OF LIFE.
FINDING INSPIRATION FROM
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL BEAUTY OR
JUST A CHANGE OF PERSPECTIVE.
OUR CREATIVE ECOSYSTEM ALSO
DEPENDS GREATLY ON THE SECTORS
THAT IS COMPRISED OF THERE ARE
FIVE SECTORS DEFINED IN THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY REPORT.
INCLUDING OF COURSE.
NONPROFIT ARTS AND CULTURE AND
ARTS EDUCATION.
COMMUNITY ARTS PROGRAMS ARE WERE
AND THEN TAKE CULTURE THRIVES.
THEY ARE THE CORE OF OUR
PIPELINE IN TALENT THEY ARE WERE
SMALL AND MID SIZE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE OF THE COMMUNITIES THEY
SERVE.
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES FACING
CALIFORNIANS TODAY THROUGH THE
ARTS.
THIS IS A SEGMENT OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY THAT I AM NOT
SURPRISINGLY VERY INTERESTED IN
AS THE HEAD OF A STATE ARTS
AGENCY.
WHERE MORE THAN 70% OF OUR
CURRENT GRANTEES ARE
ORGANIZATIONS WITH THE BUDGET
UNDER ONE MILLION DOLLARS?
BUT AS AN ARTS EDUCATOR WITH
MORE THAN FORTY YEARS OF
EXPERIENCE I GOT.
TO TAKE THAT NUMBER OUT AND WITH
MANY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE.
WORKING WITH STUDENTS WHO ENTER
THE CREATIVE WORK FOR US AS
DESIGNERS.
ANIMATORS ILLUSTRATORS AND
ENGINEERS I BELIEVE DEEPLY IN
THE STRENGTH OF THE
INTERSECTIONS OF OUR CREATIVE
SECTORS.
BUILDING ARTS EDUCATION MODELS
HAS BEEN A HALLMARK OF MY CAREER.
THE MOST EFFECTIVE MODELS HAVE
BEEN PARTNERSHIPS BASED ON
COLLABORATION WITH AN
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND IN
COMMUNITY ART CENTERS.
AND BUSINESS SETTINGS THAT CAN
ALL CONNECT TO THE ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT OF A REGION AND OF
THE STATE OVERALL.
THESE PARTNERSHIPS CONCENTRATE
ON ROBUST TO LEARNING AND THE
TRANSFERABLE SKILLS NEEDED TO
PROMOTE INNOVATION.
ECONOMIC GROWTH AND CREATIVITY.
THIS IS THE SAME TYPE OF WORK I
NOW GET TO DO IN MY ROLE AS HEAD
OF THE ARTS COUNCIL.
SUPPORT FOR ARTS EDUCATION IS
ONE OF THE LONGEST STANDING
EFFORTS BY THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL DATING ALL THE WAY BACK
TO NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WHEN THE
AGENCY WAS FIRST FORMED.
CURRENT GRANT PROGRAM OFFERINGS
HELP FUND TEACHING ARTISTS IN
THE CLASSROOMS STUDENT FIELD
TRIPS TO ARTS AND CALL.
OTHER CULTURAL EXPERIENCES AND
ARTS INTEGRATION TRAINING FOR
TEACHERS.
AND THIS YEAR THROUGH OUR NEWEST
PROGRAM YOUTH ARTS ACTION WE
WILL EXPAND THAT SUPPORT TO
YOUTH DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS FROM AGES.
ZERO TO TWENTY FOUR WE RECEIVE A
HUGE DEMAND. FOR OUR ARTS
EDUCATION GRANTS EVERY YEAR.
ARTS EDUCATION PLAYS A CENTRAL
ROLE IN BUILDING THE PIPELINE
FOR CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE CREATIVE
ECONOMY. FOR ME MEANING FOR
CREATIVE EDUCATION SYSTEM THE
CENTER OF SO MUCH IT TOUCHES
EVERY ASPECT OF OUR WORK AT THE
ARTS COUNCIL WHETHER IT'S IN
CORRECTIONS.
CULTURAL DISTRICTS OR SUPPORTING
COMMUNITY ARTS ORGANIZATIONS IT
SAYS THAT THE CENTER OF A
HEALTHY COMMUNITY OVERALL.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT TODAY'S
HEARING IS ABOUT AT THE CORE
BUILDING HEALTHY AND RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES STARTING WITH OUR
USE.
IT'S MY HONOR TO BE HERE TODAY
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO LISTENING
ALONG WITH YOU TO THE
TESTIMONIES OF MY COLLEAGUES AND
COMMUNITY LEADERS. FOR THIS
SPECIAL HEARING.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
COMMITMENT TO ENSURING THAT ALL
CALIFORNIANS CAN BENEFIT FROM
THE POWER OF CREATIVE EXPRESSION
AND THE ARTS -- OKAY
[inaudible]
OKAY.
SELECT RENEE HERE FROM -- ROBERT
KLEIN AND SEES -- GET A PRESENT.
THIS POWER POINT EASY THE CARD
FROM BEACON ECONOMICS.
AND ALSO UC RIVERSIDE SCHOOL
BUSINESS CENTER AT THEIR CENTER
FOR ECONOMIC FORECASTING AND
HE'S.
I THINK ANY GIVE US THE MOST.
DATA HEAVY OF ALL THE
PRESENTATIONS ARE HERE TO ASSIST
ME A LITTLE LONGER -- BUT A LOT
OF GREAT STUFF IN HERE AT A
CHANCE TO REVIEW SOME OF THE
MATERIALS AND OUR REALLY LOOKING
FOR TO TO TO WHAT YOU FOUND.
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU TO
ALL MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
INVITING US TO COME AND SPEAK
TODAY -- ABOUT THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY.
IN A COURSE OUR THANKS FROM
BEACON -- TO THE CALIFORNIA ARTS
COUNCIL AND TO OTIS COLLEGE --
FOR HAVING US DO THIS THIS
RESEARCH ON BEHALF OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY THIS IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PROJECT IN MY OPINION --
SO SEVERAL YEARS AGO WHEN I WAS
THE CHIEF ECONOMIST AT THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION OR THE
LED SEE THAT WAS WHEN THE IDEA.
CAME UP OUT OF DOING A STUDY OF
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY AT THE
STATE LEVEL -- AND AND THERE'S
STILL SO MUCH TO DO IN THIS VEIN
BUT WILL CONTINUE TO PLUG AWAY --
AND ALSO -- YEARS AGO AND AND
HAS JOBS I HAD OCCASION TO GO UP
AND DOWN THE STATE THROUGH
TRAVELS AND AND TO SEE AND
CITIES AND COMMUNITIES LARGE AND
SMALL HOW THE ARTS.
BUT IT'S A COMMUNITY THEATER OR
SOME OTHER MANIFESTATION REALLY
IS A PART OF EACH AND EVERY
COMMUNITY HERE.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE LARGE AND
SMALL SO -- LET ME SEE IF I CAN
GET THE TECHNOLOGY TO WORK IF
THAT WAS THE WRONG BUTTON TO
PRESS [inaudible]
SORRY.
THANK YOU OKAY SO -- I'M LOOKING
FOR TO PRESENT THE FINDINGS OF
THIS MOST RECENT -- OTIS --
REPORT ON THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
SO WHEN WE THINK ABOUT -- THE
THE ARTS -- WE THINK OF FINE
ARTS PERFORMING ARTS AND SO ON
AND THE EDUCATION ASPECT BUT IN
THIS.
CONTEXT OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
WE'RE GONNA STRETCHER THINKING
GO BEYOND THE ARCH TO COMMERCIAL
APPLICATIONS OF DESIGN AND
CREATIVITY.
WE'RE NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT THE
ARTS AS WE COMMONLY.
THINK OF THEM WERE THINKING ALSO
ABOUT INDUSTRIES WHERE.
DESIGNING CREATIVITY IS -- IS AT
AN ESSENTIAL ELEMENT OR AN
ESSENTIAL INGREDIENT. TO WHAT
THEY DO SO WE'RE GOING TO BE
LOOKING AS WELL NOT JUST AT THE
DESIGN BUT ALSO.
THE MANUFACTURE OF PRODUCTS OR
THE PRODUCTION OF SERVICES AS
WELL AS THE DISTRIBUTION SOME
CASES -- BECAUSE THE LINES BLUR
WHEN WE TAKE A LOOK AT
INDIVIDUAL INDUSTRIES -- IT WHEN
WITH RESPECT TO EACH OF THESE
DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF OF THESE
INDUSTRIES WILL LOOK AT THE
STATE AND TO A LESSER EXTENT TO
THE REGIONAL -- WE ALSO ROLLED
IN TO THIS REPORT -- MORE ABOUT
CREATIVE OCCUPATIONS -- SLICING
AND DICING -- THE BREAK DOWN BY --
WOMEN'S PARTICIPATION -- ETHNIC
PARTICIPATION SO.
ONE SO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THAT EVEN TWENTY MINUTES IS NOT
ENOUGH TO TO REALLY SUMMARIZE A
TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY SOME ODD
PAGE REPORT -- AND THEN LAST BUT
NOT LEAST THERE'S THIS BROADER
ECO SYSTEM -- INVOLVING ARTS
EDUCATION THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SUPPORTED THE GOVERNMENT ITSELF --
THEY WILL TALK ABOUT AS WELL SO.
WE JUST WANT TO SAY WE'RE REALLY
PROJECT OF THE REPORT CAME TO US
UNREDACTED.
ALL ABOUT -- TRANSPARENCY.
SO IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
THIS REPORT FROM YEARS PAST
THERE WERE SOMEWHERE ELEVEN OR
TWELVE IN THIS LARGE INDUSTRY
GROUPS WE CONSOLIDATED.
THOSE GROUPS INTO FIVE THIS TIME
AROUND I THINK THEIR SELF
EXPLANATORY WHAT YOU SEE UP HERE
ON THE SCREEN WE'VE GOT
ARCHITECTURE AND RELATED
SERVICES -- ENTERTAINMENT AND
DIGITAL MEDIA FASHION.
FINE AND PERFORMING ARTS AND
THEN WE HAVE THIS THING CALLED
CREATIVE GOODS AND PRODUCTS
WHICH MIGHT BE THE MOST -- HARD
TO DIGEST BUT THIS IS REALLY --
FURNISHINGS LIGHTING A WHOLE
ARRAY OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW
GOING TO OUR HOMES FOR EXAMPLE.
AS WELL AS TOYS WHICH YOU KNOW
THAT'S ABIG PART OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY AS WELL -- SO
THERE ARE OVER SIXTY INDUSTRIES
THAT MAKE UP THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY AND THEY BREAK DOWN I
KNOW THIS IS HARD TO READ BUT
THEY BREAK DOWN ROUGHLY -- HALF
BEING IN ENTERTAINMENT AND
DIGITAL MEDIA -- THEN WE HAVE A
NUMBER IN THAT CREATIVE GOODS
AND PRODUCTS CATEGORY FASHION IS
PROMINENT -- DOWN BELOW IN THE
BOTTOM RIGHT YOU HAVE
ARCHITECTURE RELATED SERVICES
AND THEN FINE AND PERFORMING
ARTS -- SO.
BIG PICTURE -- WE HAVE ABOUT
EIGHTY THOUSAND ESTABLISHMENTS
BASED ON DATA FROM THE BUREAU OF
LABOR STATISTICS THAT ARE
CLASSIFIED AS CREATIVE NOW THIS
IS A GOOD TIME FOR ME TO STOP
AND SAY WELL.
HOW DID WE ARRIVE AT THIS LIST
OF INDUSTRIES THAT?
WE CONSIDER TO BE CREATIVE --
THERE'S REALLY NO STANDARD --
ANYWHERE IN ACADEMIC OR OTHER
LITERATURE THAT ESTABLISHES. ONE
SET OF INDUSTRIES TO BE --
CONSTITUTED AS CREATIVE OR NOT
BUT WE'VE BEEN DOING THIS A
WHILE WE WE DID LITERATURE
REVIEW SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND WE
DID IT AGAIN THIS YEAR TO
DETERMINE WHICH INDUSTRIES --
ARE TYPICALLY CONSIDERED BEING A
PART OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY AND
WE USE THAT AS THE BASIS FOR
IDENTIFYING INDUSTRIES IN
OFFICIAL GOVERNMENT DATA -- BY
INDUSTRY CODE AGGREGATING THEM
INTO THESE -- THESE CATEGORIES
AND THEN WE CAME UP WITH THESE
ESTABLISHMENT EMPLOYEE AND AND
THAT SHOULD BE AVERAGE.
AVERAGE ANNUAL WAGE -- NUMBERS
THAT YOU SEE HERE FOR THE STATE
AS A WHOLE EIGHTY THOUSAND
ESTABLISHMENTS MOSTLY IN
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL MEDIA.
OVER A MILLION -- WAGE AND
SALARY WORKERS SO -- AN ASTERISK
ON THAT POINT IS THAT WE DO NOT
HAVE THE THE INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTORS -- TO FREELANCERS
AND SO ON INCLUDED IN THAT
NUMBER BUT IT'S ALSO
SIGNIFICANTLY LARGER IT'S JUST
COMES FROM A DIFFERENT DATA
SOURCE.
AND THE THE PAYROLL NUMBERS I
APOLOGIZE IT SHOULD BE AVERAGE
WAGE AND HAD JUST FOR REFERENCE
IT'S A HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IS THE AVERAGE WAGE --
FOR THE CREATIVE INDUSTRIES
WHICH IS CONSIDERABLY HIGHER
THAN THE SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLAR AVERAGE WAGE.
FOR ALL WORKERS IN CALIFORNIA IN
THE PERIOD.
TWO THOUSAND IT'S ONE OH TWO
RATHER THAN.
ONE THIRTY FOUR OKAY -- SO.
IN TERMS OF THE INDUSTRIES AND
THEIR CHANGES OVER TIME YOU CAN
SEE THAT -- FEW INDUSTRIES HAVE
SEEN GROWTH IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF ESTABLISHMENTS OVER
TIME SOME HAVE SEEN DECLINE AT
THE VERY TOP YOU GET
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL MEDIA.
THINK ABOUT THIS.NEXUS BETWEEN TECHNOLOGY AND AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL ALL
THINGS DIGITAL THESE DAYS A
LARGE SHARE OF THE GROWTH IN THE
STATEWIDE ECONOMY OVER THE PAST
SEVERAL YEARS HAS COME FROM THE
TECH SECTOR.
AND IT SPILLED OVER INTO THIS
ENTERTAINMENT SECTOR THAT WE
HAVE HERE SO 22% GROWTH IN
ESTABLISHMENT SO -- IN THAT
SECTOR AND THEN OTHERS GROWTH
THAT WE'RE SEEING HERE FOR
EXAMPLE WITH CREATIVE GOODS AND
AND ARTS AND ARCHITECTURE.
HAVE TO DO WITH THE ECONOMIC
CYCLE AND HAVE TO DO WITH GROWTH
IN CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITY.
SO.
YOU CAN TAKE A LOOK AT EACH ONE
OF THESE INDUSTRIES WHERE
INDUSTRY GROUPS AND YOU CAN KIND
OF FIGURE OUT WELL HOW MUCH OF
THIS IS DUE -- TO UNDER --
UNDERLYING TRENDS IN THE ECONOMY
HOW MUCH OF THIS IS THESE
CHANGES ARE DUE TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING UNIQUELY TO THAT
INDUSTRY -- FASHION IS HEAVILY
WEIGHTED TOWARD MANUFACTURING
AND MANUFACTURING HAS LOST BOTH
ESTABLISHMENT IN EMPLOYMENT.
OVER THE LAST -- SEVERAL DECADES
REALLY SO -- TO BE FLAT OVER
THIS TIME PERIOD IS IS NOT ALL
THAT BAD.
AND CREATIVE IN GOOD CREATIVE
GOODS AND PRODUCTS ALSO A
MANUFACTURING HEAVY SECTOR OF
THE ECONOMY SO WE'RE SAYING JOBS
BEING DISPLACED BY TECHNOLOGY.
MAYBE MOVING OVERSEAS BUT MORE
SO DISPLACEMENT BY TECHNOLOGY SO
INTO THE ESTABLISHMENT COUNTS
LOWER COMPARED -- 220-002-00010.
JOB CANCER GENERALLY HIGHER WITH
THE EXCEPTION OF FASHION --
CONSIDERING WHAT -- WE HAVE SEEN --
IT OVER THE LAST SEVERAL DECADES
BUT THESE OTHER SECTORS ECONOMY
OVER THIS TIME PERIOD WHICH
ARGUABLY IS RIGHT.
AT THE BEGINNING OF THE ECONOMIC
RECOVERY -- WE HAVE SEEN GROWTH --
TO VARYING DEGREES AND IT'S IT'S
GUEST JUDGE JOBS ARE OF
MANUFACTURING JOBS ARE IN
GENERAL ARE IN DECLINE -- SO
IT'S NOT JUST MANUFACTURING BUT
EVEN AEROSPACE FOR EXAMPLE AND
SOME OF THOSE JOBS ARE BEING
DISPLACED BY TECHNOLOGY SOME OF
MY JUST MOVING OUT OF STATE
BECAUSE OF HIGHER WAGES.
OR MAYBE MOVING OUT OF COUNTRY.
SO THAT'S SEE THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENING WITH FASHION WE STILL
HAVE THE DESIGN ASPECT IS
PRESENT IN.
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR.
OVERALL CREATED ECONOMY JOB
GROWTH IS ACTUALLY EXCEEDED THE
NON CREATIVE SIDE OF THE ECONOMY
24% OVER THIS TIME SPAN.
VERSUS ABOUT 21% EVEN
ESTABLISHMENT GROWTH AND OVERALL
HE'S BEEN SLIGHTLY FASTER THAN
THE THE NON CREATIVE SIDE OF THE
ECONOMY.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE THAT'S THE
RIGHT TERM TO USE FOR THE REST
OF THE WORLD BUT CREE WITH.
FOR YOU KNOW BIFURCATING AN TO
CREATE A NON CREATED FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIS PRESENTATION.
WAGE GROWTH HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
IN THE CREATIVE SECTOR OF THE
ECONOMY AGAIN YOU SAW EARLIER
THAT ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
THOUSAND WAGE NUMBER IT SHOULD
OF AND ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
I APOLOGIZE FOR THE FOR THEIR
AND SO YOU'VE ALREADY SEEN
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL MEDIA.
IS PLAYING A BIG ROLE IN THIS
GROWTH AND IT'S WHAT AND IT'S
NOT JUST WHAT OUR KIDS ARE DOING
TODAY.
ALTHOUGH YOU CAN SEE UP ON THE
SCREEN WHAT THEY'RE DOING -- BUT
WHAT SO MANY PEOPLE AND SO MANY
GENERATIONS -- OF OF
CALIFORNIANS AND AROUND THE
WORLD ARE DOING TODAY WE'VE GOT.
WHAT WE'RE CALLING DIGITAL
DESTRUCTION IS ENTERTAINMENT --
VIRTUAL REALITY IS MAKING ITS
WAY INTO A NUMBER OF INDUSTRIES
AT THIS TIME -- ANY NUMBER OF
OTHER KINDS OF ASPECTS OF WHAT
MAYBE ORIGINATED AS SOME ASPECT
OF OF ENTERTAINMENT HAVE MADE
THEIR WAY INTO OTHER INDUSTRIES
AND ARE AFFECTING OTHER
INDUSTRIES IN THIS IS JUST THE
THE BEGINNING.
I WOULD SAY OF A TRANSFER MAYES
TRANSFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
OCCURRING SO WHEN WE LOOK ACROSS
THE STATE GEOGRAPHICALLY -- A
LITTLE OVER HALF OF THE JOBS.
IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY ARE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS A
LA IN ORANGE COUNTY -- AND THEN
ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT PERCENTAGE
ABOUT A THIRD OR IN THE BAY AREA.
THEN YOU HAVE JOBS ELSEWHERE
THROUGHOUT THE OTHER REGIONS OF
THE STATE AS WELL -- UPSTATE
CALIFORNIA'S WHERE WE WILL START
BECAUSE IT PROBABLY -- RARELY
GETS.
FIRST BILLING HAS ABOUT SIXTEEN
HUNDRED JOBS IN WHAT WE HAVE TO
FIND TO BE THE CREATIVE ECONOMY.
YOU'LL SEE AND WHEN WE LOOK AT
EACH OF THESE THAT -- THERE'S
SOME PRETTY COMMON TREND
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL MEDIA
TENDS TO BE MAKE UP A LARGER
SHARE FOLLOWED BY -- CREATIVE
GOODS AND PRODUCTS.
ENTERTAINMENT DIGITAL MEDIA.
ACROSS THE REGIONS OF THE STATE
GENERALLY HAVE BEEN ADDING JOBS
ALTHOUGH YOU'LL SEE BY LOOKING
AT THE RIGHT HAND SIDE.
THAT THIS -- PART OF THE STATE
ACTUALLY LOST JOBS AND I THINK
THAT'S PROBABLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO
THE LOSS OF TRADITIONAL MEDIA
BECAUSE WE HAVE.
AMONG OTHER THINGS OF NEWSPAPERS.
AND THAT TYPE OF TRADITIONAL
MEDIA IS A PART OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL MEDIA --
CATEGORY.
CULINARY ARTS PART OF THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY IS A GREAT
QUESTION WE'VE BEEN BANDING THAT
AROUND AND THOSE OF US WHO ENJOY
FOOD THINK IT'S WORTH.
THINKING ABOUT IT AND SO WE'LL
HAVE TO SEE WHETHER THERE ARE
SOME OTHER INDUSTRIES AS AND
YEAH -- SO THAT CERTAINLY IS IS
A CANDIDATE FOR FUTURE RESEARCH --
AND IN MY OWN COMMUNITY THERE A
HIGH SCHOOL A MAGNET HIGH SCHOOL
THAT WAS JUST ESTABLISHED FOR
THE PURPOSE OF CULINARY ARTS AND
HOSPITALITY [inaudible]
SO -- YOU'LL NOTICE THE FINE
ARTS AND PERFORMING ARTS IS UP
WHICH IS A GOOD SIGN THIS ABOUT
SIXTEEN HUNDRED JOBS IN THIS
AREA OF MOVING ALONG -- WE MOVED.
TO THE CAPITAL REGION ARE HOME
TO A LITTLE OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
JOBS AGAIN HEAVILY WEIGHTED
TOWARD ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL
MEDIA ALSO THE AREA WHERE WE'VE
SEEN.
THE GREATEST GROWTH OCCUR -- AND
AND I COULD SPEND TIME ON EACH
ONE OF THESE -- AGAIN AS A TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR PAGE REPORT
SO -- UNFORTUNATELY I CAN'T TALK
ABOUT EACH AND EVERY DETAIL OF
THE BAY AREA WELL OVER A COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND JOBS IN THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY -- AND YOU CAN
YOU KNOW WHAT'S IN THAT 70% OF
ENTERTAINMENT DIGITAL MEDIA IS
THERE ARE PARTS OF WHAT WE WOULD
CONSIDER TO BE TACK.
THAT ALSO BELIEVE OVER INTO THIS
SECTOR OF THE THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY AS WELL AS THESE OTHER
CATEGORIES -- THAT YOU SEE HERE.
JOB.
ABOUT.
THE AND THOSE WHO ARE A SOLE
PROPRIETOR SO IN THESE FIGURES
YOU'RE SAYING JUST A WAGE AND
SALARY EMPLOYEES -- THERE IS
THERE ARE SEPARATE BREAK OUT OF
THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN
THE SELF EMPLOYED IN THE RIVER
IN THE BODY OF THE REPORT ITSELF
[inaudible]
SO -- AGAIN THEN THE CENTRAL
COAST -- HOME TO ABOUT -- TWENTY
THOUSAND CREATIVE SECTOR JOBS --
AGAIN THE PATTERN IS QUITE
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE'VE SEEN
ELSEWHERE -- BUT YOU'RE SEEING
THEIR THAT ARCHITECTURE IS THE
ONE THAT IS LEADING THE WAY IN
TERMS OF JOB GAINS -- AND THEN
WE MOVED TO THE CENTRAL VALLEY.
OF LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT STORY
THERE IS WE'RE SEEING SOME
CONTRACTION IN ENTERTAINMENT.
AND I DON'T MEAN TO BELABOR THE
POINT BUT I THINK IT'S DUE TO
THE DECLINE OF TRADITIONAL MEDIA
IN THESE INSTANCES WHERE IT IS --
SEEING A TO DECREASE THE INLAND
EMPIRE IS AN AREA THAT IS RICH
IN MANUFACTURING SO IT SHOULD BE
NO SURPRISE TO SEE.
THAT FASHION AND CREATIVE GOODS
AND PRODUCTS ARE BOTH -- ON THE
RISE IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA OF
THE STATE -- AND THEN AS WE MOVE
A LITTLE FURTHER ALONG -- TO THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA LA ORANGE
COUNTY REGION HOME TO ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND OF THE ONE
MILLION JOBS IN THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
YOU CAN SEE THAT.
THE LION'S SHARE OF THE GAINS
HAVE OCCURRED IN.
THIS ENTERTAINMENT AND DIGITAL
MEDIA AREA SO YOU KNOW THIS THAT
PARTICULAR CATEGORY HAS REALLY
CHANGED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS -- GONE ARE THE DAYS OF
FILM PRODUCTION GONNA THE DAYS
OF YOU KNOW LARGE SCALE GONE BUT
THEY HAVE TO THEIR NOW MAKING
ROOM FOR SMALLER SCALE
PRODUCTION COMPARED -- TO YEARS
PAST YOU CAN SEE THE FASHION
DECLINE THAT'S MANUFACTURING.
OF SOMEWHAT ARGUE THAT IT MAY BE --
DUE TO THE INCREASES IN THE
MINIMUM WAGE AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL -- BUT THERE WERE
OTHER FORCES ALREADY UNDER WAY
THAT HAVE DRIVEN THAT -- THAT
DECLINE I'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
THAT FOR SEVERAL YEARS -- BUT DO
KEEP IN MIND THAT THE DESIGN
ASPECT CONTINUES TO BE FRONT AND
CENTER IN PLACES LIKE THE BAY
AREA AND IN LA.
IN ORANGE COUNTY BECAUSE IT'S
THAT CREATIVE COMPONENT THAT YOU
KNOW DIFFERENTIATES CALIFORNIA'S.
ECONOMY AND THE SECTORS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY FROM THE REST
OF THE WORLD WE ACTUALLY DO
CHECK. TO SEE HOW WE STACK UP
AGAINST NEW YORK STATE AND I
GUESS THE THE NEW YORK CITY
REGION AND WE CAN SAFELY SAY
WERE THEIR CREATIVE CAPITAL.
OF THE UNITED STATES.
JUST THROW THAT IN WHEN YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ENTERTAINMENT AND
DIGITAL MEDIA ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT BOTH CREATORS LIKE ACTORS
TRADE.
CRAFT.
AND ANCILLARY FOLKS THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO THIS WORK LIKE
WRITERS PRODUCERS AGENTS OR WE
JUST FOCUS OKAY YES HOWEVER -- A
NUMBER OF THE OCCUPATIONS THAT
YOU MENTIONED -- YOU MAY FIND
SOME OF THE HIGH HIGH PROFILE
INDIVIDUALS ARE.
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR THAT
THEY ARE NOT EMPLOYEES OF SOME
ENTITY SO THEY MAY NOT BE
SHOWING UP HERE BUT YOU'RE
PICKING UP WE'RE PICKING UP THE
LINE SURE OF THE INDIVIDUALS.
THERE COMPENSATION AND ALL THAT
SO EVEN IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY WE
SEE CONTINUED GROWTH -- IT
ACROSS THE BOARD AND I I YOU
KNOW WHAT'S IMPORTANT AMONG
OTHER THINGS. FOR ALL OF US HERE
TO SEE IS IT FINEARTS AND
PERFORMING ARTS CONTINUES TO ADD
TO ITS JOB COUNTS.
THIS IS AN AREA THAT IS VERY
MUCH TIED TO THE UPS AND DOWNS
OF ECONOMIC CYCLES --
PHILANTHROPIC ACTIVITIES ALSO
VERY MUCH TIED TO THE UPS AND
DOWNS OF ECONOMIC CYCLES SO.
THE FACT THAT WE ARE NOW SEVERAL
YEARS INTO THIS ECONOMIC
EXPANSION AND WE'RE GENERALLY
SEEING GROWTH IN BOTH THE NUMBER
OF JOBS NUMBER ESTABLISHMENTS.
IN THE FINE ARTS AREA IS.
CERTAINLY GOOD TO SEE YEAH.
PLAY A ROLE IN THE CALCULATION
FOR FINER.
AUCTION HOUSES.
THESE YOU KNOW -- I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHERE THEY HAPPEN TO BE I'M
THINKING THAT THERE AND SOME
PART OF SALES -- OF ART SO.
I HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK THANK YOU
FOR THAT.
WAGES ARE GENERALLY HIGHER IN
EACH OF THE CREATIVE SECTORS --
COMPARED.
TO THE ECONOMY OVERALL THIS
HAPPENS TO BE A COMPARISON OF
CALIFORNIA AGAINST LA COUNTY --
JUST SO YOU CAN SEE OTHER TO
STACK UP AND KEEP IN MIND THAT
THE AVERAGE WAGE BASED ON THE
DATA THAT WERE USING FOR THIS --
REAP MOST OF THIS REPORT THE
AVERAGE WAGE IN CALIFORNIA IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WAS ABOUT SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OKAY SO WE DIDN'T JUST LOOK AT
INDUSTRIES WE ALSO LOOKED AT
OCCUPATIONS AND WE USE A
DIFFERENT DATA SOURCE
SPECIFICALLY ON OCCUPATIONS.
TO CALL THIS OUT AND OUT WHILE
WE DO TALK ABOUT THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY AND AND LARGELY TALK
ABOUT THOSE INDUSTRIES WE ALSO
SPEND TIME IN THE REPORT AND
HERE.
TALKING ABOUT THE OCCUPATIONS
AND OF COURSE.
WITH THIS FIGURE TELLS US IS
THAT.
NOT EVERY INDUSTRY SOME
INDUSTRIES ARE CREATIVE OTHERS
ARE NOT.
SOME OCCUPATIONS ARE CREATIVE
OTHERS ARE NOT I HATE TO SAY IT
THAT WAY -- AND SO.
WHAT YOU FIND IS THAT THERE ARE
CREATIVE OCCUPATIONS IN NON
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AND VICE
VERSA RIGHTS YOU HAVE ACCOUNT --
TO TAKE CARE THE BOOKS FOR LET'S
SAY THE BILLMAHER NICK OUR
ORCHESTRA AND NOW BY THE SAME
TOKEN FOR AN ACCOUNTING FIRM HE
MAY HAVE A GRAPHIC DESIGNER WHO
DESIGNS THE REPORTS AND
PUBLICATIONS AND SO ON SO.
WHERE WE WERE JUST TRYING TO
SPELL THAT OUT AND -- YOU KNOW.
THIS IS SO IMPORTANT I THINK --
YOU KNOW I HAVE COLLEGE AGE KIDS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT THEIR
FUTURE IS GOING TO LOOK LIKE.
AN AFGHAN ANYONE WHO'S THINKING
ABOUT AN OCCUPATION WE WE HEARD
THESE STORIES ABOUT THE RECENT
GRADUATES FROM LOTUS.
YOU KNOW TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHERE THEIR PLACE WILL BE IN
THIS WORLD AND UNDERSTANDING
THAT YOU CAN BE A CREATIVE BUT
MAYBE FIND.
EMPLOYMENT NOT JUST IN THE
CREATIVE SECTOR BUT ELSEWHERE IS
SO IMPORTANT -- TO UNDERSTANDING
THE THE LANDSCAPE [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
YEAH RIGHT.
AND SO VERY QUICKLY THE THE
TRENDS THAT WE IT.
EXAMINE SHOWED THAT -- WE TEND
TO HAVE.
AN INCREASING NUMBER OF HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES AND COLLEGE
GRADUATES IN THE CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES -- OVER TIME WE'VE
SEEN A GROWTH AND GROWTH IN THE
LEVEL OF ACADEMIC ATTAINMENT
AMONG THOSE WORKING IN THE
INDUSTRIES.
AND ALSO IF WE WERE TO COMPARE
THE CREATIVE INDUSTRIES AGAINST
THE NON CREATIVE INDUSTRIES --
WE WOULD FIND HIGHER LEVELS OF
EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT IN THE
CREATIVE INDUSTRIES -- DIVERSITY
IS SOMETHING WE EXAMINED -- THE
SHARE OF WOMEN ANY -- SECTORS OF
THE CREATIVE INDUSTRY IS NOT A
WHOLE LOT DIFFERENT IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN COMPARED --
TO TEN TWO THOUSAND TEN OR TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN ABOUT 40% OF AL
WORKERS -- THERE'S SOME SLIGHT
IMPROVEMENT IN THE EARNINGS ON
THE PART OF WOMEN RELATIVE TO
MEN.
BUT IT IS REALLY A A PRETTY
CONSISTENT REFLECTION OF WHAT
WE'RE SEEING IN THE GENERAL
ECONOMY AT THE PRESENT TIME.
AND WITH RESPECT TO ETHNICITY I
THINK -- YOU KNOW THEY'RE NOT
HUGE CHANGES IN THE SHARES OF OF
MINORITIES WHO ARE IN.
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY -- AND NOR
ANY BIG CHANGE IN THE SHARE OF
WHITE NON HISPANICS SO THAT'S
WHY IT'S IT'S EVOLVING WITH THE
STATEWIDE WORKFORCE.
PRETTY CONSISTENT WITH WHAT
WE'VE SEEN. FOR THE STATE AS A
WHOLE.
YOU LOOK AT COLLEGE DEBT.
WE DID NOT WE DID NOT LOOK AT
COLLEGE THAT WE JUST LOOKED AT
THE LOW.
THE EDUCATIONAL ATTAINMENT.
USING AMERICAN COMMUNITY SURVEY
DATA WHICH SHOWS AS A PEOPLE --
BY OCCUPATION AND BY EDUCATIONAL.
SO THERE'S THIS BROADER -- ECO
SYSTEM THE CREATIVE AN ECO
SYSTEM THAT WE I WHICH WE'VE
BEEN SPENDING A LOT OF TIME ON
THE TOP ONE COMMERCIAL AND
BUSINESS A LITTLE BIT LESS ON
SOMEWHAT LESS ON THE NONPROFIT
ARTS ORGANIZATIONS BUT WE DO TO
DELVE INTO THAT.
A LITTLE BIT MORE IN THE REPORT.
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS
GOVERNMENT POLICY MAKERS AND THE
PHILANTHROPIC COMMUNITY EACH OF
THESE WE TOUCH ON IN THE REPORT --
AND IN THE INTEREST OF TIME JUST
SPEND A LITTLE BIT OF TIME ON
EACH WE LOOKED AT AND ESTABLISH
THAT THERE WERE.
OVER -- ELEVEN THOUSAND
ESTABLISHMENTS IN.
THE ARTS CULTURE AND HUMANITIES
SEGMENT OF THE OF THE CALIFORNIA
ECONOMY WITH OVER -- EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN ASSETS SO
HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT -- IN
ANY ENTITY THAT HAD TO FILE A A
NON PROFIT REPORT ESSENTIALLY
WITH.
THE IRS AND SO THERE ARE MANY
SMALL NON PROFITS THAT HAVE
RECEIPTS THAT ARE FAR.
TOO SMALL. FOR REPORTING
PURPOSES SO THE ELEVEN THOUSAND
ESTABLISHMENT COUNTY IS PROBABLY
A GROSS UNDERESTIMATE.
THE NUMBER OF ASSETS YOU KNOW
MOST OF THE ASSET BASE IS GOING
TO BE FOUND IN LARGE.
INSTITUTIONS LIKE MUSEUMS AND
THEATERS AND THINGS LIKE THAT SO
THAT'S PROBABLY PRETTY CLOSE TO
THE MARK.
AND HE RECEIPTS ARE PROBABLY A
LITTLE BIT OF AN UNDERESTIMATE
AGAIN BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT
WE WERE UNDER REPRESENTING.
THE THE VERY SMALL -- ENTITIES
THAT ARE PART OF THIS
[inaudible]
UP.
WITH RESPECT TO ARTS EDUCATION
WE'VE SEEN SOME IMPROVEMENT OVER
THIS TIME SPAN FROM TWO THOUSAND
TO TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN IN
TERMS OF F. T. E. EQUIVALENT SO
THAT'S THE THE NUMBER OF FACULTY --
AVERAGE CLASS SIZE HAS ACTUALLY
DECREASED OVER THAT TIME SPAN --
AND ENROLLMENTS HAVE HAVE
ACTUALLY DECLINED PART OF THAT I
WOULD SAY HAS TO DO WITH THE
SHEER DEMOGRAPHICS READ APPOINT
TIME AS I'M SURE YOU KNOW.
WHERE CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH --
TWELVE POPULATION IS ACTUALLY
FLAT OR DECLINING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DO SO FOR THE NEXT
SEVERAL YEARS.
OKAY SO -- THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
WHICH IS REALLY.
IT'S NOT THE CENTRAL REASON WHY
THIS STUDY IS BEING DONE I THINK
JUST UNDERSTANDING THE THE
CONNECTIONS AND ALL THESE
DIFFERENT INDUSTRIES -- IT IS
QUITE IMPORTANT BUT THIS MIGHT
BE CALLED THE ICING ON THE CAKE
SO WHEN WE DO AN ECONOMIC IMPACT
ANALYSIS OF AN INDUSTRY.
OR ANYTHING ELSE WE MEASURE THE
IMPACT IN TERMS OF JOBS WAGES AN
OUTPUT.
WHAT WE DO IS WE TRY TO TRACE
THE RIPPLE EFFECT THROUGH THE
ECONOMY OF THE ACTIVITIES THAT?
KICKED IT ALL OFF SO IN THIS
CASE.
THE ACTIVITIES ARE OF THOSE FIVE
MAJOR -- INDUSTRY GROUPS AND
THEIR THEIR COMPONENT INDUSTRIES
WE USE THE JOB COUNTS FROM EACH
OF THOSE INDUSTRIES AS THE
TRIGGER IF YOU WILL [inaudible]
THAT -- REPRESENTS HIS INITIAL --
STIMULUS TO THE LOCAL AND STATE
ECONOMY -- WHICH IS CALLED THE
DIRECT EFFECT.
AND THEN WHAT HAPPENS IS -- YOU
THINK OF SUPPLY CHAIN AND YOU
THINK OF WHAT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN.
LET'S SAY A MUSEUM OR THEATER
DECIDES THAT HE NEEDS TO REMODEL
ITS FOR YANG ITS IT'S IT'S LOBBY.
SO IT'S GONNA HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION COMPANY AND THAT
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES IN TURN
GOING TO TURN TO ITS SUPPLIERS.
TO REQUISITIONMATERIALS AND SO
ON THAT'S THAT INDIRECT EFFECT
SO THAT'S THE FIRST THE NEXT
STEP IN THAT RIPPLE EFFECT
THROUGH THE GENERAL ECONOMY.
MEANWHILE BOTH THE MUSEUM AND
THE CONSTRUCTION FIRM HAVE
EMPLOYEES AND THOSE WORKERS
EARNED WAGES THAT THEY SPEND --
THE SPENDING OUT OF THAT WAGES
OUT OF THOSE WAGES THAT ENTERS
THE STATEWIDE ECONOMY IS THE SO
CALLED INDUCED TO FACT.
SO WE TRACK EACH OF THOSE USING
A MODEL OF THE STATE ECONOMY
THAT HAS SEVERAL HUNDRED
INDUSTRIES.
AND SO WHAT WE GET IS THAT WHEN
WE START WITH A MILLION JOBS
PLUS -- THROUGH THIS RIPPLE
EFFECT IT -- RESULT IN TWO POINT
SIX MILLION JOBS OVER ALL THAT
ARE -- CREATED DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY -- IN ON THE FAR
RIGHT HAND SIDE THE OUTPUT
IMPACT SO WE'VE GOT AN ECONOMY
THE STATE ECONOMY AS YOU KNOW IS
THE FIFTH LARGEST IN THE WORLD --
LITTLE OVER TWO TRILLION DOLLARS
OF ANNUAL ECONOMIC OUTPUT -- WE
START WITH THE OUTPUT THIS
IMPLIED BY THOSE ONE MILLION
JOBS THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT THROUGH THIS RIPPLE EFFECT --
ABOUT -- HALF OF I'M SORRY HALF
A TRILLION DOLLARS.
OF ECONOMIC OUTPUT RESULTS FROM
THIS CREATIVE ECONOMIES WHO WERE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT ONE QUARTER
OF THE ECONOMY ULTIMATELY THAT
IS TOUCH SO IT'S NOT WE CAN'T
CLAIM ALL OF THAT.
YOU KNOW THAT THE THAT THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY START WITH
THOSE MILLION ONE MILLION JOBS
BUT THERE'S A CONTRIBUTION
AFFECT TO THE TO THE REST OF THE
ECONOMY.
THAT AMOUNTS TO TWO POINT SIX
MILLION JOBS AND A HALF TRILLION
DOLLARS WHICH BY ANY MEASURE IS
AN IMPRESSIVE NUMBER.
SO ARE A LOT OF INFORMATION TO
HAVE PRESENTED TO YOU ODAY I
THINK WE NEED TO TAKE -- GO GO
BACK TO YOU KNOW THE FUNDAMENTAL
REASON WHY WE'RE MEETING HERE
TODAY WE HAVE.
THIS -- THIS ARTS COMMUNITY.
ARTS EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
PART AND PARCEL OF EDUCATION IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA -- I I
JUST AND AND SO I SAY LARGE AND
SMALL WE'VE GOT A CON I AN
ORGANIZATION AS LARGE AS THE LA
COUNTY MUSEUM OF ART.
THEY WERE TALKING ABOUT HERE
TODAY AND I JUST HAPPEN TO FIND
IN ALPINE COUNTY WHICH IS THE
SMALLEST BY POPULATION HERE IN
THE STATE THEY HAVE SOMETHING
CALLED THE BEAR VALLEY MUSIC
FESTIVAL THAT OCCURS EVERY YEAR.
SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
ENTIRE GAMUT OF CREATIVE
ACTIVITIES AND CULTURAL
ACTIVITIES -- IVORY ITED A
NUMBER OF NUMBERS SEVERAL
NUMBERS WHAT WE DO IS OR WHAT.
THROUGH THE THROUGH A
CONVERSATION THEY WERE PUTTING A
FACE ON THOSE NUMBERS AS WELL.
AND TALKING ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT
IS -- IT'LL CONTINUE TO BE A
DYNAMIC FORCE -- IT IN AND OF
ITSELF.
BUT IN SO MANY WAYS IT'S
AFFECTING THE OTHER INDUSTRIES
THAT WE HAVE.
THE BETTER -- SO KEY TO OUR
STATE WIDE ECONOMY AND I'LL JUST
CLOSE BY SAYING YOU KNOW WE'VE
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT STEM TO STEAM
FOR MANY YEARS NOW.
AND I THINK IT BECOMES MORE AND
MORE APPARENT AS TIME PASSES HOW.
THESE TWO ARE LINKED -- THE THE
TACK ENGINEERING MATHEMATICS.
OUR LINK TO THE ART SIDE OF THE
WORLD [inaudible]
AND THAT'S MORE TRUE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA I THINK THAN ANY
PLACE ELSE ON THE PLANET.
SO ON THAT NOTE I WILL SAY THANK
YOU -- THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- AND WELCOME BY
THE WAY YEAH.
YES AS A MEMBER.
YEAH MICHAEL TODAY I HAD LOTS OF
COFFEE DOES.
YOU KNOW SO I'M.
I ACTUALLY STARTED READING THAT
REPORT COMING OUT OF OTIS WHEN
IT FIRST STARTED -- AND SO VERY
EXCITED ABOUT THIS TOPIC IN THIS
CONVERSATION YOU KNOW MANY FOLKS
THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY.
ARE EITHER SOLE PROPRIETORS OR
THEY ARE -- OWNERS OF A VERY
SMALL BUSINESS WITH LESS THAN
FIVE EMPLOYEES.
AND SO WONDERING IF IN YOUR SORT
OF ECONOMIC CONVERSATION IF
YOU'RE EVER THINKING ABOUT --
THE TAX BURDEN THAT IS PLACED ON
MANY OF THESE FOLKS AND WE
OFTENTIMES OR TALKING ABOUT
TAXES THE ASSUMPTION IS THAT IT
CAN BE ABSORBED BECAUSE THE
INDUSTRY MAKES A TON OF MONEY
AND IS A HUGE CONTRIBUTOR.
OR BECAUSE IT'S A BUSINESS THAT
HAS A NUMBER OF EMPLOYEES AND
KIND OF WEATHER THE STORM BUT
FOR MANY SMALL BUSINESSES.
I'VE BEEN HEARING ON THAT THE
TAX BURDEN IS BECOMING
INCREASINGLY DIFFICULT AND SO WE
THINK ABOUT THAT IN.
CONNECTION WITH THE FACT THAT
MANY FOLKS MIGHT BE LEAVING THE
STATE BECAUSE OF THE
AFFORDABILITY ISSUE.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF -- THE TAX
IMPLICATIONS ARE PART OF YOUR
THOUGHT PROCESS OR THIS STUDY IN
AND HOW WE CAN MAYBE BE A LITTLE
MORE SYMPATHETIC. TO THE
CHALLENGES THAT THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY -- YOU KNOW FACES AS IT
RELATES TO THE TAX BURDEN COMING
FROM CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE I CERTAINLY WOULD WANT
THOSE JOBS TO GO AWAY RIGHT --
BUT I CERTAINLY DON'T WANT THEM.
TO FEEL.
HAVE A PINCH FEEL MORE LIKE.
A PUNCH.
SO I GUESS I WOULD START BY
SAYING THAT WE COMMONLY HERE
THAT IN AND IN ADDITION TO BEING
A CREATIVE CAPITAL.
AND ATTACK.
CAPITAL.
ALSO AN ENTREPRENEURIAL CAPITAL --
AND THAT'S ALL ABOUT SMALL
BUSINESS SO WE WE HAVE.
LARGE NUMBERS OF SMALL BUSINESS
PEOPLE IN A VARIETY OF
INDUSTRIES INCLUDING THE ARTS --
THE FIRST WITH RESPECT TO PEOPLE
AND BUSINESSES LEAVING
CALIFORNIA IT'S IT DOES HAPPEN
YOU KNOW BUT IT'S ALSO WE'VE
SEEN A NET.
POSITIVE INCREASE IN.
IN POPULATION AND SO ON WE HAVE.
MADE AN OUTSIDE CONTRIBUTION TO
JOB GROWTH RELATIVE TO THE
NATION OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS SO. FOR ALL OF THE TAXES%
AND REGULATIONS AND SO ON THAT.
BUSINESSES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE TO
FACE.
THEY HAVE SOMEHOW MANAGED -- TO
HELP PERFORM IF YOU WILL AT THE
STATE LEVEL -- MANY OTHER STATES
AROUND THE COUNTRY.
SO I THOUGHT I'D IT'S ALWAYS A
GOOD IDEA FOR US TO REMIND
OURSELVES THAT WELL WE WE LIKE
TO BEAT OURSELVES UP.
FOR BEING A HIGH COST STATE TO
DO BUSINESS FOR HAVING HIGH
LEVELS OF REGULATION.
HI TAXES ALL TRUE SOMEHOW OR
ANOTHER BUSINESSES.
FIGURE OUT A WAY TO MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN AND AND AND MANAGED TO
SUCCEED IN THE AND THE TRACK
RECORD HAS BEEN.
QUITE GOOD OVER THE LAST COUPLE
YEARS HAVING SAID ALL THAT I
THINK YOU KNOW THE WHAT I DON'T
HAVE FIGURES TO CITE -- BUT WHAT
I HAVE ARE ANECDOTAL
[inaudible]
OBSERVATIONS FROM.
TALKING TO BUSINESS PEOPLE AND
SO ON AS LONG AS THEY KNOW THE
RULES OF THE GAME.
AND THE RULES OF THE GAME IN THE
FORM OF TAXATION PERMITTING AND
SO ON ARE FAIRLY CLEAR --
MANAGEABLE AND YOU KNOW THEY CAN
NAVIGATE OR THEY CAN GET
ASSISTANCE TO NAVIGATE AT THE AT
THE STATE LOCAL LEVEL.
THEN THEY'LL DO WHAT THEY DO
BEST AND AND IN MANY INSTANCES
THEY WILL SUCCEED.
YOUR HIGH FAILURE RATES AMONG
SMALL BUSINESSES LIKE ONE OUT OF
FIVE FAILED THIS IT THIS NUMBER
IS IS REMARKABLY STABLE.
NATIONALLY AND STATEWIDE NOW ONE
OUT OF SORRY ABOUT 50%.
OF BUSINESSES SMALL BUSINESSES
THAT START UP -- FAIL WITHIN
WITHIN FIVE YEARS -- THAT'S
PARTLY THE MANIFESTATION OR OR
JUST WHAT HAPPENS IN A IN A
MARKET ECONOMY SUCH AS OURS.
SO -- I CAN APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE SAYING AND YOU KNOW THE
CONCERN ABOUT [inaudible]
TAX BURDEN -- IN REGULATORY
BURDEN WE HAVE NOT HAD OCCASION
TO STUDY THAT AS PART OF THIS
RESEARCH SO.
RIGHT WANT WHEN GIVE -- MR BUT
HIGH OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AND
THEN AND THEN WILL OPEN UP THE
THE PANEL THE QUESTION -- ALMOST
AS VICE PRESIDENT GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR ENDEAVOR.
AND WE WELCOME YOU HERE AND ARE
LOOKING FOR YOUR PRESENTATION.
A WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
HAVING ME SENATOR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
LINE DANA THANKS SO MUCH FOR ALL
YOUR WORK ON THIS AND THANKS FOR
ALL YOUR LEADERSHIP -- IN
PUSHING -- IN FOCUSING ON THE
ARTS -- SO I'M THE VICE
PRESIDENT GOVERNOR ELATION TREND
EVER LEADING ENTERTAINMENT
COMPANY BASED IN BEVERLY HILLS.
ENDEAVOR IS FORMALLY W. ANY I.
N. G. IT'S A GLOBAL LEADER IN
SPORTS ENTERTAINMENT AND FASHION
WITH NEARLY SEVEN THOUSAND
EMPLOYEES ACROSS MORE THAN
TWENTY COUNTRIES.
AROUND THE WORLD IS NAMED ONE OF
FORTUNE'S TWENTY FIVE MOST
IMPORTANT PRIVATE COMPANIES.
ENDEAVOR IS THE PARENT COMPANY
OF A NUMBER OF SUBSIDIARIES WITH
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS IN THEIR
RESPECTIVE INDUSTRIES INCLUDING
W. M. ME.
I AM G..
R. U. F. C. -- FREEZE ART WHICH
JUST HELD ITS INAUGURAL LOS
ANGELES ART FAIR IN FEBRUARY.
PROFESSIONAL BULL RIDERS --
WHICH HAD AN EVENT JUST OUTSIDE
SACRAMENTO AT THIS PAST JANUARY
AND ONE IN LOS ANGELES IN
FEBRUARY I WAS A EUPHEMISM FOR
LEGISLATORS AND I MISS UNIVERSE
ORGANIZATION.
I AM G. ACADEMY AND MANY MORE --
NINETEEN NINETY FIVE R. EMMANUEL
IS THE CURRENT CEO OF ENDEAVOR I
RECOGNIZE THAT THE WAY CONTENT
WAS BEING CREATED.
DISTRIBUTED CONSUMES WAS QUICKLY
CHANGING WITH THAT IN MIND HE
FORMED A NEW TOWN AGENCY CALLED
ENDEAVOR -- WHICH YOU BECOME W.
ME -- WITH THE IDEA OF TAKING
ADVANTAGE OF THESE CHANGES AND
BETTER REPRESENTING -- THE
ARTISTS -- THAT -- WERE IN THE
EIGHT THAT HE WAS REPRESENTING --
A KEY PART OF AFFECTED TALENT
REPRESENTATION IS UNDERSTANDING
AN ARTIST PERSPECTIVE IN VISION
FOR THEIR CAREER.
AND ONE'S GOING TO BE BETTER
POSITIONS IN THE ROLE OF AN
AGENT IF THEY HAVE A BACKGROUND
IN THE ARTS -- IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
EXECUTIVES AGENTS OFTEN BEGIN
THEIR CAREERS AS ASSISTANCE --
ANSWERING THE PHONES DELIVERING
MAIL FOR AGENTS AND EXECUTIVES
THEY ONE DAY INSPIRED TO BE --
THOSE PEOPLE YOU KNOW -- ARE
GOING TO BE -- BETTER QUALIFIED
TO DO THAT JOB AS AN ASSISTANT
ANSWERING THE PHONE IF THEY HAVE
A BACKGROUND IN ARTS EDUCATION.
YOU KNOW TODAY -- IF THEY NEVER
HAD A IN HIGH SCHOOL A JAZZ
ENSEMBLE THAT THEY WERE PART OF
AND AND LIKE THEIR DAD BANDS
PRACTICE THAT THEY ARE INVOLVED
IN AN APPRECIATED.
I DEVELOP FILM OF THE
PHOTOGRAPHY CLASS -- IN A LOT OF
WAYS THEY'RE GONNA BE LESS
QUALIFIED -- TO BE JUST AN
ASSISTANCE AT A TALENT AGENCY
THEN SOMEONE WHO HAD THAT TYPE
OF ARTS EDUCATION BACKGROUND.
BUT THAT GOT DELAYED THERE GONNA
BE MORE LIKELY TO COME FROM A
LOWER INCOME MINORITY MAJORITY
SCHOOL DISTRICT AND WAITS ARTS
EDUCATION ARTS CURRICULA -- I
WON THE FIRST THINGS THAT ARE
CUT FROM BUDGETS -- SO DIVERSITY
OF EXPERIENCE.
IS WHAT DRIVES THE ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY TO CONTINUE ITS SILLY
INNOVATE.
AND THAT IS ONLY POSSIBLE
THROUGH THE INCLUSION OF UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES.
INVOICE.
RECOGNIZING IT THERE IS A LACK
OF ACCESS FOR CERTAIN GROUPS
ENDEAVOR HAS TAKEN
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS BY
MAKING ACCESSIBILITY TO QUALITY
ARTS EDUCATION A PRIORITY.
IN ITS SOCIAL IMPACT IN CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT INITIATIVES.
THE LEGISLATURE'S ALSO WORK TO
TOWARDS MAKING HOLLYWOOD MORE
DIVERSE AND INCLUSIVE --
SPECIFICALLY WE HAD THE PLEASURE
WORKING WITH MAJORITY LEADER
CALDERON -- LIKE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT RENEWAL
CITY YOUR QUESTION IS WELL ABOUT
AYE INCENTIVIZING I MEAN I DO
THINK WE NEED TO CONTINUALLY AND
SHORE BASED ON THAT PRESENTATION
THE CALIFORNIA REMAINS
COMPETITIVE -- AND ONE WAY TO DO
THAT IS YOU KNOW THE RENEWAL
THIS CALIFORNIA PRODUCTION TAX
CREDIT WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA CHIU.
TANG SENATOR ALLEN -- MITCHELL'S
AND STERN AS WELL FOR WORKING ON
THE RENEWAL THE CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTIONTAX CREDIT
SPECIFICALLY THE INCLUSION OF A
DIVERSE CITY PROMOTE -- TRACKING
INITIATIVE COMPONENT TO IT WHICH
WITH THAT WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HOPEFULLY YOU KNOW CREATE DATA
THAT WILL BE ABLE TO ASSESS YOU
KNOW WHETHER IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY IS
BECOMING MORE.
DIVERSE -- INCLUSIVE MOVING
FORWARD -- IN WHETHER THE
HOLLYWOOD MOVIES AND TV YEAR.
MORE REFLECTIVE OF THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF THIS STATE -- SAID
THANKS FOR ALL YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON ON MAKING SURE THAT HAPPENS
FOR THIS NEXT CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTION TAX CREDIT. ONE OF
THE REASONS ENDEAVOR SUPPORTED
THE OTIS COLLEGE OF ART AND
DESIGN REPORT ON THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY IS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
THAT ARTS EDUCATION IS THAT
CREAM IS A KEY INGREDIENT TO
ENSURE THE CALIFORNIA REMAINS
THE MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT.
CAPITAL OF THE WORLD.
IF CALIFORNIA CITIZENS DO NOT
PROVIDE ACCESS TO ARTS EDUCATION
TO STUDENTS IN OUR OWN BACKYARD
SPECIFICALLY LOWER INCOME
MINORITY STUDENTS.
WHAT WILL THE FUTURE OF THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY LOOK LIKE?
WE SHOULD BE EMPOWERING THESE
VOICES OF THEY CAN CREATE THE
NEXT HIT SHOW OR BLOCKBUSTER
MOVIE SO THAT THEY CAN SELL
THEIR SCULPTURES IT FREES.
SO THAT THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE
THEIR VOICES THE NATIONAL THE
BATES.
USING ANY OF THESE ARTISTIC
VEHICLES AND EVEN IF THEY HAVE
NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY WHEN
THEY'RE OLDER.
HAVING AN UNDERSTANDING OF THE
ARTS IN APPRECIATION FOR
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES ONLY
MAKES ONE MORE VALUABLE AT
WHATEVER HE OR SHE DECIDES TO DO.
YEAH THIS REPORT PROVIDES KEY
DATA THAT IS FEEL SPECIFIC
DIVERSITY INCLUSIVITY
INITIATIVES BY ENDEAVOR ONE
CONCLUSION THAT WE GOT FROM THE
STUDY THAT THE LACK OF EQUITY
AND ACCESS STARTS EDUCATION NOT
ONLY DENIES CHILDREN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE A WELL
ROUNDED EDUCATION.
IT ALSO BLOCKS PATHWAYS INTO A
MAJOR REGIONAL ECONOMIC ENGINE.
AND IT.
DEPRIVES THAT ENGINE OF THE FUEL
IT NEEDS TO THRIVE.
ENDEAVOR IS TAKEN ON SEVERAL
PROJECTS IMPACTING A NUMBER OF
ISSUES BROUGHT UP IN THE REPORT
LAST ELECTION WE PARTNERED WITH
ARTS FOR LA AND THE CULVER CITY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT. TO
INCREASE IN SAFEGUARDS TO THE
ACCESS STARTS EDUCATION IN
CULVER CITY SCHOOLS BE A PARTIAL
TAX BALLOT INITIATIVE.
THE PARTIAL TAX PASSED WITH OVER
TWO THIRDS OF THE VOTE.
UNDER PROP THIRTEEN VOTER
APPROVED PARCEL TAXES CAN BE
PROPOSED FOR ANY CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT NEED.
AND ARE ONE OF THE FEW REMAINING
TOOLS FOR GENERATING FUNDS AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IN CULVER CITY
THE PARTIAL TAXES A FLAT HUNDRED
EIGHTY NINE DOLLAR PER PARCEL.
THIS RESULTS IN TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR SEVEN
YEARS WHICH INCLUDES ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION FOR ARTS EDUCATION.
INITIATIVESLIKE THIS OR A SMALL
STEP TOWARDS THE SYSTEMIC CHANGE
THAT IS DESPERATELY NEEDED.
THIS REPORT ALSO PROVIDES DATA
THAT IS INFLUENCED ENDEAVOR AND
W. MUSE DECISION TO FINE ARTS
EDUCATION PROGRAMMING IN THE
CONTENT SCHOOL DISTRICT.
CONNECT THE MIGHT MENTORSHIP
PROGRAM WHERE FORTY YOUNG PEOPLE
FROM COMPTON COME TO DEBBIE ME
OFFICE IS IN BEVERLY HILLS
DURING THE SCHOOL YEAR -- WE
JUST RECENTLY LAUNCHED A YOUNG
EXECUTIVES FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
WITH THE HOLLYWOOD REPORTER
YOUNG EXECUTIVES FELLOWSHIP
PROGRAM AIMS TO CREATE A
PIPELINE FOR FUTURE LEADERS IN
FILM AND TELEVISION EACH YEAR
TWENTY HIGH SCHOOL JUNIORS WILL
BE CHOSEN ON A HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE BASIS. FOR A TWO
YEAR PROGRAM THEY'LL INCLUDE
CURRICULUM COLLEGE SCHOLARSHIPS
IN MENTORING.
ALL WILL BE SELECTED FROM
UNDERSERVED SCHOOLS IN LA
CONTENT IN INGLEWOOD WHILE
THEY'RE IN SCHOOL EACH OF THE
YOUNG EXECS WILL RECEIVE A PAID
SUMMER INTERNSHIP AT ONE OF THE
PARTNER COMPANIES INCLUDING W.
I. ME.
WITH A VIEW TO LAUNCHING THEIR
CAREERS W. ME HAS PROVIDED TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN SEED FUNDING FOR THE
SCHOLARSHIP FUND -- WE ALSO
PARTNERED WITH MAYOR GARCETTI'S
OFFICE WITH THE INVOLVED
ENTERTAINMENT FUND A PUBLIC
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP AIMED AT
CREATING NEW OPPORTUNITIES FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY EXCLUDED FROM THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY -- THIS
REPORT PROVIDES THE DATA THAT
PROVES THE SUPPORTING AND
PROMOTING THE ARTS IS ESSENTIAL
TO CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY.
THIS REPORT OUTLINES ALL THE
WAYS THAT CALIFORNIA'S CITIZENS
IN ITS GOVERNMENT BENEFIT FROM
THE ARTS IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY.
WE ARE PROUD HAVE SUPPORTED AND
GRATEFUL TO THE PEOPLE AT OTIS
FOR PUTTING IT TOGETHER.
WE HOPE TO SEE CONTINUED EFFORTS
BY THE LEGISLATURE TO PROMOTE
THE ARTS BY PASSING -- WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU YOU KNOW IS
PUT AT SOME LEGISLATION ABOUT
UPDATED DATA COLLECTION
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ENABLE US
TO FURTHER STUDY THE IMPACT OF
ARTS EDUCATION -- TO THE
CREATION OF A CALIFORNIA EVENTS
FUNDS SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAVE IN.
TEXAS AND LOUISIANA -- I KNOW
THIS IS ALSO BEEN INTRODUCED AS
WELL -- TALKS ABOUT THIS IN THE
SENATE AS WELL -- THAT WILL HELP
BRING LIVE IN CREATIVE ADVANCE
TO COMMUNITIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA
AND HELP INCENTIVIZE AND PROVIDE
A A REASON FOR THEM.
TO COME HERE AND PUT ON THESE
EVENTS AND INSPIRE AND CREATE --
ECONOMIC IMPACT -- THE EVENTS ON
WHICH OUR CULTURE INSPIRE KIDS
CREATE POSITIVE ECONOMIC IMPACT
FOR THE ECONOMY -- THANK YOU
GUYS SO MUCH FOR ALL YOUR
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE AND ALL
YOUR WORK.
IN PROMOTING IT AND THANKS FOR
HAVING THANK YOU FOR YOUR MOST
PROJECT THAT.
WELL GOOD VERY INTERESTING
PRESENTATIONS ALL WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM THE FROM THE
PANEL YES SAID AS OVER TO YOU
WELCOME THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF LET ME FIRST THANK -- THE
CHAIR IN THE COMMITTEES -- AS
WELL AS EVERYONE PARTICIPATING
IN TODAY'S PANEL -- I HAD ASKED
TO JOIN THIS COMMITTEE COUPLE
YEARS AGO BECAUSE MY CITY SAN
FRANCISCO REFLECTS ONE OF THOSE
CENTERS.
OF THE CREDIT A CONNIE AND WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TODAY I DO
THINK IS INTEGRAL TO OUR SUCCESS
NOT JUST ECONOMICALLY AS A STATE
BUT WHO WE ARE AS CALIFORNIANS
THE SPIRIT OF OUR STATE AND WHAT
WE PROJECT OUT TO THE TO THE
WORLD.
I WANT TO TAKE A MOMENT JUST
THANK AMOS AND ENDEAVOR FOR THE
WORK THAT THEY DID LAST YEAR.
ON THE HOLLYWOOD FILM TAX CREDIT
AND REALLY THINKING ABOUT
DIVERSITY ISSUES WITHIN THE
HOLLYWOOD INDUSTRY IN AND SAY
THAT.
WHEN?
THE PUBLIC THINKS ABOUT THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY THERE OFTEN
THINKING ABOUT TRADITIONAL
INSTITUTIONS THAT TEND TO NOT
NECESSARILY REFLECT THE ETHNIC
RACIAL AND ECONOMIC DIVERSITY
THE STATE SO.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE SYMPHONY IN
THE UPPER THE BALLET YOU THINK
ABOUT HOLLYWOOD YOU THINK ABOUT --
THE MUSIC SCENE -- THERE IS
STILL A LOT OF WORK TO BE DONE
TO CONTINUE TO ENSURE THAT THIS
IS AN ECONOMY THAT LIFTS UP ALL
BOATS AND I LOVE THE FACT THAT
TODAY.
THIS HEARING IS FOCUSING ON THE
EDUCATION PIPELINE AND ALSO ON
HOW WE LIFT UP YOUTH -- I DO
HOPE THAT WE HAVE A CONVERSATION
SPECIFICALLY RUN THE WORKFORCE
AT SOME POINT.
ABOUT HOW IS THAT DIFFERENT
SECTORS OF THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
HIGHER.
THE DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA --
PROMOTE DIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND
HAVE IN ITS LEADERSHIP THE
DIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK MY MY QUESTION REALLY IS
IF THERE ARE ANY INITIAL
THOUGHTS ON THINGS THAT WE COULD
BE DOING IN THAT AREA TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE'RE REALLY ENGAGING
IN.
ALL ASPECTS OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY AND WHAT IS I THINK
ONE OF OUR COMPETITIVE
ADVANTAGES OF A STATE WHICH IS
OUR CREATE A CALMING.
OUT I'LL JUST SAY THAT ONE OF
THE BIGGEST PRIORITIES FOR THE
ARTS COUNCIL IS THAT CALIFORNIA
ARTS COUNCIL IS TO MAKE SURE
THAT.
WE ARE.
ARE REACHING OUT TO ALL THE
MARGINALIZED COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE MAYBE NOT EVEN [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
THERE ARE ENTERING THE WORK
FORCE AND THEN NOT EVEN GETTING
UP INTO LEADERSHIP POSITIONS
THROUGH SOME SPECIAL INITIATIVES
THAT WE HAVE.
AND THEN IN OUR GRANTS PORTFOLIO
OVER ALL.
WE WE TAKE A LOT OF TIME AND A
LOT OF CARE AND IT'S A CONSTANT
ITERATIVE.
PROCESS FOR US TO MAKE SURE THAT
WERE WE'RE HELPING TO UP LEFT
AND IN RICH ALL THE COMMUNITY SO
FOLKS CAN SEE THEMSELVES.
ANYBODY CAN SEE THEMSELVES IN A
JOB.
THAT IS [inaudible]
MAYBE NORMALLY VIEWED AS PART OF
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY OR NOT
NORMALLY VIEWED AS PART OF THE
GREAT CREATIVE ECONOMY BECAUSE
I'M ONE OF THOSE.
FOLKS IT REALLY THINKS IT'S SO
DIFFICULT TO JUST SAY THIS IS
CREATIVE ECONOMY WHEN I KNOW
FULL WELL.
WHEN I'M TALKING TO BOEING?
THEY VALUE THEIR CREE HERE IF
THERE IS.
AS WE ALL DO WHEN WE GET ON THAT
PLANE.
YEAH. TO MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYTHING.
YOU KNOW THAT THEY ARE DESIGNED
TO WELL.
AND ALL THE SYSTEMS INTERLINK
WELL AND THAT'S DESIGN AND AND
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO
KEEP THE A AND STATE.
THAT THAT'S ONE OF OUR
PRIORITIES TO MAKE SURE WE REACH
OUT TO ALL POPULATION.
IF YOU DON'T MIND -- ME ADDING
TO THAT THE ONE THING WE DON'T
TALK ABOUT IN THIS STUDY.
BUT I THINK THE CONNECTION IS
FAIRLY CLOSE IS THAT WHEN.
YOU LOOK AT A CITY LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO WHERE TOURISM IS SO
IMPORTANT.
PEOPLE COME FOR A VISIT SAN
FRANCISCO. TO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
GOLDEN GATE BRIDGE -- TO GO TO
THE MUSEUMS AND THINGS LIKE THAT.
BUT THEY ALSO STOP.
AT RESTAURANTS AND THEY STAY IN
A HOTEL SO TOUR SO THE ARTS.
REALLY IS A CATALYST IN SOME
SENSE THAT -- THAT BRINGS
TOURISM TO OUR COMMUNITIES.
AND IT AND THE BUSINESSES THAT.
SERVE THOSE TOURISTS ARE
BUSINESSES LARGE AND SMALL.
AND VERY ETHNICALLY DIVERSE.
BECAUSE PEOPLE COME TO
CALIFORNIA OR GO TO DIFFERENT
PARTS OF CALIFORNIA TO
EXPERIENCE.
THE NEIGHBORHOODS AND AND ALL
THAT SO WHEN WE WHEN WE THINK
ABOUT.
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY AS AN
ECONOMIC ENGINE -- IT'S IT'S
GOOD IDEA TO THANK YOU KNOW IF
YOU CAN POINT OUT WITH YOUR
COMMENT ABOUT -- CREATORS IN
BOEING BOEING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WE HAVE THIS THING CALLED
TOURISM WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTOR TO THE LOCAL ECONOMY
AN IMPORTANT CONTRIBUTOR TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT REVENUES.
THROUGH FRIDAY REVENUE STREAMS
THAT -- REALLY RELIES HEAVILY ON
ARTS AND CULTURE -- AS A MAGNET
TO DRAW THOSE TOURISTS IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
I THINK ONE THING I'LL JUST
OBSERVE -- IS THE ARTS AND
ENTERTAINMENT CREATIVE ECONOMY
WORLD IS NOT ONE THAT I THINK.
WITH THE EXCEPTION OF HOLLYWOOD --
HAS HAD AS MUCH OF A ROLE HERE
IN SACRAMENTO IN TRYING TO WIN
FOR POLICIES PRACTICALLY AND HOW
WE'RE TRYING TO INFLUENCE
EDUCATION WORKFORCE AS AS I WITH.
ONE AND SO I WOULD JUST SAY TO
THE PANELISTS AND AND OTHERS IN
THE PUBLIC -- AS A MEMBER THIS
COMMITTEE I'M CERTAINLY LOOKING
FOR INTERESTING IDEAS AND WHAT
WE CAN DO. TO SUPPORT THIS
ECONOMY AND ENSURE THAT IT IS
REALLY LIFTING UP EVERYONE --
BECAUSE I DO BELIEVE -- IT IS A
COMPETITIVE STRENGTH THE
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE FOR OUR
ECONOMY FOR STATE -- AND AND AND
THE OPPORTUNITIES ARE ARE ARE
ARE ARE THERE IF WE CAN FIGURE
OUT HOW TO TO TAKE ADVANTAGE.
YEAH NUMBER.
THREE THANK YOU A SENATOR AND
THEN ON THE PRESENTERS TODAY --
I AM -- WELL -- BEING --
ORIENTATED AND EDUCATED UP BY
YOUR PRESENTATION -- I OR DIDN'T
COME FROM KOREA AND YES SIXTY
EIGHT THAT DISTRIBUTES ORANGE
COUNTY.
AND I'M VERY INTRIGUED ABOUT THE
TERMINOLOGY.
CREATIVE -- ECONOMY -- BOB --
THREE FOUR FIVE SOMETHING YEARS
AGO -- PRESIDENT FORM OF
PRESIDENT OF KOREA -- THE LADY --
COULDN'T HAVE HOT.
SHE CAME UP A WITH THE
CREATIVELY KANA ME.
AND IT WAS A VERY OF BUZZ WORD
THAT TO ME AND WHAT EXACTLY SHE
WAS OF PURSUING BY THAT THE
TERMINOLOGY.
YEAH CHIANG JOEL CHUNG J. IN
KOREA AND AND THAT THAT'S
EXACTLY TO THE TRANSLATION OF
CLUB CREATIVE ECONOMY.
BUT THE TODAVíA I SEE IT THAT
IS -- MORE OF I DEFINED IN THE
POTS AND CULTURE AND AND TO TAME
A AND THE IN THE MOVIES -- FINE
NOT SO.
EVEN PERFORMING ARTS -- IN IN
THAT THE CATEGORY.
AND THEN I DO SEE THAT -- A LOT
OF A THE UPON OUR ECONOMY FROM
THAT THE INDUSTRY IS SO --
ADDING ON TO OUR STATE OF HOW
CALIFORNIA -- AND IN THAT -- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE FOR THE
PEOPLE OR IN THAT THE CREATIVE --
AREA.
AND THE WHICH I'M NOT IN THERE.
MY MAJOR WAS -- LIBRARY
INFORMATION SCIENCE.
AND I'M JUST -- I'M WHEN I ADD
THAT TO POINTS -- IN MY COMMENT
THEM.
THAT YOU HAVE MENTIONED SEVERAL
OF YOU MENTIONED THAT THE MUSEUM
IN THERE -- AS A PART OF
CREATIVE ECONOMY -- INDUSTRY.
AND WHAT I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO --
WAS -- TO OF BEER IS THE ORANGE
COUNTY SO -- THE MAIN LIBRARY --
TO KEEP UP WITH THE SQUARE
FOOTAGE PER CAPITA IT CAME UP TO
BE OVER -- TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
SQUARE FOOT.
LIBRARY ISN'T NEEDED AN ORANGE
COUNTY ORANGE COUNTY'S A
PERCEIVED AS SOME WHICH COUNTY
[inaudible]
HOWEVER STRANGELY.
I WOULDN'T HAVE -- CENTRAL
LIBRARY WEARS A OF EVEN POOR
COUNTY IS SAID TO HAVE THAT THEN
DONE IVORY IT IS -- BUT LIKE A
CULTURE CENTER OF THE COMMUNITY.
AND IN CONNECTION WITH THE
EDUCATION.
THAT'S THE PLACE SO WE ARE
MUSEUM IS SO TO ME MORE PASS IT
TO THEM IN A IN A PASSIVE AREA
YOU WILL DO.
LOOK AT THINGS ABOUT THE LIBRARY
SO MORE ACTIVE PLACE SO YOU CAN
CREATE THE ZONING -- HOW MANY
TIMES SO SCHOOLS SO WOULD HAVE
THAT KIND OF TIME? TO TO TEACH
IN OUR IN THIS INDUSTRY SO
UNLESS OF A CALL -- TO LE
COTTAGES UPPER ORTIZ COLLEGES
THAT TRUCK WHAT THE TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO EDUCATE THE THE ROD JOB
SO IN THE CREATIVE INDUSTRY.
SO THOSE ARE LIKE -- IN MY
VISION.
IN THE SPACE OF THAT ALLOW LARGE
LIBRARY SPEAKS UP.
WE CAN CREATE THE LIKE THE ROOMS
OF FOR MEDIA CREATION EDITING
ALL THE FUN HOBBY THING SO CAN
AND COURAGE.
AND ON WE HAVE A LAND THAT THAT
WE PARK IT AND ALL.
A CITY OF IRVINE WE HAVE BUILT
OVER THREE HUNDRED STYLES THREE
HUNDRED THE MILLION DOLLARS OF
FUND -- WE WE HAD EVERYTHING BUT
DOORS AND ALL -- WILL OF THE
COUNCIL WHEN I PROPOSED.
SO I COULD NOT CLOSE IT BEFORE I
LEFT THE CITY SO MAYOR.
BECAUSE I CAME UP HERE AND THE
STEELERS SPENDING I'M I'M TRYING
TO PUSH IT.
SO I HOPE WHAT I CAN FIND SOME
WAYS -- IN ALL SUPPORT DOT THAT
THE LIBRARY IT SHOULD BE PART OF
THAT EDUCATION NAME TO CREATE A
POP.
ART SO THAT TO YOUR PROMOTING.
DOES THE ONE AREA AND THAT THE
OTHER ONE IS THAT BUT AS I
SUFFER MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
MENTIONED THAT -- I SEE --
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY SEVEN
CALIFORNIA HOLLYWOOD DATE IS THE
LASTING TRYING TO INCENTIVIZE
FOR THEM TO COME BACK.
I THINK THAT THIS BODY ON THIS
TODAY CHAU WOULD HAVE -- TO I AM.
A MEMBER OF A THE WITH THE US
THEM AND LOOK AT CHIU THE
PAYMENT AND UP [inaudible]
PARTS.
SO I AM STARTING TO PAY.
ATTENTION TO THAT AREA HOW WE
CAN RETAIN AND TO BRING BACK --
SUCH INDUSTRY SO TO CALIFORNIA
ONE OF THE EXAMPLES WAS THAT --
NOT NECESSARILY.
THE INDUSTRY -- OF CREATIVE --
ECONOMY AND ALL A MOVIE MAKERS
UP BUT THAT IN GENERAL -- ANY --
BUSINESSES SO WHICH HAVE LEFT
OUR STATE.
IF YOU COME BACK A WILL GIVE YOU
A SIXTEEN POINT 5% OF A TAX
CREDIT UP COME BACK OR IF YOU
ARE HERE CREATE THE MORE JOBS TO
MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE THEN WE
WILL GIVE YOU A TAX CREDIT.
FOR THE SIXTEEN POINT 5%.
TAX INCENTIVE WAS USED IN THE
AEROSPACE INDUSTRY.
FOR ALSO TRYING TO LEAVE.
THE STATE CAME UP WITH THAT
NUMBER SO THAT NUMBER WAS
ALREADY FOR MEDIA ONE BUT
SOMEHOW FOR TWO YEARS -- IT JUST
TOOK OUT THE HUNG UP BUT AND
DOES -- APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
AND THAT DID NOT PASS -- SO I AM
TRYING -- TO CREATE -- A
MECHANISM SO THAT OUR INDUSTRY
OUR CREATIVE INDUSTRIAL WHAT ANY
BUSINESS SO -- WOULD IT WILL NOT
BE FORCED OUT OF OUR STATE.
AND TO COME BACK. TWO HOURS SO
SO I THINK OF THIS BODY NEED TO
REALLY WORK CAR.
THAT THE THIS -- OF CREATIVE --
ECONOMY INDUSTRY -- WALL NO
MATTER WHAT FIELD IT MAY BE -- A
WE NEED TO NURTURE BUSINESSES SO
THAT THAT THEY CAN THRIVE AND ED --
THE REVENUE TWELVE A STEP UP
BECAUSE OF THOSE ARE THE MOST A
JOB CREATORS SO IF WE HAVE A JOB
CREATORS TO AND AND MANY PEOPLE
WOULD HAVE A VERY ENOUGH INCOME
NOT BECOME.
HOMELESS PEOPLE YOU KNOW -- WE
CAN THEY CAN AFFORD.
THE THE HOME SO THAT EXPENSIVE
HOMES IN CALIFORNIA.
IN A WIN -- INDUSTRIES SO THAT'S
JOB CREATING INDUSTRIES A HIGH
PAYING INDUSTRIES AND LEAVE THE
STATE.
AND THE WE BECOMES WELFARE STATE.
AND ALL OR ONE SKILLED DOT HOME
NASA.
OF PEOPLE COME IN AND THE
WEALTHIEST STATE THAT DOWN NOW
WHAT THE STATE BECAUSE OF ALMOST
STATE.
AND WE SHOULD REALLY ENCOURAGE
BUSINESSES TO STAY HERE AND
ABOUT TRACK THAT YES MY COM.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANY.
FINAL THOUGHTS BEFORE WE MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT TOWN REALLY DO
APPRECIATE YOU ALL.
BEING HERE AND AND FOR ALL THE
WORK THAT IS REFLECTED IN YOUR
PRESENTATIONS -- IT'S IT'S
FANTASTIC STUFF AND AND WE'RE
GONNA BE REFER IN QUITE A BIT TO
THE T. REPORT -- AND THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR I FORGOT TO
MENTION THAT WE DON'T GET
TOGETHER -- A SNAPSHOT IF YOU
CAN WAIT LIVE TO THE OTHER
REPORT SPECIALLY YEAH.
AND THEN IF YOU JUST NEED A
QUICK CALIFORNIA'S CENTRIC
SNAPSHOT THE WE ALL GOT THE
LARGER ONES YEAH SO WHERE YOU'VE
GOT YEAH LIKE.
DIFFERENT WEIGHTS DEPENDING ON
WHAT WITH THE THAT'S THE VERSION
IT PROBABLY MORE HELPFUL FOR
MORE OF OUR LEGISLATORS GIVEN
EVERYONE'S TIME SCHEDULES BUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU TO ALL OF
YOU REALLY REALLY DO APPRECIATE
IT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT SO I I WANNA MELT
WELCOME MY MY MY GOOD FRIEND AND
IN THE THE CO CHAIR OF THIS
HEARING WAS SET CHAIR OF OUR
VICE CHAIR OF OUR JOINT
COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS AND ALSO
CHAIR OF OUR COMMITTEE ON ARTS
ENTERTAINMENT SPORTS TOURISM AND
INTERNET MEDIA OVER.
ON THE SEMI SIDE HE'S GOING TO
BE -- RUNNING THIS NEXT PANEL
WHICH INVOLVES -- EVALUATING THE
ARTS EDUCATION PIPELINE KANSEN
CHU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHOWN REALLY --
GLAD TO BE HERE TO HEAR SOME OF
THE EXPERT.
ON ARTS AND EDUCATION I DO WANT
TO MENTION THAT I HAVE A BILL A.
B. -- THREE NINETY EIGHT THE
THINK OF A COLLEGE ITEM LATE
HERE.
I DO HAVE A BILLS ARE A. B. --
THREE NINETY EIGHT TRYING TO
COLLECT DATA.
FROM A GOOD PUBLIC SCHOOL
EDUCATION -- ARCH EDUCATION.
AND IT DIDN'T REALLY -- TO VERY
WELL AND THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE.
SO -- I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE COLLECTED DATA.
FROM A FARM DAY OUR SCHOOL
REGARDING TO EDUCATION AND THAT
WE KNOW -- WHERE ARE GOOD STRONG?
JOINT ARE AND WHERE IS HE DID
THE WORK POINTS ARE GOOD I KNOW
SOME OF THE WHICH WILL DOES
COLLECTING INFORMATION BUT NOW
ALL OF THE SCHOOL INFORMATION.
I'M.
REALLY LOOKING -- FOR TO HERE
FOR AND YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY WE'LL
GET SOME OF THE STRONG DATA TO
BACK UP MY ONE FIVE BILL WHICH I
PROBABLY I WILL BE INTRODUCING
AGAIN NEXT YEAR.
AND YOU KNOW I'M AN ENGINEER BY
TRAINING A STRONG SUPPORTER OF
THE STEM EDUCATION.
BUT IS PRECISELY WHAT I SUPPORT --
EDUCATION.
THE GREAT DEAL OF RESEARCH SHOW
THAT ARTS LEAD TO BETTER -- STAM.
EDUCATION ALL CALM.
AND AT ARTS EDUCATION PROMOTE --
CURIOSITY CREATIVITY AND
ENGAGEMENT AND INVOLVEMENT.
SO WHY THIS IS WHERE YOU AT ARCH
TO SPAM YOU GASOLINE.
AND I'M DEFINITELY A VERY --
STRONG ADVOCATE -- FOR STEAM
EDUCATION TO EDUCATE.
THE NEXT GENERATION OF OUR KIDS.
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT PANEL WE
HAVE -- DEVALUATION ALL ART
EDUCATION PIPELINE.
ALL RIGHT.
SO.
WE HAVE THE JACK MITCHELL.
OF BE BOP HA AND ART MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT CONSULTANT.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION -- PLEASE COME FORWARD.
AND WE DO HAVE -- DENISE GRANDY
THE DIRECTOR OF ARTS EDUCATION
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ARCH AT
COLLECTIVE.
LOS ANGELES COUNTY ARTS
COMMISSION.
AND THE THIRD.
ONE IS.
TO THE HIS SHOES.
ALL THE WHOLE GM.
THE CHAIR OF CREATIVE.
CREATE CALIFORNIA PRESIDENT --
THEM MORE MORE MORE MORENO
VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
BOARD OF EDUCATION WELCOME
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I WOULD LIKE TO BE BEGIN BY
THANKING SENATOR ALLEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHIU AND THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR SHINING A LIGHT ON
THE ARTS IN CALIFORNIA AND ARTS
EDUCATION -- MORE SPECIFICALLY
MY NAME IS JACK MITCHELL -- A.
M. THE ARCH MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT
CONSULTANT AT THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION I'VE
BEEN DOING THAT FOR THE PAST
TWELVE YEARS PRIOR TO THAT I WAS
A THEATER AND STAGE CRAFT
TEACHER AND LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT. FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS.
AND PRIOR TO THAT I WAS A
STATISTIC IN THE ORDERS REPORT
WHEN I WAS AN ACTOR IN FILM AND
TELEVISION IN LOS ANGELES. FOR
ABOUT TWELVE YEARS -- I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR INVITING THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION BE PART OF THIS
CONVERSATION TODAY -- IT'S OUR
ROLE TO SUPPORT CREATIVITY
CATION FOR CALIFORNIA IN ALL
CALIFORNIA CLASSROOMS FOR OUR
SIX MILLION.
STUDENTS -- MY ROLE HERE IS TO
GIVE YOU SORT OF A THIRTY
THOUSAND FOOT VIEW OF EDUCATION
AND THEN WE WILL LOOKS BRING THE
PLANE IN FOR A LANDING AS WE
MOVE THROUGH THE OTHER PANELISTS --
AND LET ME BEGIN BY SAYING THAT
WHEN I CAME TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION THERE WAS A ART MUSIC
BLOCK GRANT THAT FUNDED. TO GO
PROVIDE CATEGORICAL FUNDING --
FOR ARTS EDUCATION -- IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN L. C. F. F.
CAME ABOUT -- THOSE FUNDS WERE
ROLLED INTO THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING AND THE FOCUS OF OF
ADVOCACY AND SUPPORT AND
PLANNING FOR ARTS EDUCATION
SHIFTED FROM THE STATE LEVEL. TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL -- THE PROBABLY
THE MOST EXCITING THING THAT'S
HAPPENED AND MOST ENCOURAGING
THING THAT'S HAPPENED IN MY
TWELVE YEARS AT THE DEPARTMENT
OF ED.
IS -- HAPPENED JUST RECENTLY
WHEN THE CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD
OF EDUCATION -- ADOPTED NEW
STANDARDS FOR ARTS EDUCATION AND
SORT OF ALIGNED WITH WHAT YOU
HEARD FOR THE FOLKS REMOTEST
TALKING ABOUT THE INCREASE IN
MEDIA EDUCATION AND MEDIA ARTS
IN CALIFORNIA.
WE INCLUDED MEDIA ARTS STANDARDS
FOR MEDIA ARTS.
EDUCATION AS WELL AND THOSE
STANDARDS ARE FOR MEDIA ARTS
EDUCATION FROM K. THROUGH TWELVE
NOT JUST FOR THOSE FOLKS IN HIGH
SCHOOL BUT KIDS NEED TO BEGIN
LEARNING ABOUT MEDIA ARTS
EDUCATION.
IN THE EARLY GRADES -- THIS IS
WHEN IN FACT STUDENTS ARE MOST
CREATIVE -- AND THE EXPERTS THE
ABILITY TO ADDRESS THEM SET TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES FOR MEDIA
ARTS IS A VERY IMPORTANT.
I WAS ASKED TO TALK ABOUT THE
EDUCATION PIPELINE AND SO ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I THE ROLE THAT
I HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS AS THE INDUSTRY
SECTOR LEAD.
FOR ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
WHICH IS CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION IN THE ARTS -- MOST OF
YOUR FAMILIAR WITH CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THE STATE PLAN FOR
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION --
MOVED FROM SIX GENERAL CAREER
AREAS TO FIFTEEN INDUSTRY
SECTORS.
AND AT THAT POINT THE STATE PLAN
WRITERS REALIZED THAT THERE WAS.
A EXISTING INDUSTRY IN A RAPIDLY
GROWING INDUSTRY IN ARTS MEDIAAND ENTERTAINMENT AND THAT IT
SHOULD IN FACT BE ONE OF THE
INDUSTRY SECTORS THAT WE BEGAN
TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THROUGH
THE EDUCATIONAL PROCESS.
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN WE
FIRST BEGAN COLLECTING DATA ON
ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT.
THERE WERE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN A ME
PROGRAMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE.
THOSE STUDENTS WERE ENROLLED IN
FOUR MAIN PATHWAYS.
DESIGN VISUAL AND MEDIA ARTS.
PERFORMING ARTS PRODUCTION AND
MANAGERIAL ARTS AND GAME DESIGN.
THERE WAS NO WIDESPREAD --
SUPPORT FOR ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT AS AN INDUSTRY
SECTOR.
AND THERE WAS NO DATA BEING
PUBLICLY GATHERED I KNOW THAT
DATA WAS BEING GATHERED BUT
THERE WAS NO MESS THAT OF
DISSEMINATING THAT DATA ON JOBS.
IN ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT.
WHEN I CAME UP THROUGH SCHOOL --
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
REMEMBER AND MAYBE SOME OF YOU
REMEMBER TO IS THAT IF YOU WERE
INTERESTED IN THE ARTS AS I WAS
YOU WERE.
TOLD HIM THAT YOU NEED A BACK UP
PLAN.
WELL I THINK THAT LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION IN THE ORDERS REPORT
ONE OF THE THINGS IT'S CLEAR NOW
IS THAT THE ARTS CAN BE YOUR
BACKUP PLAN.
THERE ARE JOBS IN THE ARTS IN
AND WE PREPARE THOSE STUDENTS IN
ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
PROGRAMS.
THE ARTS MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY SECTOR HAS GROWN FROM
THOSE TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
TO TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN
MAKING ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT THE LARGEST
INDUSTRY SECTOR IN CALIFORNIA
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION.
TWICE THE SIZE OF AGRICULTURE
EDUCATION AND TWICE THE SIZE OF
HEALTH CAREERS EDUCATION
ACTUALLY AMY IS LARGER THAN BOTH
AGRICULTURE AND HEALTH CAREERS
EDUCATION.
COMBINED WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS ENROLLED -- I
PROVIDED YOU -- ACTUALLY LAUREN
I BELIEVE WILL SHARE WITH YOU
SOME INFORMATION REGARDING
STUDENT ENROLLMENT DATA -- AND
WE WERE WE'RE GOING TO BE
TALKING ABOUT DATE A LITTLE BIT
LATER BUT SOME STUDENT ROMAN
DATA BOTH IN THE ARTS AND IN THE
ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY SECTORS.
SO IN ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT THERE ARE A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS STATEWIDE INFO ENROLLED
IN THE DESIGN VISUAL AND MEDIA
ARTS PATHWAY.
AND THAT PATHWAY INCLUDES FOLKS
LIKE PRODUCTION -- DESIGNERS --
DIRECTORS -- ARTISTS -- MEDIA
ARTISTS ANIMATORS -- THERE ARE.
TWENTY SIX THOUSAND STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN PERFORMING ARTS
PROGRAMS AND DANCE THEATER MUSIC --
THERE FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
STUDENTS IN PRODUCTION
MANAGERIAL ARTS AND THOSE ARE
BASICALLY THE BELOW THE LINE
JOBS IN FILM AND TELEVISION THE
FOLKS WHO WORK BEHIND THE CAMERA
BEHIND THE SCENES.
AND THEN FOUR THOUSAND STUDENTS
IN OUR NEWEST INDUSTRY SECTOR OF
GAME DESIGN [inaudible]
SO THE IN THE PAST -- TWELVE
YEARS THERE'S BEEN A HUGE GROWTH
IN ART IN ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT AND THAT GROWTH.
IS WHILE I WON'T SAY IT'S
BECAUSE BY IT CERTAINLY HAS BEEN
GREATLY SUPPORTED BY THE DATA
PROVIDED BY THE OLDEST REPORT.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
WHEN I FIRST SAW THE OWNERS
REPORT THERE WAS NO PUBLIC DATA
THAT WE COULD POINT TO TO SHOW
THAT THERE WERE IN FACT JOBS
HERE.
BUT THAT OTIS REPORT PROVIDED US
WITH -- WITH THE ABILITY TO
SHARE WITH FOLKS THE IMPACT OF
THE OF THE ARTS ON THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY.
THE NUMBER OF JOBS AVAILABLE IN
THE CREATIVE ECONOMY AND THAT
CERTAINLY HELPED ME OUT WHEN I
TALK TO SCHOOL COUNSELORS ABOUT.
IT URGING STUDENTS TO GO INTO
THE ARTS RATHER THAN SUPPORTING
THEM INTO THE ARTS BECAUSE
THERE'S NO PLACE ELSE FOR THEM --
AND IT ALSO TALK ABOUT THE ROLE
OF CREATIVE IN THE CALIFORNIA
WORK FORCE BECAUSE THAT BECAME
ABUNDANTLY CLEAR THROUGH LOOKING
AT THE REPORT.
SO AS I MENTIONED BEFORE THE
ARTS MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT IS NOW
THE LARGEST INDUSTRY SECTOR IN
CALIFORNIA EDUCATION -- THERE
ARE THIRTEEN SUB PATHWAYS WITHIN
OUR FOR MAJOR PATHWAYS THAT I
DISCUSSED THAT PEPARE STUDENTS.
TO TO FOR CAREERS IN MEDIA ARTS
IN ANIMATION IN GRAPHIC DESIGN
IN PROFESSIONAL FILL
PROFESSIONAL FILM IN DANCE --
THEATER AND MUSIC -- TO SUPPORT
THE ARTS MEDIA AND ENTERTAINMENT
EDUCATION WE HAVE ELEVEN MODEL
DEMONSTRATION SITE PROGRAMS AS
WE GREW ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACED WAS -- HOW ARE WE
GOING TO BE SURE THAT THE
QUALITY OF THE PROGRAMS IS HIGH
QUALITY -- WE HAVE A LOT OF KIDS
INTEREST IN ROLLING IN PROGRAMS
AND A LOT OF TEACHERS INTERESTED
IN THE AREAS BUT HOW COULD WE
ASSURE HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS.
SO WE TOOK A LOOK AT A MODEL --
USED BY SPECIALIZED SECONDARY
PROGRAMS OF CREATING A REGIONAL
TECHNICAL SUPPORT MODELS AND SO
WE HAVE A LEVEL OF THOSE AROUND
THE STATE ONE IN EACH
SUPERINTENDENTS REGION.
AND THESE ARE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
HIGH QUALITY CAREER TECH ED
PROGRAMS IN ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT.
AND THEY ARE REQUIRED TO SHARE
THEIR THEIR CURRICULUM THEIR
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE.
WITH OTHER SCHOOLS IN THE REGION
SO THEY PROVIDE REGIONAL SUPPORT
FOR A A ME PROGRAMS AROUND THE
STATE.
THIS PAST YEAR WE LAUNCHED.
FOR PILOT -- PRE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS IN ARTS ME IN FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION.
THIS WAS SORT OF GREW OUT OF OUR
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FILM COMMISSION AND THE
LEGISLATION THAT YOU GUYS HAVE
TALKED ABOUT ABOUT BRINGING --
FILM AND TELEVISION PRODUCTION
BACK INTO THE STATE AND ONE OF
THE PROVISIONS OF THAT IS.
IS THOSE -- PRODUCTION COMPANIES
NEED TO BE PART OF A CAREER
READY IN THIS PROGRAM.
AND SO AS PART OF THE CAREER
READING THIS PROGRAM WE PARTNER
WITH THE FILM COMMISSION ON
IDENTIFYING HOW CAN THOSE
PRODUCTION PROGRAMS ACTUALLY
ENGAGE WITH EDUCATIONAL ENTITIES.
BECAUSE FOR A LOT OF THE FOLKS
IN IN FILM AND TELEVISION
PRODUCTION THEY DON'T TALK TO
EDUCATORS AND THE FOLKS WHO WERE
IN EDUCATION VERY OFTEN.
DON'T HAVE REGULAR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE FOLKS ARE IN FILM AND
TELEVISION PRODUCTION.
AND SO THAT -- CAREER READING
THIS PIECE IS A WAY TO GET THAT
CONVERSATION STARTED SO THAT WE
CAN BE SURE THAT THE STUDENTS
THAT WE GRADUATE ARE READY FOR
THE CREATIVE WORK FORCE -- SO
WHAT ARE FUTURE KEYS TO GROWTH
IN ARTS MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT HOW
CAN WE GROW CONTINUE TO GROW
THESE PROGRAMS AND BILL THIS
PIPELINE AND ALSO BE SURE THAT
WE HAVE HIGH QUALITY PROGRAMS IN
PLACE TO PREPARE STUDENTS.
THE FIRST I THINK IT'S CONTINUE.
TO CONTINUATION EXPANSION OF
REPORTS LIKE THE OLDEST REPORT
THAT PROVIDE US WITH THE DATA WE
NEED TO ACTUALLY ARGUE FOR THESE
PROGRAMS TO MAKE THE CASE WITH
LEGISLATORS LIKE YOURSELF.
AND ALSO WITH LOCAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS AND AND SITE
LEVEL PRINCIPLES THAT THESE
PROGRAMS ARE IMPORTANT FOR KIDS
THAT THERE.
ARE PLACES FOR THESE KIDS TO GO
AND WORK -- THE SECOND IS
INCREASE INDUSTRY AND
LEGISLATIVE SUPPORT FOR CREATIVE
EDUCATION ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE DON'T DO AS WELL AS SAY
AGRICULTURE EDUCATION.
IS INDUSTRY ADVOCACY FOR ARTS
EDUCATION -- IF A COUPLE OF I
GUESS IT WAS LAST YEAR THE THE
AGRICULTURE EDUCATION PROGRAM
HAS SEVEN CONSULTANT SEVEN FOLKS
LIKE MYSELF.
AND THEY WERE FACED WITH
ELIMINATING ONE OF THOSE SEVEN
CONSULTANT POSITIONS.
AND THE AG ADVOCACY BOARD WENT
TO THE GOVERNOR.
AND HE SAID WHAT DO I HAVE TO DO
TO GET THESE EGG PEOPLE OFF MY
BACK.
AND IN FACT THEY KEPT THAT
SEVENTH POSITION SO THEY HAVE
SEVEN FOLKS SUPPORTING THEIR
HUNDRED AND THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS WHILE WE HAVE ONE FOR
OUR TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND STUDENTS -- SHOW
CONTINUED SUPPORT -- A CREATIVE
EDUCATION INCENTIVE GRANT.
THE ARTS AT THE AG EDUCATION HAS
AN INCENTIVE GRANT A LINE ITEM
IN THE BUDGET OF I THINK AROUND
FOUR POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
TO SUPPORT AGRICULTURE EDUCATION
OR AROUND THE STATE.
BUT THERE'S NO SUCH INCENTIVE
GRANT FOR CREATIVE EDUCATION.
THAT WOULD SERVE STUDENTS IN
GRADES K. THROUGH.
TWELVE AND THAT WOULD BE
VALUABLE.
AND THEN START UP FUNDING FOR A
ARTS MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT
TEACHER ORGANIZATION.
THIS -- ARTS MEDIA AND
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY SECTOR
INVOLVES TEACHERS WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY VISUAL PERFORMING
ARTS TEACHERS IN IN OUR TO IN
THEATER AND BRINGING THOSE FOLKS
TOGETHER IN AN ORGANIZED FASHION.
SO THAT THEY CAN HAVE A SINGLE
VOICE IN ADVOCACY FOR PIPELINE.
TO CAREERS IS AN IMPORTANT
COMPONENT -- ANOTHER IMPORTANT
PIECES IS THE ONE THAT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO MENTION AND
THAT IS DATA I KNOW THAT SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES ARE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT EDUCATIONAL DATA.
BUT HAVING AN EDUCATIONAL DATA
SYSTEM THAT ALLOWS US TO
IDENTIFY GAPS.
IN NOT ONLY SECONDARY EDUCATION
BUT ALSO IN ELEMENTARY EDUCATION
IS A CRITICAL PIECE OF PROVIDING
ARTS EDUCATION FOR ALL
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS.
AND THEN -- A CONTINUED FOCUS
THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION IN THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS AND YOU HAVE SEEN A
TREMENDOUS INCREASE IN ARTS
MEDIAN ENTERTAINMENT IS.
GENERALLY A RESULT OF THAT
SUPPORT AND SO THAT CONTINUING
THAT SUPPORT IS A CRITICAL PIECE
OF MAINTAINING THE PIPELINE FROM
THE EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT TO
THE POST SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL
ENVIRONMENT. TO THE INDUSTRY
JOBS THEMSELVES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ROOM WAS VERY.
ENCOURAGING TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
PUTTING A LOT OF ARTS WITH HIM
THE EMPHASIS ON ARTS IN THE CITY.
I MEAN THAT'S THROUGH THE AREA I
THANK -- OF WE THE CALIFORNIA
THE GENERAL NEED TO REVIEW --
EMPATHIZE SO IT WILL BE ON TO
THE NEXT PANELIST.
WE HAVE TV.
THE MORNING MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE TODAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CURIOSITY AND YOUR LEADERSHIP IN
THIS.
ARENA.
I'M I WANT TO START TODAY BY.
OFFERING A PERSONAL AND
HISTORICAL PERSPECTIVE ON ARTS
EDUCATION -- I WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN STILL LIVE IN A
NEIGHBORHOOD OF LA COUNTY --
ELLIE CITY KNOWN AS SAN PEDRO.
AND AT LAST YEAR MY DAUGHTER
GRADUATED FROM THE SAME MIDDLE
SCHOOL THAT I ATTENDED AND THAT
MY FATHER ATTENDED -- MY FATHER
GRADUATED FROM THERE IN THE
NINETEEN FIFTIES.
I WAS THERE -- WHEN PROP
THIRTEEN PASSED AND SIGNED FRONT
OF ME ONE YEAR THE ARTS IN
SCHOOL AND THE NEXT YEAR THEM
GONE?
AND I'VE NAVIGATED MY TWO
DAUGHTERS THROUGH THE EDUCATION
SYSTEM ENSURING THAT THEY HAVE
THE ARTS IN THEIR SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE THIS BEING MY FIELD I
KNOW THE IMPACT OF THE ARTS ON
BRAIN DEVELOPMENT ON COGNITIVE
DEVELOPMENT.
ON SOCIAL DEVELOPMENT ON AN
EMOTIONAL WELL BEING.
SO I'M MAKING SURE THAT MY
STUDENT MY CHILDREN HAVE ARTS
INSTRUCTION AS PART OF THEIR
PUBLIC EDUCATION.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THAT LOW --
INCOME PARENTS OR IMMIGRANT
PARENTS CARE LESS OR WANT LESS
FOR THEIR OWN CHILDREN.
BUT I AND I BELIEVE THAT A WELL
ROUNDED EDUCATION.
THAT INCLUDES THE ARTS BY
DEFINITION -- SHOULD NOT BE
SUBJECT -- TO CHILDREN WHOSE
PARENTS HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE THE
TIME OR THE RESOURCES TO
NAVIGATE THEM THROUGH A SYSTEM.
I'M OR JUST.
TO HAVE THE LUCK OF LANDING IN A
SCHOOL WHERE MAYBE A PRINCIPLE
OR SPECIFIC TEACHER VALUES THE
ARTS.
OF FORTY YEARS OUT FROM
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN I WILL SAY
THAT I BELIEVE THAT IT'S NOT
THAT THE OUT THE ARTS ARE NOT
VALUED AND PUBLIC EDUCATION.
I AM AND NOW IN A PLACE WHERE
I'M.
THINKING THAT AFTER THE FORTY
YEARS WE'VE LOST THE
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY FOR HOW TO
PUT THE ARTS BACK INTO PUBLIC
EDUCATION.
AND MAYBE ALONG THE WAY WE'VE
LOST SOME PUBLIC WELL.
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF ARTS
EDUCATION AT THE LA COUNTY ARTS
COMMISSION WHERE I OVERSEE
SOMETHING CALLED THE LA COUNTY
ARTS EDUCATION COLLECTIVE.
IT WAS SOMETHING STARTED IN TWO
THOUSAND TWO BY COUNTY
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS RECOGNIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF ARTS EDUCATION
FOR CHILD DEVELOPMENT. FOR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND FOR
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT.
AND SO BECAUSE LA COUNTY
EDUCATES 25% OF CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC EDUCATION STUDENTS.
THE COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WAS WORK BEING DONE TO SUPPORT
THE EIGHTY ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT ARE EDUCATING OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE.
WE STARTED THIS EFFORT IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE IN FIVE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND TODAY SEVENTY OF
THAT EIGHTY ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN LA COUNTY.
PLUS FIVE CHARTER SCHOOL
NETWORKS HAVE.
DEVELOPED AND ADOPTED OR IN THE
PROCESS OF DEVELOPING.
A STRATEGIC PLAN FOR PUTTING THE
ARTS BACK INTO THEIR SCHOOLS.
WE NEVER IMAGINED THAT IT THAT
WOULD WE WOULD GET TO THAT LEVEL
OF SCALE IN.
TWO THOUSAND THREE BUT WE'RE ON
PACE TO BE WORKING WITH ALL
EIGHTY ONE SCHOOL DISTRICTS BY.
TWENTY TWENTY WHICH GIVES US A
MOMENT OF UP TO A MOMENT.
TO CHECK OFF THAT FIRST
BENCHMARK AND TO RE.
REDEFINE WHAT WE MEAN BY SCALE
AND I WOULD ARGUE BY EQUITY.
M. P TO THIS POINT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE IS A
BELIEF THAT WE NEVER REALLY GET
TO SCALE AGAIN.
AND SO SCALE WAS WELL MAYBE SOME
DAY.
EVERY CHILD EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT WILL BE WORKING TOWARDS
PUTTING ARTS BACK IN THEIR
SCHOOLS.
AND WHILE WE'RE DOING THAT IN
TERMS OF ACTUALLY LET'S MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
HAVE HISTORICALLY BEEN UNDER
RESOURCE LET'S MAKE SURE THAT
THEY REALLY ARE GETTING IT.
WELL IF WE CHANGE OUR DEFINITION
TO SCALE. TO EVERY CHILD ALL
YEAR EVERY YEAR.
THE NET ALSO SHIFTS OUR
DEFINITION OF EQUITY WHICH IS TO
AND THOSE FROM HISTORICALLY
UNDER RESOURCE COMMUNITIES GET
MORE.
SO SCALE BECOMES ALL CHILDREN.
AND EQUITY BECOMES AND
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THOSE
WHO HISTORICALLY HAVEN'T
RECEIVED THEM.
IN JUST ABOUT A YEAR AGO THAT LA
COUNTY ARTS COMMISSION RELEASED
OF WHAT IT'S CALLED AT THE ARTS
EDUCATION PROFILE.
OF WHICH WAS A COUNTY WIDE
SNAPSHOT OF THE STATE OF ARTS
EDUCATION IN ALL EIGHTY ONE
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND I WOULD PUT
FORWARD THAT.
IT'S OF POTENTIALLY A MODEL FOR
HOW.
TO USE DATA COLLECTION OR HAVE
TO SHOW THE IMPACT AND VALUE OF
THE ARTS AND DATA COLLECTION
STATEWIDE -- IN PUTTING TOGETHER
THIS REPORT WE BUILT ON THE DATA
ALREADY COLLECTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WHICH TRACKS HIGH
SCHOOL COURSE WORK.
BUT WE ALSO ADDED ELEMENTARY
DATA WE LOOKED AT BOTH DISCRETE
ARTS INSTRUCTION SO ARTS COURSES.
AND INTEGRATED ARTS INSTRUCTION
AND WE LOOKED AT THE ROLE OF
COMMUNITY ARTS PARTNERS IN THE
PROVIDING ARTS INSTRUCTION IN
SCHOOLS.
AND WE DID THIS FOR THREE
REASONS ONE IS WE WANTED TO
COLLECT MEANINGFUL DATA THAT
THEN WE CAN GET BACK TO SCHOOLS
AND SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN
DEVELOPING THEIR OWN PLANS FOR
ADVANCING THE ARTS SO THAT THEY
WERE LOOKING UP WHAT WAS REALLY
IN PLACE.
AND IDENTIFYING STRATEGIES FOR
AYE AT FILLING GAPS.
WE ALSO WANTED THE DATA TO BE
PUBLICLY OF AVAILABLE WE WANTED
PERRANCE IN ONE PART OF TOWN TO
BE ABLE TO SEE WHAT'S BEING
OFFERED IN THEIR CHILD'S SCHOOL
AND TO BE ABLE TO COMPARE THAT
WITH WILL WHAT'S.
WHAT OUR CHILDREN ACROSS TOWN
PERHAPS IN A BETTER SOCIAL
ECONOMIC NEIGHBORHOOD?
WHAT ARE THEIR CHILDREN
RECEIVING IN TERMS OF ARTS
INSTRUCTION?
AND THEN FINALLY WE WANTED TO
IDENTIFY FACTORS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE QUANTITY.
THE QUALITY AND THE EQUITY OF
ARTS INSTRUCTION THAT WERE IS
PROVIDED IN SCHOOLS.
AND WE HAVE OVER TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SCHOOLS IN LA COUNTY.
I'M WE RECEIVED A DATA BACK FROM --
MORE THE FROM JUST UNDER A
THOUSAND SCHOOLS AND BECAUSE
THIS DATA REPRESENTS FORTY SEVEN
PER ONE OF THE SCHOOLS IN OUR
COUNTY WE WERE ABLE TO
GENERALIZE THESE FINDINGS ACROSS
ALL DISTRICTS.
SO WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT NEARLY
90%.
OF SCHOOLS ACROSS THE COUNTY
OFFER ARTS INSTRUCTION TO THEIR
STUDENTS.
I HAVE THEM DOUBLE CHECK THIS
DATA THREE OR FOUR TIMES BECAUSE
WITH THE CONSTANT BUT THE
CONSTANT WAY WE TALK ABOUT THE
ARTS OR THE ARTS ARE FIRST TO BE
CUT I WAS SHOCKED THAT IT WAS
THAT.
MANY SCHOOLS PROVIDING ARTS
INSTRUCTION.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO KNOW THAT
WE NEED TO BREAK THE MYTH THAT
THERE IS NO ARTS INSTRUCTION
PROVIDED IN SCHOOL.
WELL THAT WAS TRUE FOLLOWING
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN THAT'S NO
LONGER THE CASE AND WE NEED TO
WORK HARD TO CHANGE THAT
NARRATIVE -- WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE ARTS ARE
BEING TAUGHT LIFT UP MODELS LIKE
JACK WAS TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS
OF MODEL SCHOOLS SO THAT OTHERS
CAN LEARN FROM THEM -- AND TO
USE THIS AS A NEW BASELINE FOR
MOVING FORWARD.
BUT AS WE DIG DEEPER INTO THE
DATA WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT 90%
MEANS THAT. 90% OF SCHOOLS ARE
OFFERING SOME ARTS INSTRUCTION
TO SOME STUDENTS FOR SOME PART
OF THE YEAR [inaudible]
AND IT BECOMES AN INCREASINGLY
MORE INTERESTING AS WE LOOK AT
SCALE AND EQUITY SO WE KNOW THAT
AS EXPECTED MUSIC AND VISUAL
ARTS ARE MOST OFTEN TAUGHT.
WE KNOW THAT LESS THAN HALF OF
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS PROVIDE ANY
INSTRUCTION IN DANCE THEATER OR
MEDIA ARTS.
AND ONLY A ABOUT A HALF OFFER
ANY THEATER OR MEDIA ARTS
INSTRUCTION.
IF WE'RE LOOKING AT JUST SCHOOLS
WITH FOURTH GRADE.
WE KNOW THAT ONLY 10% OF SCHOOL
OF SCHOOLS WITH FOURTH GRADERS
PROVIDE YOUR LONG MUSIC
INSTRUCTION. TO ALL OF THEIR
STUDENTS.
AND LESS THAN 1% OF SCHOOLS WITH
FOURTH GRADERS.
PROVIDE YOUR LONG INSTRUCTION IN
MEN ANY ART FORM TO ALL OF THEIR
FOURTH GRADERS.
SO 190% OF SCHOOLS OFFER SOME
ARTS INSTRUCTION.
LESS THAN 10%.
WITH FOURTH GRADERS PROVIDE YOUR
LONG INSTRUCTION.
WE ALSO KNOW.
THAT IF YOU ARE A STUDENT FROM A
LOW INCOME IT COMMUNITY.
IF YOU ARE AN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNER.
OR IF YOU ARE A STUDENT OF COLOR.
YOUR SCHOOL IS NOT ONLY
PROVIDING LESS ARTS INSTRUCTION.
BUT IS PROVIDING LOWER QUALITY
ARTS INSTRUCTION THEN SCHOOLS
AND OTHER PARTS OF THE COUNTY.
AND THAT THE SCHOOLS WITH THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF WHITE STUDENTS
OFFER THE MOST ARTS INSTRUCTION
AND THE HIGHEST QUALITY ARTS
INSTRUCTION.
IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
THE LA COUNTY ARTS COMMISSION
RELEASED A REPORT CALLED
CREATIVE WORK.
AND WE WERE SPECIFICALLY
INTERESTED IN EXAMINING THE
CREATIVE OCCUPATIONS THAT WERE
REFERENCED THIS MORNING SO THOSE
JOBS THAT THE US DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR.
IDENTIFIES AS NEEDING CREATIVITY
IS ONE OF THE SKILLS FOR THOSE
JOBS BUT THEY CAN BE FOUND
ACROSS MANY AYE.
INDUSTRY SECTORS.
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT HALF OF
THESE CREATIVE?
OCCUPATIONS REQUIRE A COLLEGE
DEGREE.
WHICH MEANS THAT HALF OF THEM
DON'T.
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN THOSE
JOBS THAT DON'T REQUIRE A
COLLEGE DEGREE.
BECAUSE OF THE ACCESSIBILITY.
WE ALSO FOUND OUT THAT -- THEY
PAY ON AVERAGE A HIGHER MEDIAN
ANNUAL WAGE.
THEN THE COUNTY WIDE AVERAGE
WHICH MEANS THAT THESE ARE.
LIVABLE WAGE JOBS.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT.
ALL YOU INCLUDING THOSE THAT ARE
NOT IMMEDIATELY COLLEGE BOUND
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE LIVING WAGE.
JOBS.
LAST MONTH WE REACHED A RELEASED
SOMETHING CALL ANOTHER FIELD
SCANNED WHICH IS I BELIEVE IN
YOUR PACKET.
THIS CALL THE BUILDING CREATIVE
CAREER PATHWAYS FOR YOU.
I WOULD KNOWLEDGE THAT IT'S ONE
OF FIVE RECENT OF STATE RESEARCH
STUDIES ON THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
RELEASED IN LA COUNTY OVER THE
PAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
IT GREW OUT OF THAT COUNTIES
EFFORTS AT CULTURALLY CULTURAL
EQUITY AND INCLUSION.
AND IT IS LOOKING SPECIFICALLY
AT HOW.
WE CAN PROVIDE ACCESS TO THESE
TWO JOBS IN THE CREATIVE ECONOMY
TO YOUNG PEOPLE IN LA COUNTY.
INCLUDED NOT ONLY A LABOR MARKET
ANALYSIS AND INTERVIEWS WITH
YOUNG PEOPLE.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT ONE OF THE
MOST KEY FINDINGS WAS THAT THE
FIELDS.
DEVELOPED A TYPOLOGY FOR
THINKING ABOUT CREATIVE -- AND
PATHWAYS TO THEIR CREATIVE
ECONOMY SO A NEW WAY OF
ORGANIZING.
HOW WE PREPARE YOUNG PEOPLE?
WE NEED TO RECOGNIZE THAT ARTS
EDUCATION K. TWELVE ARTS
EDUCATION IS.
THE FIRST STEP IN THIS PROCESS.
CAREER EXPLORATION MAKING SURE
THAT FOLKS THAT YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THEIR FAMILIES KNOW WHAT THESE
JOBS ARE IS IMPORTANT.
THAT'S DISTINCT FROM.
CAREER A COLLEGE AND CAREER
READINESS MAKING SURE THAT YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
ARTS CAREERS ARE WELL PREPARED
TO BE ACCEPTED INTO THOSE FIELDS.
AND THEN COMPLETELY SEPARATE
WORK BASED LEARNING.
WHICH INCLUDES INTERNSHIP SO
OFTEN WE LUMP ALL OF THESE
THINGS TOGETHER AND NOW THAT WE
HAVE A CLEAR WAY OF THINKING
ABOUT THEM DISTINCTLY IT'LL
ALLOW US TO DEVELOP STRATEGIES
AROUND EACH OF THESE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF PREPARATION.
THIS CAN ALSO IDENTIFIES
CHALLENGES.
PARTICULARLY FOR SYSTEMS
INVOLVED YOUTH FOSTER YOUTH
THOSE THAT ARE INVOLVED IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM -- DOES
THAT HAVE FINANCIAL BARRIERS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION.
THOSE THAT ARE NOT ABLE -- TO
PARTICIPATE IN UNPAID
INTERNSHIPS BECAUSE THEIR
FAMILIES DON'T COME FROM -- AT
THE FINANCIAL MEANS TO WILL TO
SUPPORT THEM THROUGH THESE
PROCESSES.
AND ALSO CHALLENGES FOR BID FOR
BUSINESSES AND THAT WHAT WE CALL
THE ELUSIVE ENTRY OF ENTRY LEVEL
JOB.
SO MANY INTRO LEVEL JOBS THAT
ARE BEING FILLED BY -- YOUNG
PEOPLE WITH MASTERS DEGREES AND
ALSO ON THE IMPORTANCE OF
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR
CORPORATIONS.
SO -- ENDS WITH SAYING THAT --
FORTY YEARS AFTER PROPER PROP.
THIRTEEN WE HAVE BEEN WE HAVE
MADE PROGRESS.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
COLLECTING THE DATA SO THAT WE
KNOW WHERE WE STAND AND WE CAN
CONTINUE TRACKING PROGRESS
FORWARD.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW WHO IS
AND WHO ISN'T RECEIVING ARTS
INSTRUCTION.
AND TO GET TO THE PLACE WHERE
EVERY CHILD.
IS RECEIVING INSTRUCTION ALL
YEAR EVERY YEAR.
SO THAT EVERY PERSON IN.
THE STATE ENGAGES IN THE ARTS
ALL YEAR EVERY YEAR JUST BECAUSE
IT'S A FUNDAMENTAL.
PART OF HUMAN GROWTH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
AND IT'S NOT ONLY THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO AT THIRTEEN YEARS OLD
BEFORE THEY GET INTO HIGH SCHOOL.
ALREADY KNOW WHAT CAREER THEY
WANT TO GO INTO AND ARE
SELECTING A PARTICULAR MAGNET OR
C. T. BAG AT SCHOOL OR C. T. A.
C. T. PATHWAY.
BUT HOW DO WE ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
JOBS AS THEY MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH ON
THE WALL TO APPLY ALL OF THE THE
LA COUNTY ART YEAH COLLECTIVE.
AND BOARDS OF STRAPPING.
ON TO THE VERY VERY IMPORTANT --
ISSUE THERE TO COLLECTING DATA
YOU KNOW WE CAN ONLY OBJECTIVELY
IMPROVE THINGS THAT WE CAN
MEASURE.
SO THE FACT THAT YOU HAVE TO THE
STARTED THIS PROCESS AND COLLECT
THE DATA.
TRUMP'S SEVENTY ALL OF YOUR
EIGHTY SCHOOL DISTRICT IS REALLY
REALLY COMMENDABLE CAN I GO OUT
OF THE QUESTION OR WE SHOULD
LEAVE THE QUOTE TO YOU CAN
PROBABLY ANSWER THE QUESTION.
WHEN WE GO WAS TO THE NEXT
PRESENTER BUT I'M JUST?
VERY CURIOUS TO FIND OUT IF THE
LIST AT ANY PUSH BACK.
FROM THE TEACHERS OR
ADMINISTRATORS OF THE SCHOOL TO
SAY HEY YOUR GIVEN US --
ADDITIONAL OF OF WORK -- AND
HAVE NO FUNDING ATTACHED TO IT.
I REALLY LIKE TO FIND OUT.
US SO TWO THINGS ONE IS THAT WE
TRIED -- TO WE WORKED TO MAKING
SURE THAT THE DATA COLLECTION
WAS TIME -- AT THE SAME TIME OF
THE YEAR THAT THE STATE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION IS COLLECTING THE DATA
SO THAT -- THEY CAN GO HAND IN
HAND.
AND WE I USED IT AS AN INCENTIVE
TO THEN GO BACK AND HELP SCHOOL
DISTRICTS DEVELOP THEIR OWN
REGIONAL PLAN SO WE PROVIDED
THEM RESOURCES IN TERMS OF
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. TO DEVELOP
STRATEGIES FOR BRINGING THE ARTS
BACK INTO THEIR SCHOOLS.
AND SO WE FUNDED THE DATA
COLLECTION FOR THEM TO AND TO TO
REALLY PART TIME TO LUNCH THERE
NEEDS ASSESSMENT.
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NOW WE MOVE ON TO THE THE NEXT
TO A PRESENTER.
CLOSE WITH.
HIS SHOES YES SIR.
THIS IS A GAME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND AND FIRST OF ALL I'D
LIKE TO SAY I I TRULY APPRECIATE
THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR ALL OF
US AND SPECIALLY FOR ME IT'S A
GREAT HONOR TO BE HERE.
AND TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS A
LITTLE BIT OF MY FEELINGS ABOUT
THEIR ARTS EDUCATION AND THE
NEED FOR THAT.
AND THEN -- TO PRESENT TO YOU
SOME INFORMATION -- I'M THE
CHAIR OF CREATE CALIFORNIA AND
I'LL TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT CREATE IS.
AND I ALSO CURRENTLY SERVES A
PRESIDENT TO THE MORENO VALLEY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
GOVERNING MORE.
AND IT MIGHT MIGHT COME IN SOME
GOING.
TO INCLUDE A LITTLE BIT OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING AND THAT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT TO PUT IT IN THAT
PERSPECTIVE.
TO BUT I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
THREE CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THAT IT IS IMPORTANT --
IT IS IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION AND
SEVERAL OF THE MEMBERS ARE HERE
TODAY -- BUT BEFORE I DO THAT --
I HAVE A PRESENTATION AND I'M
GONNA GO THROUGH IT AND AND THAT
MAKE MY COMMENTS ON THAT.
SO THE FIRST THING I'D LIKE TO
SAY IS IS THIS -- GIVEN THE
GROWTH OF CREATIVE INDUSTRY IN
OUR STATE.
WHEN WE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR
STUDENTS IN THE K. TWELVE SYSTEM
SIX POINT TWO MILLION STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR SCHOOLS?
AND WHEN WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE SOON AS ARE NOT ONLY
YOU -- WELL PREPARED FOR THE
WORKFORCE BUT ALSO.
CREATE THE CREATIVELY PREPARE
FOR ANY CAREER TO DATE THEY
DECIDE TO PURSUE AFTER HIGH
SCHOOL THE THE THEY NEED THAT
CREATIVITY.
IN AND THE DATE THEY NEED TO BE
FULLY PREPARED WITH A WELL
ROUNDED EDUCATION WHICH INCLUDES
ARTS EDUCATION.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THE MOST
POWERFUL -- PATHWAY FOR STUDENTS
TO DEVELOP.
THAT DOES CREATIVE THINKING
SKILLS ARE THROUGH ARTS
EDUCATION IS CRITICAL.
IN THE EARLIER WAS STARTED IT
AND BE A KETTLE SYSTEM TO BETTER
BECAUSE THE MUCH PREPARE THE
STUDENTS ARE GOING TO BE. FOR
THE WORK FORCE.
AND THAT NOW THAT WE SEE THE
THERE'S A LOT OF CAREERS AND THE
AND THE WITH CREATIVITY NEEDED.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO TO PURSUE
THAT.
SO.
WE HAVE A CHARTER THAT SHOWS --
THREE THREE DATES IN THREE YEARS.
THREE THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN
HISTORY.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW THAT WHAT
WE'RE WHAT WE'RE LOOKING TODAY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADVOCATE
THAN WHAT WE'RE WORKING FOR AND
THEY ALL THE SAME THE RESULTS
HERE ARE LOOKING UP INFORMATION.
IS RELATED THIS TO SOMETHING
THAT WE ALREADY HAD IN THE PAST.
AND THESE THREE PIECES OF
LEGISLATION ORTIZ -- THREE THREE
MARKS IN HISTORY -- DID
SOMETHING.
FOR WHAT USED TO BE -- THE ONE
OF THE MODELS IN THE NATION AS
FAR AS CREATIVITY CATION.
IN CALIFORNIA THESE THREE MARKS --
DID SOMETHING PROBABLY AN
INTENTIONALLY BETTER.
CAN DISMANTLE WHAT WAS HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA AND ARTS EDUCATION.
AREA [inaudible]
AND THE TODAY -- WE'RE TRYING TO
GET BACK TO WHERE WE WERE BEFORE
BEFORE THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES
WHEN WE HAD THAT -- THAT -- YOU
KNOW THE MARK TO BE THE CREATIVE
STATE IN THE NATION [inaudible]
SO.
WHEN WHEN THOSE THREES -- THREE
THREE LEGISLATION TO PLACE IN
THE NINETEEN SEVENTIES.
SOME ORGANIZATIONS CONTINUE
ADVOCATING FOR ARTS BECAUSE THEY
STRONGLY BELIEVE IN THE ARTS AT
THE TIME AND PTA MANY OTHER
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS CONTINUE
TRYING.
TO TRY TO PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH
SOMETHING RELATED TO THE ARTS SO
THAT THE WASN'T.
TOTALLY -- TOTALLY GONE FROM
SCHOOLS.
BUT WHAT HAPPENED -- WITH THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS AND THE WITH THE
WITH THE NOT THEY'RE NOT
RESOURCES AND ON MANY DIFFERENT
FACTORS.
WHAT HAPPENED WAS AT THE TIME
THE EQUITIES IN THE DIVIDE
BETWEEN STUDENTS AND AFFLUENT
AREAS AND ON THERE ARE DESERVE
POPULATIONS WAS CREATED?
SO FROM THAT POINT FORWARD WE
HEARD ABOUT.
THE INEQUITIES THAT EXIST IN
SCHOOLS SOME STUDENTS GET MORE
SOME STUDENTS GET LESS SOME
STUDENTS DON'T GET ANY AT ALL.
SO THAT WAS CREATED BECAUSE OF
THOSE PIECES OF LEGISLATION SO
AGAIN WE'RE TRYING TO GET BACK
TO WHERE WE WERE BEFORE --
SENATOR ALLEN EARLIER YOU SAID
AND IT'S BASED ON THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT THAT.
THE CREATIVITY IN THIS CREATIVE
ECONOMY ONLY ONE OF TEN JOBS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE.
IN THAT PARTICULAR AREA.
AND SO HE WILL GIVE OUR STUDENTS
AN AXIS FULL ACCESS TO OUR TO
THE CATION ALL THE WAY FROM THE
KATE KATE -- GREAT TO THE
TWELFTH GRADE.
WE DON'T GIVE THEM ACCESS THEN
WE'RE CONTINUING LOSING THOSE
JOBS IN THE CREATIVE INDUSTRY.
SO IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT THE WE
WE CONTINUE SAID IN THE BASE A
SEVEN THERE'S STRONG PILLARS AND
THE CREATIVE.
INDUSTRY SO THAT WE HAVE MORE
JOBS [inaudible]
THAT.
SO.
CRITICAL FORTY IS A COALITION OF
DEDICATED INNOVATIVE LEADERS WHO
UNDERSTAND THAT TOGETHER WE HAVE
THE POWER TO CREATE LASTING
CHANGE FOR EVERY CALIFORNIA
STUDENT.
AND OUR MISSION IS TO ENSURE ALL
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO REACH THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL -- BY EVENTS IN
AN INDICATION MODEL THAT
PROMOTES CREATIVITY IN THE ARTS.
SO I TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN FORMER
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION ATTEMPT OR LOOKS ON
SEND A TEAM TO THE NATIONAL
EDUCATION LEADERSHIP INSTITUTE.
TO LEARN A LOT OF TO NOTE TO
LEARN ABOUT THAT.
ARTS EDUCATION AND THEY CAME
BACK WITH THE ON FIRE TO ELEVATE
CREATIVITY AT THE HEART OF
EDUCATION.
THEY CAME BACK WITH A LOT OF
IDEAS THAT CAME BACK WITH A LOT
OF A LOT OF RECOMMENDATIONS.
SO -- WHAT HAPPENED AT THE TIME
THAT THEY WENT CREEK CALIFORNIA
WAS FORMED INCREASE CALIFORNIA
IS AGAINST THE COALITION -- AND
AND MAINLY FORM -- I'VE
REPRESENTING FIVE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HAVE CONTINUE
WORKING AND HAVING THEIR THE
COLLECTIVE IMPACT -- ON NOTE ON
CREATIVE CREATE -- ARTS
EDUCATION IN THE STATE.
AT THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AS YOU CAN SEE AT THE
TOP.
THE CALIFORNIA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS THE
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
RECTIFICATION.
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA THE
CALIFORNIA OUR SCHOOLS ALL THESE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE TREMENDOUS
ADVOCATES FOR THE ARTS AND HAVE
CONTINUES WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
ON DIFFERENT INITIATIVES.
AND INDIVIDUALLY AND
COLLECTIVELY ENOUGH TO CREATE
CALIFORNIA WE'RE TRYING TO WORK --
SO THAT WE MAXIMIZE THE BENEFIT
OF HAVING THAT PARTICIPATION OF
THOSE THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES AND
YOU CAN SEE MANY AREAS THAT.
EACH OF THOSE ORGANIZATIONS ARE
WORKING ON A PDA VERY STRONGLY --
INCLUDING GAUGING THE PARENTS IN
THE ARTS.
CALIFORNIA'S EDUCATION WITH OUR
TONSILS OUT TO THE ORGANIZATIONS
AND ON AND ON AND ON AND OF
COURSE THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION WITH A DIFFERENT.
INITIATIVES AND THE DIFFERENT --
AREAS -- THE DATE THAT THEY
CONTINUOUSLY -- PURSUIT.
SAW THREE TELEPHONE IN THE
POLICY COUNCIL IS -- TRYING --
TO BRING UP THE RECOMMENDATIONS
SO THAT SO THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING OUT ON AN IMPROVING THE
EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM THE ARTS.
SINCE THEY SUPERINTENDENT BY THE
CONSTRUCTION AS THE COALITION.
TO PRODUCE A BLUEPRINT FOR
CREATIVE SCHOOLS.
WHICH WOULD THE FOCUS AND SEVEN
AREAS. SEVEN AREAS AND WHICH
INCLUDED OVER SEVENTY
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
IMPROVE OUR TO THE CATION AND
STATE.
THE YET THE COUNCIL -- AFTER THE
LIGHTS IN THE BLUEPRINT AND AT
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT AREAS WERE
DIFFERENT RECOMMENDATIONS.
IDENTIFIED RESEARCH AND DATA AND
EQUITY AS THE TWO AREAS THAT
NEEDED TO BE FOCUS ON FIRST.
SO WITH THAT -- I LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT A COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF
AREAS THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON AND ONE OF THM IS -- RELATED
TO THE DATA THE HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT SEVERAL TIMES ALREADY
TODAY.
THE DATA PROJECT AND CALIFORNIA
IS THE FIRST STATE TO
PARTICIPATE ALLOW TO THE DATA
AFTER THE NEW JERSEY PROJECT YOU
JUST HAD A PROJECT WHERE.
WHERE THEY WERE AND LICENSE
CONTINUOUSLY THE DATA FOR ARTS
EDUCATION AND STATE?
SO CALIFORNIA WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING SIMILAR SO THEY TOOK
ON THE BIGGER SAY PILOT.
AND THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE JUST AS
DOES AN EXAMPLE OF WHAT IT IS
AND IS THIS IS THE DATA PROJECT
IS A DASHBOARD THAT THAT
INCLUDES.
INFORMATION.
FOR ALL THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
ALL HIGH SCHOOLS MIDDLE SCHOOLS
IN THE STATE.
AND OF COURSE -- AT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED BEFORE SEVERAL TIMES
THE ELEMENTARY INFORMATION IS
NOT COMPLETE YET IT'S NOT THERE.
BECAUSE THE ELEMENTARY EDUCATION
IS NOT A REQUIREMENT TO BE
SUBMITTED BY THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND AND I LIKE TO ADD HERE
COMMENT THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SHE
WOULD TRULY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
ON ON SUBMITTED THAT.
THE BILL THAT THAT IS LOOKING
FOR REQUIRE IN ELEMENTARY
EDUCATION TO BE SUBMITTED.
BECAUSE I THINK IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION
NOT ONLY AT THE HIGH SCHOOL AND
MIDDLE SCHOOL LEVEL.
BUT ALSO AT THE ELEMENTARY LEVEL
IF WE ARE LOOKING FOR WAYS.
TO ASSIST OUR STUDENTS AND TO
IMPROVE THE SYSTEM ALL THE WAY
FROM THE BEGINNING WE HAVE TO
HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
AND I'M PLEASED TO SAY THAT THAT --
IN IN THE EVEN WHEN THE
INFORMATION IS NOT REQUIRE.
SEVERAL DISTRICTS THE US BEEN
MENTIONED SEVERAL DISTRICTS TO
MEET THE INFORMATION ANYWAY BUT
IT'S ONLY ABOUT 70% OF DISTRICTS
STATEWIDE WE HAVE OVER ONE
THOUSAND SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
PROBABLY ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY TWO HUNDRED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE SUBMITTED THE
INFORMATION.
SO THAT DOESN'T GIVE YOU A CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHAT IS HAPPENING AT
THAT LEVEL.
SO AGAIN I THANK YOU FOR THAT
EFFORT BECAUSE IT IS CRITICAL
THAT WE HAVE THAT INFORMATION.
AND THE IN THROUGH THE DASHBOARD
WE HAVE LEARNED THAT ABOUT 39%
OF MIDDLE AND HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE.
RECEIVE OR HAVE ACCESS TO AND
PARTICIPATE IN ONE OR MORE ARTS
DISCIPLINES.
AND THE THIS THESE LAST WORD
ALLOWS YOU TO SEE A YOU KNOW THE
DIFFERENT COLOR STILL DO.
YOU KNOW THE THE THE DARKER
COLORS ARE MORE WHERE THEY COULD
CALL LEASES ARE WITH THE
CRITICAL.
AREAS THAT NEED TO BE WORKED ON
OUR AND THE CLEAR CALLERS ARE
WHERE THERE'S SOMETHING GREAT
BEING DONE.
IN THE AREAS AND THEN -- THE
OTHER PIECES THAT BAY
INTERPRETATION OF WHAT IS
EARLIER AND YOU KNOW SOME
DISTRICTS ARE DOING SOMETHING AT
CERTAIN TIMES AND FOR ONLY
CERTAIN STUDENTS.
SO THE INFORMATION THAT'S WHY
IT'S CRITICAL TO HAVE IT.
THAT WHEN WE COMPARE TO OTHER
STATES IN THE NATION.
THERE ARE TEN STATES THAT ARE
USING THE DATA PROJECT -- TO
ANALYZE THE DATA AND ARTS
EDUCATION.
I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THE IN
OUR STATE 39% OF STUDENTS HAVE
THAT PARTICIPATION.
IT WILL LOOK AT WISCONSIN
WISCONSIN HAS 77% PARTICIPATION.
IF WE LOOK AT OHIO HI IT HAS 82%
PARTICIPATION.
WHY IS IT THAT THE DIFFERENCE?
WHEN I GO BACK TO THAT SLIDE
THAT SHOW THE THREE MARKS IN
HISTORY AND I BELIEVE THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE DIFFERENCE WAS
CREATED WITH THOSE THREE MARKS?
WITH THOSE TWO PIECES OF HISTORY
THE PLACE.
AND DISMANTLE WHAT WAS HAPPENING
IN CALIFORNIA SO NOW WE'RE AT
239%.
AND AGAIN MANY ORGANIZATIONS
FIGHTING TO BRING IT BACK TO A
MUCH HIGHER LEVEL.
SO AGAIN -- THE BACK TO THE DATA
CALIFORNIA IS THE ONLY STATE NOT
REQUIRED REPORTING THE
ELEMENTARY DATA.
THE ONLY STATE IN THE NATION.
WHICH I BELIEVE IS -- IT'S BEEN
DETRIMENTAL TO THE SYSTEM SO
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING THAT
INFORMATION.
AND WE HEAR FROM SOME DISTRICTS
THAT ARE WILLING TO TO PROVIDE
THAT INFORMATION BUT ALSO THAT
SHOULD BE A REQUIREMENT.
AND THE I HAVE MY NOTES HERE AB
THREE NINETY EIGHT IS A BILL TO
YOU.
THE QUEUE -- AUTHORED AND AGAIN
WE APPRECIATE THAT.
AND THE SAD TO HEAR THAT IS NOT
HAVING.
PERFORMANCE BUT GLAD TO HEAR
THAT YOU'RE WILLING TO SUBMITTED
AGAIN.
IN THE FUTURE OF ANOTHER CONCERN
IS THE EQUITY GAP WHICH WHICH
AND AND THAT THAT'S WHERE YOU
CAN SEE CLEARLY.
WHEN YOU GO IN AND YOU CAN SEE
ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE STATE
THAT ANY ANY HIGH SCHOOL AND YOU
CAN SEE [inaudible]
THAT -- SOME GRABS TELL YOU THAT
THE STUDENTS THAT ARE RECEIVING
LESS OR THAT HAVE ACCESS TO LAST
YEAH ARTS EDUCATION ARE DOES
THAT ARE ON THE DAY.
THE FREE LUNCH PROGRAM.
THAT MEANS THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
THE LOW INCOME AREAS ARE THE
ONES THAT ARE NOT HAVING.
ENOUGH AXIS.
YEAH SO SO THAT'S AN EQUITY
ISSUE THAT WE WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE CONTINUE FIGHTING
BECAUSE IT IS NOT FAIR FOR THE
STUDENTS THAT ARE IN THE LOW
INCOME AREAS TO NOT HAVING.
THAT OPPORTUNITY. TO TO NOT HAVE
THAT ACCESS AND TO EXPLORE THEIR
TALENTS AND SKILLS AND THE CREE
TV.
THEY THEY SHOULD HAVE THE SAME
OPPORTUNITY OF OTHERS.
TO ANOTHER PLEASE THAT I'D LIKE
TO MENTION TO YOU IS A THE
DECLARATION OF STUDENT RIGHTS TO
EQUITY IN OUR LEARNING.
CREATE CALIFORNIA PRODUCED A
DECLARATION OF STUDENTS RIGHTS.
WHICH IS A A DOCUMENT THAT
EXPLAINS IN SIX SIX ITEMS WHAT
THE STUDENTS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
RECEIVE NOTIFICATION.
AND AND THERE IS A THE STUDENT
RIGHTS TO EQUITABLE [inaudible]
ARTS EDUCATION.
MEANING THAT ALL THE STUDENTS
WHO HAVE ACCESS TO TO THE ARTS
ONCE AGAIN.
ALL THE STUDENTS EVERY SINGLE
STUDENT.
SO WHAT WE DID IS WE EMBEDDED
THIS DECLARATION IN -- TO BOARD
RESOLUTION [inaudible]
AND WE HAVE A MAP IN OUR IN OUR
WEBSITE AND CREATE CALIFORNIA
WEBSITE WHERE YOU CAN SEE WHAT
DISTRICTS HAVE ALREADY ADOPTED
AND WHAT ORGANIZATIONS HAVE IT
READY ABOUT ADOPTED THESE.
RESOLUTION AND I I HAVE CONCERT
HERE I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT MARIN
THE VALUE WAS THE FIRST SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE STATE THAT ABOUT
THAT.
SUCH RESOLUTION.
AND IT IS A COMMITMENT THAT WE
MADE TO PROVIDE ACCESS TO ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS IN THE DIFFERENT
AREAS AND WE'RE WORKING.
VERY HARD TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN IN
OUR DISTRICT BUT AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE TRYING TO CONVINCE
ORDER SCHOOL DISTRICT'S OTHER
SCHOOL BOARDS. TO ADOPT THE
RESOLUTION AND DO THE SAME THING
THAT WE'RE DOING AS WELL AS
OTHER ORGANIZATIONS.
GAVE ACCESS TO ALL THE STUDENTS.
TO ARTS EDUCATION EQUITABLE.
ARTS EDUCATION.
NOT EARLIER -- SEVERAL SPEAKERS
TALKED ABOUT THE NEW STANDARDS.
AND CREATE CALIFORNIANS PARTNERS
ARE WORKING TO BUILD AWARENESS
ABOUT THE NEW STANDARDS IN
WORKING ON WAYS TO HELP
EDUCATORS.
UNDERSTAND THE NEW STANDARDS.
WHICH EVERY DIFFERENT FROM OUR
PREVIOUS STANDARDS.
SO -- THIS WAS ALREADY MENTIONED --
AND SO WE'RE VERY AWARE AND WILL
CONTINUE WORKING ON THAT
[inaudible]
SO OF IN A STUDY CONDUCTED BY
OUR A PUBLIC RELATIONS COMPANY
WE REALIZE THAT SOMETIMES THE
IMAGE THAT PUBLIC MY CALLED BAR
TO THE KITCHEN IS THAT IT'S A
NICE THING TO HAVE.
YEAH THAT'S A PROBLEM THAT WE
HAVE AND IN MANY MANY OF OUR
SCHOOLS NOT ONLY READ ABOUT IT
BUT IN OTHER AREAS.
TOO AB AND THAT WHAT IS THE
DEFINITION OF HAVING A GOOD
QUALITY EQUITABLE EDUCATION.
AND AND HAS TO BE MEANINGFUL THE
HAS TO BE -- BY LINE WITH THE
STANDARDS AND AND THAT.
THE CREATING BAD WELL ROUNDED
EDUCATION FOR STUDENTS TO START
JUST HAVING A PIECE OF PAPER AND
A PEN OR PENCIL.
AND ALLOWING THE STUDENTS DO
WHATEVER THEY WANT THAT HAS TO
BE STRUCTURE.
AND NOW IT'S HARD TO COMMUNICATE
THAT THAT TO STUDENTS AND TO
EDUCATE OR SOMETIMES AND TO THE
PARENTS.
BUT IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
CONTINUE TO FINDING PROPERLY
WHAT ARTS EDUCATION THIS IS NOT
JUST.
CHILDREN AS PLAYED BY.
MANY POOR ARTS EDUCATION
[inaudible]
SO -- WHAT WE HAVE AND MARK ON
IS A CAMPAIGN TO SHOW THAT
CREATIVITY IS NOT OPTIONAL?
IN THIS OUR PUBLIC WILL CAMPAIGN
DOUBTS THAT ARTS EDUCATION IS A
POWERFUL PART OF THE CORE
CURRICULUM AND IT IS A BETTER
THAN DAY AND THE EDUCATION CODE.
THAT ARTS EDUCATION IS PART OF
THE CORE CURRICULUM SO WE WANT
TO STRESS THAT TO ALL THE CHIU
GATORS AND STATE THROUGH.
YOU THAT THE RESOLUTION OR TO
OUR CAMPAIGN.
OR TWO WEBSITE MANY MANY
DIFFERENT OR OTHER AREAS
[inaudible]
AND THE IS A PART OF A PART OF
THE CORE CURRICULUM THAT CAN
DELIVER THE CREATIVE THINK IS A
PROBLEM SOLVER STEP WE NEED IN
ALL OF OUR INDUSTRIES.
AT THE END OUR LEADERS AND NOT
ONLY THE CREATIVE -- INDUSTRY
WORK BUT IF THE ANY ANY --
INDUSTRY IN OUR STATE -- THE
THERE IS A NEED FOR THAT CREEPY
READING AND THE AND THEIR MINDS
AND STUDENTS [inaudible]
SO.
THE LIGHTS LIKE.
WHAT IF EVERY SCHOOL WAS A
CREATIVE INCUBATOR THAT STUDENTS
CAN'T WAIT TO GET TO EVERY
SINGLE DAY?
SO THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE AND
THAT KIND OF ENVIRONMENT THAT WE
WANT TO CREATE IN OUR SCHOOLS WE
WANT OUR STUDENTS TO BE EXCITED
TO GO TO SCHOOL BECAUSE NORMALLY
THEY'RE ACADEMICS BUT BECAUSE
THERE'S A PIECE OF ART WAITING
FOR THEM.
SOMEWHERE WHERE THEY CAN TRULY
EXPRESS THEIR FEELINGS THERE
THINKING -- DECREE TV.
AND WE SEE A LOT OF EXAMPLES IN
OUR SCHOOLS.
AND THAT'S WHY WE IN THE ONE OF
THE VALUE WE MADE THAT
COMMITMENT TO OPEN OPPORTUNITIES
FOR ALL OF OUR STUDENTS.
AND IT IS HAPPENING ANYWHERE
DIRECT CITED TO SEE THAT
HAPPENING IN THAT ALL LEVELS
FROM KINDERGARTEN TO TWELVE RATE
AND ALL THE AREAS.
TO BUT WE RECENTLY HAD A A A AN
ADVANCE IN PALM SPRINGS AND
SUMMIT ARTS SUMMIT WOULD WE
INVITED SEVERAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE AREA TO JOIN US.
AND THE HIGHLIGHT WAS -- WHAT
WAS HAPPENING IN READ THE BALLOT
HOW IT'S HAPPENING AND HOW IS IT
BEING DONE?
SO WE'RE PLEASED TO SHARE THAT
INFORMATION WITH WITH THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO BE HERE.
AND THAT.
THAT'S MY PRESENTATION THANKS SO
MUCH.
WELL THANK YOU SO MUCH -- AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR ALL
YOU'VE DONE AND THE COMMITTEES
SPECIALLY TO THE A STUDENT --
FIVE OF THE DID -- SLIDE GOOD
FOR THE LAST.
ONE YOU KNOW YOU HAVE THE
CREATIVITY.
RIGHT NEXT TO A MENTAL HEALTH.
YOU KNOW I I JUST WANT TO POINT
OUT A LOT OF OUR OUR TO MONEY
THROUGH OUR CONSUL CALIFORNIA IS
ACTUALLY GOING. TO THE JUNE I
HALL TO THE PRISON.
AND AND TO TO TO TO VETERAN TO
ASSOCIATION TRYING TO HELP
TOMORROW -- WAS THERE OF A
MENTAL YOU SHOES AT AS WELL SO --
ANY QUESTIONS.
CENTER [inaudible]
YEAH.
I HAVE ANOTHER QUESTION OF BOTH
FOR NEEDS IS A WHAT IS YOUR
SUCCESS IN AN L. A. CONTE.
WOULD YOU HAVE YOU EVER TRIED TO
USE THAT DATA. TO GO AFTER SOME
PRIVATE FUNDING PRIVATE GRANT
INSIDE I WOULD THINK.
WOULD WOULD -- LISTED THE TO THE
DISCREPANCY THE GAP.
I KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF OF
PRIVATE SECTOR THE BILL.
ALSO WANTED TO CLOSE THE GAP FOR
THE ARTS A COLLECTIVE IS A
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP SO
FUNDED BY LA COUNTY GOVERNMENT.
AND THE PULL OF THIRTY
PHILANTHROPIC CORPORATE AND
FOUNDATION PARTNERS.
ON SO HAD THEY DID HELP FUND THE
AT THE DATA PROJECT -- AND WHILE
I BELIEVE THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT PHILLIP PHILANTHROPIST
PLAYS AN IMPORTANT ROLE IN.
RISK TAKING INNOVATION TRYING
NEW MODELS TESTING NEW
PROTOTYPES -- IT'S REALLY THE
GOVERNMENT FUNDING THAT ALLOWS
SCALE AND SUSTAINABILITY.
AND WOULD PUT FORWARD THAT WHEN
WE THINK ABOUT MATH INSTRUCTION --
WE DON'T THINK ABOUT
PHILANTHROPY AND NONPROFIT ARTS
OR NOT NONPROFIT COMMUNITY
PARTNERS STEPPING IN TO PROVIDE
THE BULK OF INSTRUCTION.
AND SO -- I WOULD OFFERED THAT
WE'RE AT A UNIQUE MOMENT WE HAVE
A REAL OPPORTUNITY HERE WITH THE
NEW STANDARDS BEING PASSED THE
NEW FRAMEWORK COMING ON BOARD.
I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT -- MINE
WAS THE GENERATION.
THAT WAS HIT BY PROPOSITION
THIRTEEN WHICH MEANS THAT.
ANYONE IN THIS ROOM YOUNGER THAN
ME COULD HAVE GONE THE COMPLETE
K. TWELVE EDUCATION WITHOUT ANY
ARTS INSTRUCTION.
SO IF WE REALLY ARE GOING TO
LOOK AT BROAD SCALE SYSTEMS
CHANGE AND REALLY GET TO ISSUES
OF SCALE IN EQUITY.
THEN I WOULD ENCOURAGE US TO
THINK OF THE ROLL OUT OF THE
FRAME WORK SIMILAR TO HOW WE
THOUGHT OF COMMON CORE.
THAT WAS A DRAMATIC SYSTEMS
CHANGE ACT COULD A DRAMATIC
SHIFT IN HOW WE THINK ABOUT
EDUCATING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE.
AND TO RECOGNIZE THAT.
REALLY PUTTING THE ARTS BACK IN
EVERY SCHOOL FOR EVERY CHILD
WE'LL TAKE THAT KIND O
INVESTMENT TO ENSURE THAT
TEACHERS HAVE THE SKILLS AND
ABILITY TO REALLY IMPLEMENT ARTS
INSTRUCTION K. [inaudible]
TWELVE RIGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU KNOW --
WE DO GO.
TO A PRIVATE SECTORS.
OF FOR FUNDING ON FOR A GRANT TO
PROMOTE OUR STEM EDUCATION
WITHOUT THE AID IS NOT THE SAME
EDUCATION SOLD.
AT A DIRT THAT'S WHY WITH
THINKING THAT THERE SHOULD BE
SOME OPPORTUNITIES.
ALSO I THE GOVERNMENT THAT WOULD
BE ABLE TO TAP THEM FOR FOR
ASSISTANCE.
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT ARE
GOOD TO AB.
THREE NINETY EIGHT REALLY -- IT
WOULD JUST PRETTY MUCH GOT GOT A
GARDEN AND AMANDA IN THE
ASSEMBLY -- I'M HOPING THAT WILL
MOVE A BILL. TO PUT TOWARD THE
CENTER SO I AM HOPING SENATOR
ALLEN OR WILL HAVE A WOULD BE
WORK TO WITH ALL OF YOU HERE. TO
THE POST SO OFTEN NEED TO BACK
INTO THE A. B.. THREE NINETY
EIGHT WHAT'S THAT I'M GOING --
TO TURN IT OVER BACK TURN IT
BACK TO SENATOR ALLEN FOR OURS.
THIRTY THE FINAL SECTION OF OUR
HEARING ALL RIGHT THANK YOU SO
MUCH THAT SOME MEMBER AND AND
WE'LL BE WATCHING THAT BILL
CLOSELY THANK YOU TO THE THE
PANELISTS.
AND I ALSO WANT TO WELCOME OUR
GOOD FRIEND A FRIEND OF THE ARTS --
CENTER -- NIELSEN USE YEARS
WHILE HAVING JUST DRIVEN DOWN
FROM HIS DISTRICT.
SO WE WELCOME YOU SENATOR.
I WHAT WE'VE BECOME SUDDENLY A
LITTLE I'M TIME CONSTRAINT -- AS
I COULD BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
THINGS HAPPENING BUT BUT LET'S
LET'S WELCOME UP OUR NEXT PANEL
WE'RE GONNA SPLIT UP INTO TWO
THIS IS PANEL THREE MENTORING
CONNECTING AN INSPIRING YOU
THROUGH THE ARTS WILL START WITH --
BUT IF MONEY FASTER GARCIA --
BONNIE WHO'S A GOOD FRIEND AND
AND SOMEONE WHO WORKS VERY
CLOSELY WITH EDWARD JAMES OLMOS
AND OTHERS ON THE LATINO FILM
FESTIVAL USE IN A PROJECT --
KIANA CONLEY AND ALSO MICHAEL WE
ARE AND WHAT WE INVITE THEM UP
TO THE PRESENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
HI.
THE BODY MAY YOU MAY HI.
YEAH.
THANK YOU IT'S A PLEASURE BEING
HERE ON THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF PRESIDENT
OF THE LATINO FILM INSTITUTE --
WE HAVE TO PROGRAMS ONE IS THE
USE AND A PROJECT -- WHICH AND
WILL SHOW ON A MINUTE AND THE
OTHER ONE IS THE LOS ANGELES
LATINO INTERNATIONAL FILM
FESTIVAL SO IF WE COULD HAVE THE
VIDEO -- YEAH.
FILM.
INFLUENCES THE HUMAN MIND IT'S A
VERY POWERFUL MEDIUM THE WAY YOU
ADDRESS DIVERSITY.
IS BY GOING BACK TO THE DRAWING
BOARD AND STARTING IN FOURTH
GRADE THE MISSION OF THE YOUTH
SUMMER PROJECT IS VERY SIMPLE
IT'S ABOUT CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN THE CLASSROOM
FOR MOST UNDERPRIVILEGED.
CHILDREN AND TO CLOSE THE
OPPORTUNITY GAP IN THE
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THE PROGRAM INVOLVES TWO FOR
MAKING MENTORS GOING INTO THE
CLASSROOM AND THEY TEACH THE
ENTIRE PROCESS OF FILM SO HOW TO
GENERATE IDEAS HOW TO WRITE THE
SCRIPT.
ALL THE PLANNING IN PRE
PRODUCTION FILMING ITSELF IN
PRODUCTIONS WELL AS POST THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
TREATING THE STUDENTS AS
COLLEAGUES RATHER THAN.
LECTURING TO THEM.
INSPIRED THE COMMUNITY TO THE
POINT OF WHERE.
KIDS ARE ACTUALLY ATTENDING
SCHOOL MORE WE TALK ABOUT
PROJECT BASED LEARNING.
SO RATHER THAN JUST TAKING A
BOOK AND TALKING ABOUT A
PARTICULAR SET OF CONCEPTS IN
THE BOOK IT'S IT'S GOT A
PRACTICAL APPLICATION.
IS NOT BE SHY AND MYSELF. TO
NEVER GIVE UP THE SAILOR IN THIS
PROGRAM WAS TO COLLABORATE WITH
OTHERS EXPRESS THEMSELVES.
THEY THINK IT'S JUST A DIFFERENT
WAY TO APPROACH LEARNING THIS IS
THE ONLY PROGRAM I KNOW.
THAT BRINGS IN INDUSTRY IN THIS
CASE ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY.
INTO THE CLASSROOM.
INTO THE SCHOOL SITE.
INTO THE DISTRICT.
CREATIVITY CRITICAL THINKING
COMMUNICATION AND COLLABORATION.
ALL THOSE VALUES ARE SO MUCH A
PART OF FILMMAKING WE CREATE
LIFELONG LEARNERS.
AND LIFELONG PROBLEM SOLVERS
THIS IS THE ONLY PROGRAM I KNOW
WHERE TEACHERS PRINCIPALS
SUPERINTENDENTS IMPORTANT SAME
DISKETTES 100%.
I THINK THIS ROOM SHOULD BE.
AROUND AGAIN THERE'S OTHER
PROGRAMS IT'S MORE LIKE LOOK AT
THE BOARD AND YOU JUST GONNA
LEARN THIS.
AND HAND FILLED YOU ACTUALLY GOT
TO MESS AROUND WITH EQUIPMENT.
WHY ARE YOU HERE SAME?
HERE WE KNOW WHICH I WOULD HAVE
HAD THIS CLASS WHEN I WAS IN THE
FOURTH GRADE.
MY WORK WOULD HAVE BEEN
COMPLETELY DIFFERENT ULTIMATE
GOAL IS TO TRY TO GET THE YOUTH
CENTER PROJECT INSIDE EVERY
FOURTH GRADE CLASS THROUGHOUT
THE UNITED STATES I AM THE
FOUNDER.
AND CREATOR OF THE USE OF THE
PROJECT NUMBER -- ITS PROJECT
BASED WE TOOK THE CURRICULUM OF
THE AMERICAN FILM INSTITUTE
WHICH IS A MASTERS BASED PROGRAM
ONE OF THE BEST IN THE COUNTRY.
TOOK THEIR CURRICULUM AND PUT IT
pDESIGNED THE INTERFACE WITH
DOCTOR RICHARD MILLER WHO WAS AT
THE TIME SUPERINTENDENT SANTA
ANA SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I WHEN IT FIRST STARTED I
FEEL AT AND THIS IS A PROGRAM
THAT EDWARD JAMES OLMOS FOUND.
AT THE TIME THIS BEGAN I THOUGHT
WELL.
WHEN YOU WHAT DO YOU MEAN WHEN
YOU DO A FILM BECAUSE EVERYTHING
IS DONE BY THE HEADS?
THE YOU TAKE THIRTY KIDS DO.
EVERYONE OF THEM RIGHTS TELLS A
STORY FIRST.
THEY WRITE THE STORY.
A BREAK UP INTO FIVE PRODUCTION
TEAMS.
THEY DECIDE WHICH ONE OF THE
STORIES COUNTY FILM.
ALL OF THEM DO THE SCRIPT.
THEY ALL DECIDE WHO'S GONNA DO
WHAT JOB.
ARE THEY START WRITING THE
SCRIPT STORY BOARDING THAT GOING
THROUGH PRODUCTION USUALLY BY
JANUARY.
ARE THE END OF IT THEY DECIDE
WHAT MUSIC THERE'S GOING TO BE
THEY GET THEM.
THE MARKETING DONE ON AT THE
BEGINNING WE ALL FORM AN LLC.
SO THEY KNOW THE BUSINESS THEY
KNOW THE BUSINESS SIDE OF IT.
THE PRINCIPAL BECOMES THE CITY
SO THEY HAVE TO GET A PERMIT TO
FILM ANY PLACE OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM.
ARE THE THEY THEN HAVE THE FILM
SHOWN AT IF THEY'RE IN
ELEMENTARY IT SHOWN AT THE
OSCARS THE ACADEMY OF MOTION
PICTURES ARTS AND SCIENCES AND
ACADEMY.
PAYS FOR THE BUS AND LUNCH.
IF THEY'RE IN MIDDLE SCHOOL OR
HIGH SCHOOL THERE SHOWN AT
CREATIVE ARTISTS.
IN THE NORTH -- WE HAD THE FILM
SHOWN PIXAR BECAUSE WE'RE TO
STATEWIDE -- THE NEXT SHOWING
AND THIS IS WHERE THEY SEE THEIR
FILM UP ON ON THE BIG SCREEN A
PROFESSIONAL SO.
WE ASK THAT THE NEXT SHOWING BE
THE COMMUNITY SHOWING WHERE THEY
CAN ENGAGE THE COMMUNITY.
AND THEN THE HOUSE OF LAST YEAR
WE HAD WHAT WE CALLED AN
INDUSTRIAL SHOWING WHICH IS
THEIR FILMS ARE SHOWN.
AT THE LOS ANGELES LATINO
INTERNATIONAL FILM FESTIVAL
WHICH IS THE LARGEST MOST
PRESTIGIOUS.
INTERNATIONAL FILM FESTIVAL ON
MOBILE PHONES.
AND WHAT WE DID THIS TIME WAS WE
PUT IN A USE PROGRAM I USE
CINEMA.
FESTIVAL.
WHERE WE SHOWED HUNDRED EIGHTY
FIVE FILMS?
AT CHINESE THEATER -- IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN INTERNATIONAL FOCUS
WAS THE ONLY ONE OF THE WORLD.
THE REAL IMPORTANT THING IS WHAT
ARE THE OUTCOMES YEAH WE GO.
RIGHT THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL.
RECENTLY WE'VE -- RANGE AN
AGREEMENT WITH CHAPMAN WERE
CHAPMAN'S GIVING TEN
SCHOLARSHIPS A YEAR. TWO SANTANA
HIGH SCHOOL GRADUATES -- THEY GO
THROUGH THE PROGRAM AND NOT IN
TO SELL IT IS INTO ALL AREAS.
BECAUSE WE KEEP SAYING THAT THE
PRODUCT IS THE STUDENT NOT THAT
FILL.
AND IT'S ALSO -- WE CONNECTED IT
TO THE FILM FESTIVAL BECAUSE
WE'RE LOOKING ABOUT SHRINKING
THE OPPORTUNITY GAP.
AND GIVING KIDS OPPORTUNITIES
FOR JOBS IN THE INDUSTRY.
OUTCOMES ARE I ONLY HAVE
ANECDOTAL DATA RIGHT NOW -- BUT
WE HAVE RETAINED OF STANFORD'S
CENTER FOR ASSESSMENT LEARNING
INEQUITY TO DO A COMPREHENSIVE.
STUDY WHICH IS COMING OUT IN
JUNE.
BUT SOME OF THE PRELIMINARY
INDICATIONS ARE -- HAVE BEEN
STANDING.
SO FOR INSTANCE IN ENGLISH --
LITERACY OR ACQUISITION -- WHEN
COMPARED TO OUR CLASS?
A NON YCP CLASS HAD KIDS THAT
TESTED AT SEVEN KIDS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE YEAR WERE
PROFICIENT.
AND IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
SEMESTER WENT TO EIGHT OUR CLASS
SIX WERE TESTED PROFICIENT AND
BY THE MIDDLE THE YEAR WENT.
TO THIRTEEN IN RALEIGH WHICH
TESTS OUT AT YOU KNOW THERE
STATEWIDE TESTING.
AT THE THIRTY FOR THIRTY
PERCENTILE.
I MEAN AND IT'S VERY.
OUR OUR KIDS AVERAGE.
THE FIFTIETH IN THE ONES IN OUR
CLASSES I MEAN IT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THEY'RE GOING TO BE UP TO A
YEAR BUT THE REASON FOR THE
OUTCOMES.
AS I VAST SUPERINTENDENTS IS
BECAUSE EVERY KIDS ENGAGE.
NOBODY IS THERE ALL ENGAGED AND
THEY ALL WANT TO BE THERE.
AND SO THINGS HAPPEN ATTENDANCE
GOES UP -- THEY'RE MORE
INTERESTED IN SCHOOL AND ANOTHER
THING HAPPENS THEIR TEAMMATES
COLUMN UP TO MAKE SURE THEY GET
TO SCHOOL BECAUSE THEY GOT TO
GET THE PROJECT DONE.
BY THE END OF MAY -- SO AND THE
MOVE SOME DRAMATIC THINGS HAVE
HAPPENED WITH RESPECT TO ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS -- THERE'S A
THING CALLED EL TELLS AND THAT'S
IN SOPHOMORES AND HOT THAT'S IN
HIGH SCHOOL WERE LAKE
TRANSITIONING WITH.
ONE AND THE DATA ON THAT'S
PRETTY STUNNING BECAUSE IF
YOU'RE INTENT GREATER HIGH
SCHOOL YOU HAVE A TRANSITION
YOU'RE NOT GOING.
TO THE NUMBERS ARE THAT THE
NUMBERS OF PEOPLE KIDS THE
TRANSITIONS ABOUT ZERO ONE IF
YOU'RE LUCKY.
TO CAMPBELL UNION BROUGHT THIS
PROGRAM INTO THEIR SCHOOL AND IN
THE FIRST SEMESTER. THIRTY OUT
OF THIRTY TWO KIDS TRANSITIONED
INTO ENGLISH.
AND SO.
OF THAT THE DISTRICT DECIDED TO
DOUBLE THE SIZE OF THE PROGRAM.
IN FACT OUR BEST ASSESSMENT IS
OR YOU KNOW WHATEVER WHAT OF OUR
DISTRICTS DONE -- ARE DISTRICTS
PALMDALE STARTED WITH ONE
THEY'VE EXPANDED TO THREE
CLASSES WE'RE GOING TO FIGHT
NEXT YEAR.
SANTA ANA STARTED -- IN FOURTH
GRADE THEY NOW HAVE A FULL
PATHWAY.
OUR OTHER DISTRICTS HAPPENED.
NOW THE CHALLENGE IS FINDING OF
COURSE BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT.
ARE THERE ARE NO FREE LUNCHES
THIS COSTS BECAUSE WE PAY FOR IN
THE INDUSTRY TO COME IN AND GET
THIS DONE.
SO IN TERMS OF WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION -- NUMBER
ONE IS THIS IS VOCATIONAL
BECAUSE WE GIVE KIDS ACT I DON'T
LIKE THAT WORD BUT IT'S CAREER
TRAINING.
WE GIVE KIDS AN OPTION. TO THEY
WANT TO GO THE ACADEMIC ROUTE.
WE'RE TRYING TO FIND A PATH FOR
THAT.
BUT BY THE END OF THAT FOURTH
GRADE CLASS EVERYONE OF THOSE
KIDS KNOW THAT EVERY JOB IN THE
FILM ON A SET.
SO THEY CAN DECIDE WHICH WAY.
THEY WANT TO GO AND AGAIN THIS
PURPOSE OF THIS ISN'T TO CREATE
FILMMAKERS.
IS TO CREATE LIFE LONG LEARNERS.
OUR AND WE HAD AND I JUST GIVING
YOU A SNIPPET OF OUR DATA -- AND
IT'S BEEN PRETTY SPECTACULAR.
I CAN'T.
UNDER ESTá OVER YOU KNOW I
CAN'T OVERESTIMATE IF YOU WILL
THE IMPACT OF BRINGING IN THE
PROFESSIONAL SIDE LOLLIES.
AND OUR PARTNERSHIPS WITH
INDUSTRY PEOPLE.
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN URGING FOLKS
TO GIVE OUR KIDS -- INTERNSHIPS
IN HIGH SCHOOL EVEN THOUGH THE
USUALLY DON'T DO IT TO ABOLISH.
AND A AND BECAUSE OF OUR KIDS.
THEY KNOW ABOUT THE BUSINESS --
THEY'VE BEEN PRETTY SATISFIED SO
THE CATEGORY AND OTHER FOLKS --
SO MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN GIVING
HIGH SCHOOL INTERNSHIPS VERSUS --
COLLEGE.
ONE SO -- WITHOUT MORE.
GONNA TRY TO KEEP MY TIME.
SO EVERYBODY CAN GET ELECTION
TIME.
SO ONE IF I WERE TO HAVE ASKS
ONE WOULD BE.
IF WE CAN WORK WITH THE RULES SO
THAT MY TEACHERS AT VERSUS MY
MENTORS -- IN THE DISTRICTS THAT
WE HAVE CAN QUALIFY FOR C. T.
FUNDING. TO THE UP THE THE OTHER
BIG DEAL HERE IS.
YOU KNOW THE TYPE.
FINANCES THAT THE DISTRICTS HAVE.
AND WHAT I'VE NOTED IS THAT YOUR
TWO DIFFERENT TYPES OF
SUPERINTENDENTS.
THEIR SUPERINTENDENTS WHO ARE
WANTING TO TAKE THE RESOURCES
AND INVEST.
AND GET OUT COMES -- WHERE
THEY'RE GETTING AND THEY ARE
GETTING ALL COMES?
OUT WHERE THEY'RE HAVING
EXPANDED ATTENDANCE -- INCREASED
TENANTS AND THEY SEE VALUE -- IN
DIFFERENT WAYS EVEN IN UP TO AND
INCLUDING THEIR ADA SO THAT'S AN
INVESTOR SUPERINTENDENT.
AND THE OTHER ONES ARE I'M JUST
SO OVERWHELMED BY MY BUDGET
DEFICITS I REALLY CAN'T AFFORD
TO BRING IN AN OUTSIDE PROGRAM I
GOT TO TAKE CARE OF THE FOLKS
THAT ARE IN HERE.
AND THOSE ARE VERY THAT'S A VERY
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT.
SO IF THERE'S A WAY TO ALLOCATE
OR IN CASE ENHANCE FUNDING.
SO THAT DISTRICTS THAT WANT TO
INVEST CAN GET SOME ASSISTANCE
IN INVESTING.
AND SO THAT'S OUR SECOND THING
THE OTHER FINAL POINT I WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE IS THAT.
WE ASK AND WE GO INTO THE MOST
CHALLENGED.
DISTRICTS AND WHEN WE GO INTO A
DISTRICT WE SAY WELL OF COURSE
WE'RE HERE TO SERVE YOU.
BUT GIVE US YOUR MOST
CHALLENGING ENVIRONMENT -- WE
ARE IN THE NORTH AND SOUTH ROUTE
IN -- IN.
BRAWLEY ALL THE WAY UP TO ALLEN
WRONG.
BROUGH -- WE ARE -- PALMDALE
OXNARD -- AND WE SAY THAT WE ARE
THE LATINO FILM INSTITUTE YOU
CINEMA PROJECT.
NOT BECAUSE WE'RE ONLY FOCUSING
ON WHAT THE NO KIDS.
IT IS BECAUSE THIS PROGRAM WAS
DEVELOPED BY THE LEFT IN A
COMMUNITY AND WE HAVE --
EXPENSIVE TURN WHEN IT AS A GIFT
TO ALL CHILDREN.
SO IT DOESN'T MATTER WHETHER
YOU'RE AT RISK.
YOU CAN BENEFIT FROM THIS.
BUT THAT ARE AT RISK COMMUNITY
AND THAT'S EVERYBODY -- GETS A
LOT OUT OF THIS AGAIN I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT THIS PROGRAM.
NOW THIS REAL SPECIAL WORK WITH
THE WITH THE YOUTH I MEAN I AND
I AND I AND I ALWAYS SEE THESE
ABSENT OUR REGARDS TO TO MISTER
ALMOST AS WELL AS AND AND YEAH
INSPIRATION BEHIND THAT SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT PRESENTATION --
LET'S MOVE FROM FILM TO MUSIC --
AND OTHER IMPORTANT.
GO FROM FROM.
FROM -- AN OSCAR SO THE GRAMMYS --
WILL LITERALLY HAVE WILL GO TO
THE KEY ON AND AND MICHAEL SO SO --
THE RECORDING ACADEMY AMONG
OTHER THINGS -- RUNS THE THE
GRAMMY -- WORDS IN IS AN
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT -- DRIVER IN
IN OUR IN OUR MUSIC THE MUSIC
SIDE THE CRITICAL NEED WE'VE
BEEN DISCUSSING TODAY AND SO.
I CAN HAVE -- THIS EXACTLY
RECTOR OF THE RECORDING CARRIES
LA CHAPTER AND THEN MICHAEL UP
IN SAN FRANCISCO SO REALLY DOES.
AND IN BOTH OF YOUR YOUR
PORTFOLIO IS INVOLVED -- NOT
JUST THOSE CITIES BUT ALL OF
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
SO WE WE WELCOME THE TWO OF YOU.
TO PRESENT A BIT ABOUT YOUR WORK.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US TODAY
THANK YOU THE US AND AROUND THE
THANK YOU TO HEAR CHIU US OVER
TO LAUREN TO ALL OF YOU FOR FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY IT'S AND
IT'S ALWAYS AN HONOR TO BE ABLE.
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
MUSIC IN CALIFORNIA AND
ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES TO
EDUCATION BECAUSE WE FEEL THAT.
THE PART OF OUR WORK -- AS
SENATOR ALLEN MENTION MY NAME'S
MICHAEL WINNER ON THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE RECORDING
ACADEMY SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER.
WE ARE A MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION --
I AM ALSO A SONGWRITER PRODUCER
ENGINEER FORMER TOURING ARTIST
AND KIND OF RUN THE GAMUT OF ALL
OF THE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
GIGS YOU CAN DO IN THE MUSIC
INDUSTRY -- SO IT'S IT'S IT'S
BEEN REALLY FASCINATING TO BE
HERE TODAY AND LEARN.
AND OF HOW THE STATE IS
FUNCTIONING WITHIN THE CREATIVE
ECONOMY -- I'M ALSO THE PARENT
OF A THREE AND A FIVE YEAR OLD
WHO ARE BOTH NOT IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND IT'S NEAR AND
DEAR TO MY HEART SEE.
HOW THE STATE WORKS ON BRINGING
THEM INTO OUR CREATIVE WORLD
YEAH THEIR EDUCATION -- JUST
ABOUT THE RECORDING ACADEMY WE
AS AN ORGANIZATION REPRESENT THE
VOICES OF PERFORMERS SONG
WRITERS PRODUCERS ENGINEERS AND
ALL MUSIC PROFESSIONALS SO
THAT'S WHAT OUR MEMBERSHIP IS
MADE OUT OF WE'RE DEDICATED TO
ENSURING THAT THE RECORDING ARTS.
REMAIN A THRIVING PART OF OUR
SHARED CULTURAL HERITAGE -- IT
IS ALSO WE ALSO INVEST IN WE
HONOR OUR HISTORY AND ALSO
INVEST IN OUR FUTURE THROUGH THE
GRAMMY MUSEUM AND THE GRAMMY
MUSEUM FOUNDATION -- WHERE WE DO
A LOT OF WE ALSO ADVOCATE ON
BEHALF OF MUSIC CREATORS WE
SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN?
STATE CAPITOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AS WELL AS IN WASHINGTON
DC -- AND THEN WE ALSO HELP
MUSIC CREATORS IN TIMES OF NEED
THROUGH MUSIC CARES WHO PROVIDES --
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE TO PEOPLE
WITH HEALTH OR FINANCIAL CRISES
TO MUSIC PROFESSIONALS -- AND
OBVIOUSLY AS SENATOR ALLEN
MENTION WE ALSO ARE -- WE HONOR
ARTISTIC EXCELLENCE THROUGH THE
GRAMMY AWARDS WHICH IS --
MUSIC'S ONLY PEER RECOGNIZED
ACCOLADE SO OUR AWARD IS
ACTUALLY PRESENTED TO MUSIC
CREATORS BY MUSIC CREATORS AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
VERY ROUD OF AND AS THE WORLD'S
LEADING SOCIETY OF MUSIC
PROFESSIONALS -- WE WORK YEAR
ROUND TO FOSTER A MORE INSPIRING
WORLD FROM MUSIC CREATORS.
GOOD GOOD EARLY AFTERNOON AS THE
EARLY MORNING HI -- MY NAME IS
KIANA CONLEY I AM THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE LOS ANGELES
AFTER THE RECORDING ACADEMY --
BUT I THINK PERHAPS MORE
IMPORTANTLY I AM A NATIVE
ANGELINO I WAS BORN AND RAISED
IN HAWTHORNE CALIFORNIA -- ICE
BOYS.
I ACTUALLY WENT TO THE SAME
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL AS BRIAN
WILSON -- AS I LEARNED ABOUT
WHILE I WAS IN ELEMENTARY SCHOOL
AND HAVE KEPT THAT WITH ME -- SO
YEAH THERE'S A SANDBOX THERE I
THINK WE YES WE PLAYED ON THE
SIX I'M SO.
LONG LOVE OF HIS EXACTLY -- AND
SO YES I AM YOU KNOW AND THEN
AND THEN THEY'D A NATIVE OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA PARTICULAR
THE SOUTH BAY AREA -- BUT I ALSO
AM EDUCATED I HAVE BEEN EDUCATED
THROUGHOUT -- MY SCHOOLING IN
ARTS PROGRAMS -- IN ARTS
EDUCATION -- I HAVE BEEN BOTH A
PERFORMER MYSELF -- INVOLVED IN
MUSICAL THEATER AND THEN WHEN I
WENT INTO I STUDIED AT THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
MATHEMATICS AND SCIENCE WHERE I
ALSO LET -- A BIT OF OUR DANCE
PROGRAMMING THERE AND THEN WHEN
I GOT INTO UNIVERSITY ONCE YOU
SCA -- AND CONTINUED AND
PERFORMING ARTS THERE -- THOUGH
I WAS ALSO IN BUSINESS AND
DECIDED THAT THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
WAS A CAREER FOR ME SO BEING
ABLE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE VALUE OF
ARTS EDUCATION FROM --
ELEMENTARY ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TO COLLEGE -- IS VERY CLOSE TO
MY OWN PERSONAL EXPERIENCE --
AND AND I AM OF THE BENEFACTOR
OF WHAT WAS OFFERED HOWEVER
SMALL IT MAY HAVE BEEN -- AT
THAT TIME SO WHILE WE ARE BEST
KNOWN OFFENDER AND A BENEFICIARY
AND OF AN ASSOCIATION ARE A
BENEFACTOR KNOWN ABOUT THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
WHILE -- WE ARE BEST KNOWN FOR
THE GRAMMY AWARDS WE ARE FIRST
AND FOREMOST A MEMBERSHIP
ORGANIZATION AS MICHAEL HAS SAID --
WERE MADE UP OF CAREER
PROFESSIONALS AND CREATORS IN
THE MUSIC INDUSTRY IN MANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE NAMES THAT YOU
WOULD RECOGNIZE -- THE MANY MORE
OF THEM WORK AND LESS VISIBLE
AREAS OF THE INDUSTRY.
ALL THE MAKE UP A KEY PART OF
WHAT IS THE FABRIC OF OUR
CREATIVE ECONOMY AND MOST OF
THEM HAD THE GOOD FORTUNE TO
RECIEVE MUSIC EDUCATION -- WHEN
THEY WERE GROWING UP?
SO IN CALIFORNIA IS WHERE OUR
HEADQUARTERS ARE BASED WERE
BASED IN LOS ANGELES IT'S THE
HOME OF THE LARGEST PERCENTAGE
OF OUR ORGANIZATION -- MY
MEMBERSHIP AND IN LOS ANGELES
REPRESENTS ONE QUARTER OF OUR
MEMBERS ABOUT THE WHOLE WE HAVE
SIXTY FIVE HUNDRED MEMBERS AT
THE LA CHAPTER.
IN OUR OTHER CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
SAN FRANCISCO OF REPRESENTS THE
FOURTH LARGEST -- IS THE NEXT
LARGEST IN CALIFORNIA AND IT'S
THE FOURTH LARGEST WITHIN OUR
ORGANIZATION JUST BEHIND NEW
YORK AND NASHVILLE SO
COLLECTIVELY -- OUR STATE
REPRESENTS EIGHT THOUSAND OF THE
MEMBERS OF OUR ORGANIZATION
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE OF THAT --
THAT GROUP AND AND LARGELY
REPRESENTS WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
PROBABLY -- A LARGE PERCENTAGE
OF THE MOST INFLUENTIAL MEMBERS
OF THE MUSIC INDUSTRY.
SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIA AS LIKELY THE
CREATIVE CAPITAL THE U. S. I
THINK IT'S QUITE ARE YOU GOING
TO SAY THAT THE EPICENTER OF THE
MUSIC AND A PRIZE IN THE
FOUNDATION.
IS BASED IN CALIFORNIA
PARTICULARLY -- THE NORTHERN AND
THE AND THE SOUTHERN REGION.
YEAH I'M AND MUSIC AND ARTS
EDUCATION ADVOCACY IS ACTUALLY
REALLY ARE.
A CRITICAL PART OF THE WORK THAT
WE DO I RECORDING ACADEMY --
AND THAT IS WE RECENT WE ALSO DO
AS I MENTIONED NATIONAL ADVOCACY
RECENTLY PASSED THE MUSIC
MODERNIZATION ACT -- THROUGH THE
UNITED STATES CONGRESS
UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH BOTH HOUSES --
AND SIGNED INTO LAW WHICH IS THE
FIRST MAJOR COPYRIGHT LAW TO
PASS THROUGH THE SINCE --
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX WE BELIEVE
VERY STRONGLY THAT SUPPORTING
MUSIC CREATORS AND COPYRIGHT
OWNERS IN GENERAL THROUGH
LEGISLATION IS CRITICAL.
BOTH FOR PROTECTING OUR FUTURE --
MUSIC MAKERS AS WELL AS OUR
CURRENT MUSIC MAKERS -- AND
RIGHT NOW ARE YOU ARE
LEGISLATION SUPPORTS FOCUS ON
STABILIZING THE FINANCIAL FUTURE
OF OUR OF OUR WHOLE INDUSTRY.
AND WE CAN'T SEPARATE THE NEED
FOR PREPARING THE CREATIVE
FOUNDATIONS OF THOSE WHO WILL.
INHERIT -- CREATIVITY IS DEEPLY
EMBEDDED IN CALIFORNIA'S
IDENTITY -- WE ARE KNOWN AS THE
STATE THE CONTINUES TO CREATE
THE MOST POPULAR WORKS OF ART IN
THE WORLD -- WE CALIFORNIA IS
SYNONYMOUS WITH MUSIC AND FILM
AND CREATIVITY.
AND WE ARE A BEACON TO CREATIVE
PROFESSIONALS EVERYWHERE I KNOW
THAT BECAUSE I MOVED HERE FROM
GEORGIA.
WHICH IS STILL IN A LOT OF OUR
OUR PEOPLE FROM.
OUR STATE BUT I MOVED HERE FROM
THERE BECAUSE CALIFORNIA HAD
SUCH A RICH CULTURE AND SUCH AN
IMPORTANT.
PLACE FOR BRINGING IN.
VOICES THAT CAN DO WHAT WHATEVER
FEELS RIGHT TO THEM THERE'S SUCH
FREEDOM HERE THERE'S SUCH A
SUPPORTIVE COMMUNITY AND A
NETWORK IN A FABRIC OF
PROFESSIONALS FROM ALL KINDS OF
GENRES AND I THINK.
AS MENTIONED EARLIER IN THE
STUDIES THAT WERE PRESENTED.
THE VARIETY THEM INDUSTRIES JUST
THE HUGE DIVERSITY OF CREATIVE
INDUSTRIES IN THIS STATE MAKES.
MAKES FOR A UNIQUE CULTURE THAT
EXISTS PRETTY MUCH KNOW WHERE
ELSE.
AND AND SO FOR US -- CREATIVITY
IS ALSO AT THE HEART OF
ENTREPRENEURSHIP.
AND PRETTY MUCH ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE ENTREPRENEURS IN ONE
SENSE OR ANOTHER WE ALSO
REPRESENT SOME OF THE SMALLEST
BUSINESSES.
YOU CAN THAT CAN EXIST A SONG
WRITER IS OF FREESTANDING SOLO
ENTERPRISE AND THEY CAN.
MAKE A LOT OF MONEY FROM ONE
SINGLE HIT THERE LIKE THE GOLD
DIGGERS OF THE PAST SO.
THIS IS IT THIS IS THE WAY THAT
OUR ECONOMY IS OFTEN FUNCTIONED
AS BOOMER BUST IN THE MUSIC
INDUSTRY IS NO DIFFERENT -- OUR
MEMBERS ARE THE CREATIVE
PROFESSIONALS THAT MAKE THE
MUSIC YOU LISTEN TO TODAY YOU
YOU KNOW THEIR WORK WHETHER YOU
KNOW THE PEOPLE OR NOT AND AND
IT AND I'VE AND I NOTICED THAT
FROM THE STUDY WE ARE HARD TO
QUANTIFY.
WITHIN THE ECONOMY BECAUSE SO
MANY OF OUR OUR MEMBERS AND THE
PEOPLE MAKING THE MUSIC YOU EVEN
HEAR ON THE RADIO OR THAT ARE
TRENDING ON SPOTIFY.
ARE MADE BY PEOPLE WHO DON'T FLY
OVER THE RADAR AND THEY'RE NOT
HIRED BY MAJOR CORPORATIONS AND
THEY'RE NOT ON THE EASY TO READ
TAX ROLLS AND THOSE SORTS OF
THINGS BECAUSE THEY ARE.
THEY'RE HUSTLERS.
THAT IS THE THAT IS THE KEY
PIECE OF OUR OF OUR OF ECONOMY
THOUGH BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE
HUSTLERS WHO ARE WORKING ON THE
STREETS AND MAY NOT BE EVEN
EARNING ENOUGH TO PAY TAXES FROM
THE MUSIC CAREER.
MAY EVENTUALLY GO ON TO BECOME
MAJOR ARTISTS AND SO WE WE WE
REALLY TRY AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
SUPPORT AND REPRESENT THOSE
PEOPLE AS WELL. ONE UNIQUE THING
ABOUT THE ARTS OBVIOUSLY AS
WE'VE ALL BEEN TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IS THAT IT PROVIDES SKILLS
AND KNOWLEDGE -- TO STUDENTS
THAT STUDENTS NEED TO DEVELOP
THE CREATIVITY AND DETERMINATION
NECESSARY FOR SUCCESS -- OUR
CREATIVE ECONOMY AND WHAT WE CAN
OFFER TO THE CREATIVE ECONOMY BY
INVESTING IN THE ARTS IS PROBLEM
SOLVING SKILLS DECISION MAKING
SKILLS CREATIVE THINKING.
BUILDING SELF ESTEEM TEACHING
SELF DISCIPLINE TEAM BUILDING
COLLABORATION AND GOT ALL GREAT --
ACCOUNTABILITY LOS ANGELES
NATIVE AND GRAMMY AWARD WINNER
JOSH GROVE AND HAS BEEN QUOTED
AS SAYING ALL OF THE THINGS IN
ARTS EDUCATION GIVES A YOUNG
PERSON ENHANCE THEIR LEADERSHIP
SKILLS AND HELP RAISE GRADES.
THE ARTS PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES
FOR CREATIVE TALENT AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES AND
INFLUENCES CREATORS AS CHANGE
AGENTS THAT ARE INTEGRAL AND
LOCAL COMMUNITY SUCCESS AND
PROVIDING FURTHER INSPIRATION --
SO WHETHER THEY YOU KNOW THERE'S
A BENEFIT NOT ONLY TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS BUT ALSO THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE HEAVILY
INFLUENCED BY THEM -- LOOKING AT
CALIFORNIA BASED ARTS EDUCATED
MUSIC CREATORS THEY CONTINUE TO
BE THE BACKBONE OF THE GLOBAL
MUSICAL SUCCESS STORIES THAT
HEAVILY INFLUENCE TODAY'S YOUTH
CULTURE.
SO WHETHER THE ARTIST HIMSELF IS
OUT OF YOU KNOW -- A NATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA OR NOT -- A LOT OF
THE COLLABORATORS THAT THEY WORK
WITH ARE ARE TYPICALLY ARTS
EDUCATED MUSIC CREATORS.
OF FOR EXAMPLE.
LET'S SEE THE SECRET INGREDIENT
IN THE MUSIC OF CURRENT HIP HOP
CHANGE AGENT IN COMPTON
CALIFORNIA NATIVE KENDRICK LAMAR
WHO IS A THIRTEEN TIME GRAMMY
AWARD WINNER.
IS A FELLOW ANGELINO NAME
TERRACE MARTIN AND TERRACE AS A
MUSIC INSTRUMENTALIST PRODUCER
THAT HAS APPEARED ON EVERY
SINGLE KENDRICK LAMAR ALBUM.
HE WAS ONCE POINT AS A CHILD
PRODIGY WHEN RELEASED A MIXTAPE
AT THE AGE OF THIRTEEN AND THEN
HE CONTINUED HIS ARTS EDUCATION
BY STUDYING SAXOPHONE.
AT SANTA MONICA HIGH SCHOOL --
AS WELL AS LOCK HIGH SCHOOL IN
LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA I THOUGHT
YOU'D APPRECIATE THAT AND PUT
THAT BACK.
ON VIKING -- ANY AND AND
KENDRICK LAMAR TODAY IF YOU'RE
JUST LOOKING AT THE INFLUENCE AT
THIS ARTS EDUCATED COLD MUSIC
COLLABORATOR.
HAD ON WHO CANTICLE MAR IS IN
THE MUSIC THAT IS INFLUENCING
THE YOU HE'S CURRENTLY THE TOP
IN R. A.'S TOP TWENTY CERTIFIED%
ARTISTS WERE DIGITAL SINGLES
WITH OVER FORTY ONE MILLION
UNITS -- BEING TRACKED -- SO
THERE'S A DIRECT.
CORRELATION -- TO HOW IT'S
INFLUENCING THE YOUTH WHETHER
THEY ARE THEMSELVES
PARTICIPATING AS MUSIC CREATORS
ARE NOT -- AND THERE ARE.
A LOT OF STUDIES TO BACK THIS UP
AS YOU ALL ARE NO DOUBT AWARE --
AND I LEARNED I KNOW I WAS
TRYING TO SEND YOU THIS PRIOR TO
THIS OR MAKING INTO THAT
BEAUTIFUL BOOK YOU HAVE BUT JUST
A FEW.
THAT'S A THE THERE WE ALSO HAVE
KIND OF CAME ACROSS IN OUR IN
OUR HEARING THIS -- THE ANY I
HAD COMMISSION TO TWENTY TWELVE
STUDY -- THAT SHOWED THAT HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM UNDER
RESOURCE ENVIRONMENTS WHO ARE
HIGHLY INVOLVED IN THE ARTS HAVE
BETTER GRADES AND ARE LESS
LIKELY TO DROP OUT MORE LIKELY
TO GO ON TO COLLEGE -- THE
COLLEGE BOARD'S NATIONAL TASK
FORCE ON ARTS AND EDUCATION
RECOMMENDS THE GREATER ACCESS TO
ARTS EDUCATION CAN SERVE AS AN
EFFECTIVE TOOL IN CLOSING THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP -- INCREASING
THE NUMBER OF UNDERSERVED
STUDENTS THAT ACHIEVE THE
HIGHEST LEVELS OF EDUCATION --
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION'S
TENURE REVIEW OF ARTS EDUCATION
FUNDED PROGRAMS FINDS THAT
STUDENTS IN ARTS PROGRAMMING HAD
BETTER ATTENDANCE FEWER
DISCIPLINARY ISSUES AND IMPROVED
ON TAP ON TASK BEHAVIOR.
RELATIVE TO COMPARISON STUDENTS --
ARTS EDUCATION PARTNERSHIP FIND
SCHOOLS OF LARGE POPULATIONS OF
STUDENTS AND ECONOMIC POVERTY
CAN BE TRANSFORMED INTO VIBRANT
HUBS OF LEARNING WHEN THE ARTS
ARE INFUSED INTO THEIR CULTURE
AND CURRICULUM WHICH MONEY
OBVIOUSLY POINTED TO JUST.
JUST WITH ONE EXAMPLE THERE --
pEDUCATION TO CLEAR THE STATUS OF
ARTS EDUCATION IN EQUITY ISSUE
AND A CIVIL RIGHTS ISSUE SINCE
SCHOOLS OF HIGHER CONCENTRATION
OF STUDENTS IN POVERTY WERE LESS
LIKELY TO OFFER ARTS EDUCATION
YEAH AND I CAN SEND YOU LINKS TO
ALL OF THOSE.
STUDIES WHEN THAT POINT WAS YOU
KNOW VERY.
THE PRESENTLY MADE BY MID BY THE
KNEES YEAH YEAH YEAH.
I JUST DON'T WANT TO ONE CAN
KIND OF AS A AS ASTORY OF WHAT
WE DO WHICH WE FIND KIND OF
REACHING SOME OF THE HIGHER
ACHIEVING STUDENTS WE HAVE A
PROGRAM CALLED GRAHAM YOU AND I
CAN ALL OF OUR CHAPTERS AND IT'S
IT IS MADE.
FOR FULL TIME COLLEGE STUDENTS --
WE SUPPORT MUSIC CAREER
ENDEAVORS BY OFFERING EXCLUSIVE
TALENT AND PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
INTRODUCTIONS IN NETWORKING
AMONGST PEERS -- JUST BEFORE
THEY REACH THE MOMENT WHEN
THEY'RE ABOUT TO ENTER THE
WORKPLACE SO IT'S USUALLY A
COUPLE YEARS INTO THEIR COLLEGE
CAREERS THAT THEY TEND TO JOIN
GRAHAM YOU -- AND PART OF WHAT
THIS PROGRAM ALSO OFFERS
ESPECIALLY IN OUR MARKET AND I
KNOW YOU GUYS ALSO DO THIS AND
AND BROTHER CHAPTERS WE WE HOW
OFFER A MENTOR PROGRAM FOR A
VERY SELECT GROUP OF OUR TOP TOP
MUSICIANS AND INTRODUCE THEM TO
THE PROFESSIONALS IN OUR MARKET
PLACE I PERSONALLY HAVE MEANT
SORT ABOUT SIX STUDENTS IN THE
LAST COUPLE YEARS -- IT'S AN
AMAZING OPPORTUNITY BOTH FOR US
AS PROFESSIONALS AS WELL AS FOR
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO GET HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE AN INTRODUCTION TO
THEIR PEERS.
AND WHEREVER MENTORING AN
APPRENTICESHIP IN IN TERMS ARE
AVAILABLE. FOR INTERNSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES I SHOULD SAY NOT
IN THE INTERIM.
WE NEED BOTH -- BUT THE
INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES ARE
AVAILABLE.
WE SEE GREATER -- BETTER
OUTCOMES LONGER LASTING CAREERS
AND HIGHER EARNINGS
OPPORTUNITIES JUST IN GENERAL
WE'VE SEEN STUDENTS TO GO FROM
BEING COLLEGE STUDENTS TO
BECOMING THE GENERAL MANAGERS OF
RECORD LABELS ONE OF MY STUDENTS
THAT I MENTOR FOR EXAMPLE SO --
AND WE HAVE ALSO FOUND THAT WITH
GRAMMY YOU IN THE COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT WE WORK WITH OUR
MEMBERSHIP.
THAT THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF THAT
PARTICULAR GROUP COMPARED TO OUR
GENERAL PROFESSIONAL MEMBERSHIPS.
ARE MUCH MORE DIVERSE -- TEND TO
BE GENDER BALANCED AND ARE MORE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE ETHNIC AND
RACIAL DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE STATE.
SO -- CATCHING STUDENTS WHILE
THEY ARE YOUNG AND BRINGING THEM
INTO THE PROFESSIONAL PIPELINE
[inaudible]
OFFERING.
EVEN AT THE COLLEGE LEVEL IS
WE'RE FINDING THAT THE THAT
EQUITY AND DIVERSITY IS IS KIND
OF BECOMING MORE THE NORM.
THAN HIS WHAT WE'VE SEEN
HISTORICALLY SO THAT'S BEEN
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE REALLY
PROUD OF ADDITIONALLY THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK THAT WE DO AT THE
HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL WE TYPICALLY
DO THAT THROUGH OUR NOT AT NOT.
NON PROFITS -- ORGANIZATIONS THE
GRAMMY MUSEUM FOUNDATION -- THEY
OFFER A PROGRAM CALLED GRAMMY IN
THE SCHOOLS AND WE USE THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY CONNECTS
SUCCESSFUL ARTISTS WITH ASPIRING
STUDENTS -- PERFORMERS SUCH AS
FULL TIME GRAMMY NOMINEE LEGACY
AND TWICE NOMINATED SINGER
KALANI HAVE PARTICIPATE IN THIS
PROGRAM IN SAN FRANCISCO -- WE
CLEARLY RECOGNIZE THAT STUDENTS
WITH STRONG MENTORING
OPPORTUNITIES AND CAN GO ON TO
ACHIEVE THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
SUCCESS IN THE RIGHT ENVIRONMENT.
ADDITIONALLY THE GRAMMY MUSEUM
FOUND THAT NATION ALSO OFFERS A
SUMMER INTENSIVE PROGRAM CALLED
GRAHAM ACCOUNT IT'S A FIVE DAY.
NOT CURRENTLY NON RESIDENTIAL
SUMMER MUSIC INDUSTRY PROGRAM
FOR HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS THAT
ARE INTERESTED IN CAREERS AND
MUSIC SO SOME OF OUR OTHER
PROGRAMMING IS ABOUT JUST
EXPOSURE. TO MUSIC IN THE
PROFESSION -- IN MUSIC BUT BUT
ADDITIONALLY THIS PROGRAM IS
FOCUSED ON THOSE THAT WANT A
CAREER TRACK IN MUSIC AND THEN
OFFER THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE THAT.
IN SORT OF THIS -- HEART BE OF
LA -- IT'S IT'S A PROGRAM THAT
WE'VE BEEN DOING FOR A FEW YEARS
AND IT IS A PROGRAM THAT EVEN
THOUGH -- WE OFFER IT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT IS COMPLETELY.
FUNDED IT'S SOMETHING THAT THEY
THEMSELVES -- HAVE TO ALSO GET
SCHOLARS OF A LOT OF TIME IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT THEM ATTENDING
THIS PROGRAM -- I KNOW WE NEED
TO WRAP UP YES ARE KIND OF TIME
SO -- ONE I GUESS JUST WE WERE
GOING TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
OBSTACLES FACING MUSIC EDUCATION
WHICH REALLY COMES DOWN TO
FUNDING.
YEAH I THINK THAT WE'RE WE ARE
CONSTANTLY RECOGNIZING IS A
FIGHT WITHIN THE CAPITAL -- WE
WE HAVE A VERY SIMPLE MISSION
WHICH IS WE WANT TO MUSIC
TEACHER IN EVERY PUBLIC SCHOOL
IN CALIFORNIA THAT IS THAT AT
OUR WE FEEL THAT EVERY STUDENT
SHOULD HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY --
ENDS THIS THIS SIMPLE GOAL ISN'T
EASY BUT WE WE WOULD AT LEAST
LIKE TO SEE -- THE FUNDING
LEVELS PER PUPIL REACH THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE -- WAY I HAVE
OF I BELIEVE IT'S TWELVE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PRISTINE ROUGHLY --
WHICH WE WERE HERE LAST WEEK
WITH THE NAM FOUNDATION IN
CALIFORNIA'S AGHAJ CATERS
ASSOCIATION TO TALK ABOUT WITH.
A LOT OF DIFFERENT FOLKS HERE IN
THIS BUILDING SO -- WE HOPE THAT
THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU ALL CAN
CONSIDER ON JUST RAISING THE PER
PEOPLE AVERAGE AND ALSO WANT TO
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN FOR FOR
YOUR WORK LAST YEAR ALONG WITH
WHEN WITH OUR PARTNERS OF
CALIFORNIA LINES FOR ARTS
EDUCATION -- IN PASSING GRANT
PROGRAM -- TO MAKE SURE THAT
SCHOOLS WERE GETTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING RESOURCES MAY I GROW IT
YEP.
OKAY REALLY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- FOR ALSO
HAVING ME AND AND YOUR
HEADQUARTERS AND LESSONS THAT
WAS GREAT -- AND THIS GREAT
LEARNING ABOUT THE WORK YOU'RE
DOING.
LET ME ASK I JUST FINE BEFORE WE
BEFORE MOVING THE NEXT PANEL ON
IMAGE I RECEIVED WE BOTH TALKED
ABOUT THE NEED FOR MORE MONEY I
GET THAT.
I WANTED TO JUST ZERO IN A
LITTLE BIT ON ONE PARTICULAR ASK
YOU HAD TO DO WITH THE WITH THE
CATEGORIZATION C. T. FUNDING AND
AND WHAT'S STANDING IN THE WAY
IN TERMS OF THAT SEEMS LIKE
SOMETHING WE WE COULD.
GET FIXED CURRENTLY A TEACHER
HAS TO HAVE ONE THOUSAND YEARS --
HOURS OF EXPERTISE IN THE AREA.
FOR THE QUALIFY -- FIFTY FIVE WE
ARE ACTUALLY TRAINING THE
TEACHERS THAT ARE IN THE CLASS
BY THE TIME THEY GOT THREE YEARS
WHICH IS NOT NOT THOUSAND HOURS.
BUT IT IS VERY INTENSE.
BECAUSE OUR KIDS IT'S AN IN
SCHOOL PROGRAM NINETY MINUTES
TWICE A WEEK -- AND THERE ARE
AND IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE IN THE
CLASS BY THEMSELVES THEY'RE
THERE WITH OUR PROFESSIONAL.
SO IF YOU COULD CATEGORIZE IT
SAY HE LOOKS EITHER A THOUSAND
HOURS FOR INSTRUCTION.
OR TEEN TEACHING WITH
PROFESSIONALS FOR SOME FAT YOU
KNOW I WOULD SAY I WOULD SAY TWO
THREE YEARS WHAT THAT DOES THAT
THAT GIVES.
THE DISTRICTS INCENTIVE HEY WAIT
A MINUTE IF I GO WITH THIS AND I
DEVELOP THE PROGRAM.
BY YEAR THREE I CAN HAVE EVERY
TEACHER THAT I HAD A CLASS AND
THEN I CAN GET SOME SUBSIDIES OR
SOME EXTRA FUNDS. FOR THESE
CLASSES OKAY -- BECAUSE THEY
WERE OUT AT THE IF YOU DON'T
MIND IF I COULD ASK YOU TO TEAM
UP WITH DAN AND LEARN ON THAT --
TRIP TO TACKLE SHOP ABOUT MAYBE
WE CAN MAKE ALL THE CHANGES IN
THE RULES -- TO YEAH YEAH YEAH
OKAY ALL RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU THE THREE OF YOU
AND THEY AND OUT ONCE AGAIN AND
THEY'RE SUCH COOL WORK BEHIND
EACH OF THOSE PRESENTATIONS AND
WE KNOW HOW MANY YOUNG PEOPLE'S
LIVES ARE BEING CHANGED.
I THERE'S ALL THE ALERT THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT LET'S CALL UP --
I'VE ACTUALLY COUPLE THOSE YOUNG
PEOPLE -- THESE LIVES ARE BEING
CHANGED WE HAVE SERRA BURKE
BAKER AND CAROLINE BURKE BAKER
WHO ARE -- STUDENTS IN STOCKTON
UNIFIED I WE ALSO JUST A
MARTINEZ IS THE PRINCIPAL
FREMONT LOPEZ -- ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL WE COULD TALK ABOUT THEIR
WORK AND THEN AND THEN TIFFANY'S
HERE IS WELL AS EXACTLY DIRECTOR
OF TURN AROUND ARTS.
CALIFORNIA -- SO I THINK WE'RE
TO START WITH TIFFANY AND THEN
GO ON TO PRINCIPLE MARTINEZ AND
AND AND THEN THE THE BURKE BAKER
SISTERS -- WE APPRECIATE YOU.
CONFORMING WITH OUR A TIME FRAME
RIGHT NOW TO DO APOLOGIZE I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
LET'S START WITH YOU -- TIFFANY.
GREAT FANTASTIC HIGH THANK YOU
ALL FOR HAVING US -- I KNOW
WE'RE TAKE FOR TIMES I'M GOING
TO KEEP MY REMARKS -- TO A
MINIMUM BECAUSE I'M SUPER
GRATEFUL. TO HAVE ONE OF OUR
INCREDIBLE PARTNER SCHOOLS
FREMONT LOPEZ ELEMENTARY WITH US
OUR PRINCIPAL INTO INCREDIBLE.
ALARMS FROM THAT SCHOOL ONE WHO
ACTUALLY HAD A FINAL THIS
MORNING.
SO THAT'S THE DEDICATION.
OF THEM COMING ALL THE WAY OVER
HERE AFTER HAVING ALREADY TAKEN
THE FINAL SO THANK YOU VERY.
MUCH FOR COMING.
I THINK WE'RE GONNA SHOW A SHORT
VIDEO ON TURN ON ARTS AND THEN
I'LL GIVE YOU A LITTLE
BACKGROUND ON OUR WORK BEFORE
YOU CAN HEAR FROM.
OUR PARTNER
.
REALLY GOT US EXCITED
[inaudible]
ON SOMETHING [inaudible]
SEXUAL [inaudible]
RUSHING.
I FEEL LIKE.
BECAUSE I JUST LOVE THE SOUND
THEY GENERATE.
THAT'S THAT'S THE VISCERAL RATE
YEAH THAT'S HOW WE HELP TO
CREATE PASSION IN OUR KIDS LIVES
CLASSES BUZZING.
YEAH SO -- THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN SO MUCH FOR INVITING TURN
ON ARTS CALIFORNIA -- SOMEONE
NUMBER TWO IN YOUR YOUR HEARING.
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS WONDERFUL.
AND THANK YOU LAUREN SO MUCH FOR
YOUR SUPPORT.
SO I'M GONNA KEEP OUR HISTORY
SHORT BUT JUST SO YOU KNOW TURN
ON ARTS WAS BORN OUT OF
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S IT RECOGNITION --
THAT WE NEED TO REINVEST IN THE
ARTS -- AND THE PRESIDENT'S
COMMITTEE ON THE ARTS AND
HUMANITIES -- RESEARCH AND ALL
TO ACTION AROUND THAT
REINVESTMENT -- AND THEN -- IN --
TWENTY FOURTEEN TURN ON ARTS
CALIFORNIA WAS BORN THROUGH THE
VISIONARY LEADERSHIP OF FRANK
YURI AND LISA SHRIVER.
AND FIVE YEARS LATER WE ARE NOW
PARTNERING WITH TWENTY FOUR
SCHOOLS ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA -- AND IT IS OUR GOAL
TO HELP IN POWER THOSE SCHOOLS
THROUGH THE TRAM TRANSFORMATIVE
POWER OF LEADING THROUGH THE
ARTS YEAH -- SO.
I'M IT QUICKLY TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT OUR APPROACH OUR RESULTS
AND THEN I'M GONNA LET YOU TALK --
TO ONE OF OUR INCREDIBLE --
PRINCIPLES AND TO STUDENTS WHO
REALLY LIVED IT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S GONNA BE A LOT MORE
INTERESTING THAN THAN -- MORE IN
TERMS OF ART FOR ME.
BUT REALLY JUST TO GIVE YOU A
SENSE OF WHAT OUR APPROACH IS A
TURNAROUND ARTS.
ITS THREE PRONGED WE LEVERAGE
RESOURCES -- WITH OUR PARTNER
SCHOOLS WE DIDN'T WE ASK FOR A
COMMITMENT FROM THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FINANCIALLY -- AND TO
BRING A DISCREET ARE DEDICATION
AND TO SUPPORT THAT ARTS
EDUCATION IN THE CLASSROOM WE
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL FINANCIAL
SUPPORT TO THOSE SCHOOLS. TO
WORK WITH ARTS ORGANIZATIONS IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO REALLY
EMPOWER THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WE
WORK WITH ORGANIZATIONS LIKE PS
ARTS GET LIT VISUAL THINKING
STRATEGIES SUNSET CENTER.
AND WE REALLY FOCUSED ON
BUILDING HELPING THOSE SCHOOLS.
BILL THOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH
THOSE LOCAL ARTS ORGANIZATIONS
AND OUR GOAL IS THAT ALL
STUDENTS IN THOSE SCHOOLS
RECEIVE ARTS EDUCATION IN THE
CLASSROOM YEAR ROUND AND IF
YOU'VE HEARD THAT BEFORE THAT.
THAT IS WHAT OUR ASPIRATION
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING IN OUR
SCHOOLS YEAH.
THE SECOND THING WE DO WHEN WE
REALLY DOUBLE DOWN ON THIS IN
THE AST FEW YEARS BECAUSE WE
ARE LIVING THIS AND LEARNING
FROM IT.
IS REALLY FOCUSING ON THE ADULTS.
INVESTING IN THE ADULT IN THE
SCHOOLS OUR TEACHERS AND OUR
PRINCIPLES AND REALLY HELPING
THEM TO LEAD THROUGH THE ARTS.
SO WE PROVIDE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT COACHING AND
TRAINING. TO THOSE PRINCIPLES TO
THOSE TEACHERS NOT ONLY -- IN
THEIR CORE SUBJECTS BUT ALSO IN
ARTS EDUCATION REALLY FOCUSED ON
HOW DO WE USE ARTS INTEGRATION
TO EMPOWER TEACHERS TO FEEL LIKE
THEY HAVE THE TOOLS. TO ENGAGE.
OUR KIDS IN AND HELP THEM TO
LEARN IN CREATIVE WAYS -- THE
THIRD THING THAT WE DO IS WE
ALSO PARTNER WITH HIGH PROFILE
ARTISTS AND WE BRING THEM INTO
THE SCHOOLS.
AND THE SCHOOLS THAT WE PARTNERS
WITH I SHOULD SAY ARE THE
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED -- FEDERALLY AND IN
CALIFORNIA AS HIGH PRIORITY SO
NOT ONLY ARE THEY TITLE ONE
SCHOOLS THEIR SCHOOLS WITH KIDS --
AND FAMILIES WHO HAVE LOW INCOME
THEY'RE ALSO SCHOOLS THAT ARE.
ESSENTIALLY LABELED ON
HISTORICALLY LABELED LOW
PERFORMING.
AND THERE'S OFTEN A NARRATIVE --
THAT FOLLOWS -- THOSE
COMMUNITIES -- AND CAN BE REALLY --
NOT SUPPORTIVE TO THEIR IS
THRIVING AND SUCCESS AND PART OF
WHAT WE DO WITH WORKING IN THESE
HIGH PROFILE ARTISTS WORKING
WITH THE KIDS BRINGING MEDIAN
VISIBILITY THE SCHOOLS IS TO
SHOW THAT.
THE KIDS IN THE SCHOOLS HAVE
JUST AS MUCH ABILITY IN
POTENTIAL AS ANY OTHER SCHOOL
YEAH AND TO HELP ALL THE THAT
COMMUNITY THE TEACHERS THE
STUDENTS TO SEE.
THEY ARE AT POTENTIAL NOT AT
RISK YOU HAVE TO REALLY HAVE
SUCCESS [inaudible]
SO.
THE RESULTS THAT WE FOCUSED ON
AND WHEN WE WERE ORIGINALLY --
CREATED IT WAS BASED ON A
NATIONAL PILOT -- THAT LOOKED AT
HIGH PRIORITY SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
NATION AND PROVIDED ARTS
EDUCATION AND THEN LOOKED AT
OTHER SCHOOLS THAT JUST WERE
JUST RECEIVE ADDITIONAL FUNDING
AND THE RESULTS WERE SIGNIFICANT
THAT THOSE KIDS WERE PERFORMING
BETTER IN SCHOOL.
AND THAT'S TRUE IN OUR PROGRAM
BUT ONE THING THAT WE HAVE FOUND
AND THAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING AT
AND DIGGING INTO EVALUATING.
IS WHEN WE WORK WITH OUR SCHOOLS.%
OUR PARTNER SCHOOLS THE TEACHERS
THE PRINCIPALS THE COMMUNITIES
REPORT TO RENT DRAMATIC SHIFTS
IN THE SCHOOL CULTURE AND
CLIMATE.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO US
OUR TEACHERS ARE MOTIVATED AND
ENGAGE AND THEY FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE NEW TOOLS AND NEW WAYS TO
ENGAGE WITH THEIR CHILDREN
THROUGH THE ARTS TO LEARN AGAIN
NOT JUST DIRECT ARTS EDUCATION
BUT ALSO IN THE CORE SUBJECTS.
USING OUR DEDICATION.
I'M OUR STUDENTS ARE ENGAGED NOT
ONLY ATTENDANCE BUT REALLY
LOOKING AT TEACHER SURVEYS AND
HOW THEY ARE ENGAGED IN THE
CLASSROOM IN THE LEARNING
PROCESS.
AND THEN THE THIRD IS FAMILY
ENGAGEMENT.
HOW DO WE GET OUR FAMILIES TO
OUR SCHOOLS AND THESE ARE
SCHOOLS WHEREFAMILIES ARE
WORKING VERY HARD TO SUPPORT
THEIR KIDS AND IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET THEM INTO THE INTO THE
SCHOOL OR MAYBE THEY DON'T FEEL?
WELCOME AT THE SCHOOLS WE REALLY
FOCUS ON BRINGING THEM IN
LEARNING THEM IN THROUGH THE
ARTS. TO WORK WITH WITH TEACHERS
PRINCIPALS AND STUDENTS -- AND
THEN WE ALSO SEE A HIGHER TEST
SCORES WITH OUR STUDENTS.
BUT WHAT WE REALLY FEEL IS THAT
THOSE INITIAL INDICATORS ARE ARE
REALLY ABOUT READING IS TO LEARN
WE KEEP TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
ARTS SUPPORTS ARE SHOWN THE
ABILITY TO LEARN.
BUT WHAT IT ALSO DOES THIS OF
COURSE THEY'RE READY MISS TO
LEARN RAIN WATER THESE KIDS.
CHECK THE BOX FOR A LOT OF ACES
STUDY INDICATORS AND WHAT WE
NEED TO DO IS CREATE AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE WHERE THEY
FEEL SAFE WITH THE FEEL JOY AND
WILL THEY FEEL -- INTERESTED IN
YOUR AGENT AND LEARNING.
SO I'M GONNA END THERE BECAUSE
I'M VERY EXCITED TO INTRODUCE
PRINCIPLE MARTINEZ WHO'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE PARTNER. TO TURN
AROUND ARTS -- AND ARE TO
STUDENTS.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN AND
ASSEMBLY FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU TODAY -- THE FIRST
THING I'D LIKE TO SAY IS THAT WE
PARTNER WITH HER ON ARTS -- WE
WERE TOLD THAT ARTS USE ARTS IS
A TOOL NOT A ROSE OKAY SO WHAT
WE LOOKED AT THE OR WHEN I'M
ENGAGING MY KIDS I SAID WE STILL
HAVE TO HAVE THE ROSE.
AS WE DEVELOP THE TOOLS SO WE
DEVELOPED OUR PATHWAYS.
AND EXPOSURE WE GIVE KATE
THROUGH FOR EXPOSURE TO THE ARTS
AND IN FIFTH THROUGH EIGHTH
GRADE WE GIVE THE PATHWAYS
BECAUSE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
INTRODUCE A PROGRAM YOU HAVE TO
HAVE A PATHWAY.
AND THEN LEADS TO A HIGH SCHOOL
SO KIDS SEE PURPOSE SO THAT WAS
THE NUMBER ONE THING WE DID.
THE NEXT THING WE DID WAS LOOK
AT INTEGRATION STRATEGIES
THROUGH THE CLASSROOM -- IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT AS THE TOOL AS WE
WANT TO USE THE ARTS FOR THAT IT
IS TIED TO STANDARDS IN THAT --
STUDENTS KNOW THAT WHEN WE'RE
USING A LARGE STRATEGY IT HELPS
TO LEARN. FOR CURRICULUM.
THE LA STANDARD MASS STANDARD
AND I THINK THAT'S WERE -- THE
DIRECTION THAT THE ARTS DOES
NEED TO GO IS GET INTO THAT
CLASSROOM MAKE SURE THE BILL
STRATEGIES ARE REAL.
SO THAT NOT ONLY THAT THE DO THE
TEACHERS KNOW HOW TO ARTICULATE
TO THE STUDENTS THAT THEY ARE
LEARNING THIS.
THAT ARE LEARNING COMMON CORE
STRATEGIES IN THE LA MATH.
BUT THAT ALSO THE STUDENTS ARE
DOING IT AND THE TEACHERS ARE
DOING AND WE'RE ALL AWARE THAT
MORNING IS TAKING PLACE -- IN
THOSE AREAS.
BUT THE MAIN THING THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO DO AT FREMONT WAS TO
PROVIDE OUR STUDENTS WITH
PURPOSE.
AND TWENTY FIRST CENTURY SKILLS
SO THAT WHAT THEY WERE LEARNING
AT FREMONT THEY WERE ABLE TO SAY
HEY I WANT TO GO TO CHAVEZ HIGH
SCHOOL OR NO I DON'T WANT TO GO
TO CHáVZ HIGH SCHOOL BASED OFF
OF WHAT I LEARNED.
FROM MY AND THAT'S KIND OF I'M
GIVING YOU THE I KNOW WE'RE WERE
WERE PRESSED FOR TIME.
BUT THAT'S THE BIG PICTURE OF
WHAT I SAW AS FAR AS PRESENTING
TO OUR STUDENTS AND STAFF THAT
WE HAVE TO GIVE ALL OF OUR
STUDENTS WE WE'VE HEARD ABOUT
EQUITY -- ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
HAVE ACCESS TO IT.
WHAT AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE WERE DOING
SO THAT'S?
THAT WAS THE MAIN DRIVE FOR THE
PROGRAM SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THE WAY THROUGH THE THICK THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AND YOUR OFFERINGS TO MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE WAY
THE STUDENT LOOKS AT THEIR
LONGER TERM HE EXACTLY OR
ANYTHING YOU HEALTH YEAH YOU
HAVE TO DO A FROM QUE ALL THE
WAY IF YOU JUST RIGHT IF YOU
GIVE IT TO ON THE SEVENTH AND
EIGHTH.
GRADE IT'S JUST A FILLER REYES
HAS TO BE WHO YOU ARE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU OKAY.
NOW WE HAVE OUR OUR STUDENTS.
SO MY NAME IS SARAH AND I'M A
SOPHOMORE AT CEDAR TRAVIS HIGH
SCHOOL AND FREMONT LIKE WITH MY
OWN TO SCHOOL FROM KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH THE EIGHTH GRADE.
AND I WAS IN SIXTH GRADE WHEN
TURN ON ARTS WAS IMPLEMENTED OUR
SCHOOLS AND I REMEMBER BEFORE
THAT.
REMOTE WAS A FAIRLY ROUGH SCHOOL
LIKE THE ATTENDANCE WASN'T TOO
GREAT BUT I FOUND THAT THROUGH
THE ART.
KIDS WERE LIKE SHOWING UP MORE
BECAUSE THEY WANTED TO COME TO
THEIR MUSIC CLASSES THEY WANTED
TO BE THERE FOR THEM.
AND LIKE KIDS SO YOU'RE LIKE HEY
MAN LIKE.
STAY ON TASK BECAUSE YOU GOT TO
KEEP YOUR GRADES UP SO LIKE WE
CAN GO TO LIKE THIS FUN STUFF
MUSIC.
SO LIKE.
IT'S AN INCENTIVE TO WANT TO BE
ABLE TO DO GOD LIKE BETTER
YOURSELF THAT WAY YOU CAN ENJOY
WHAT YOU'RE.
HAVE IN FRONT OF YOU.
AND THEN FOR ME WHAT TURN ON
ARTS IS LIKE BEEN MEANING TO ME
IS I LIKE EVERY KID HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY.
TO DISCOVER THEMSELVES THROUGH
THE ART.
IS ART CAN BE A VERY EXPRESSIVE
THING TO WEAR.
SOMETIMES MORE LIKE YOU CAN'T
FIGURE OUT STUFF IN WORDS YOU
CAN EXPRESS THROUGH MUSIC SIR OR
ARE EVEN DANCE -- TO WHERE IT'S
JUST.
EASIER THAT SENT.
SO LIKE I FELT LIKE IT MEANS TO
ME THAT EVERY KID DOES HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO FIND THEMSELVES
AND JUST.
HAVE DIFFERENT OPPORTUNITIES
THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE WITHOUT
THE ART.
BECAUSE I'VE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH
TO HAVE TURN ARTS LIKE AND JUST
ARTS IN GENERAL LIKE HAVE A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR MYSELF AS
SUCH AS GOING TO THE COUNTY
CENTER.
I'M GOING TO WASHINGTON DC NOW
TWICE.
LIKE WITHOUT THE ARTS I WOULDN'T
OF HOW THOSE OPPORTUNITIES I
WOULD HAVE HAD THESE EXPERIENCES
THAT MAKE ME WHO I AM TODAY.
AND EVEN THOUGH I DON'T WANT TO
MAJOR IN MUSIC WHEN I GO TO
COLLEGE I WANTED ON THE MEDICAL
FIELD.
BUT MUSIC AND THE ARTS HAS STILL
MADE ME A BETTER PERSON AND
MAYBE BETTER PREPARED THAT.
IT IS MADE ME LEARN HOW TO HAVE
PATIENCE WITH MYSELF AND OTHERS.
IT IS MADE ME BETTER IN MATH
WITH COUNTING AND JUST RHYTHMS
AND FIGURING OUT DIFFERENT.
FORMULAS.
AND THEN ALSO JUST LEADERSHIP
AND HAVING LIKE BETTER SELF
CONTROL AND RESPONSIBILITY OVER
MYSELF. TO WHERE I AM NOW A
BETTER PERSON THAT I CAN GO INTO
WHATEVER FIELD I CHOOSE EVEN
THOUGH IT'S NOT NECESSARILY
MUSIC HERE.
WHAT BROUGHT YOU TO COUNTY
CENTER WOULD YOU YOU PERFORM
THERE WAS YEAH IT WAS IT?
OUR ORCHESTRA OR WHAT OR I'M IN
THE MONEY YET SHE AT SO WHEN I
STARTED THE MONEY YET TO PROGRAM
AT THREE MILE MENTERI AND AND
AND THE JOB AS MANY AS YOU
PROGRAM.
PLAYED THE CASE THAT.
AS A WAY TO FREMONT CHAVEZ MONEY
GETTING A CALL. OH OKAY WE HAVE
ALL AGES. TO SHOW THE LOVE IT --
GROUND OF HOW STUDENTS FROM
FREMONT ARE GOING -- TO CHAVEZ
AND THEN THEY COME BACK AND HELP
OUR KIDS I LOVE IT YEAH THAT'S
THE RECORD.
OKAY AWESOME DISSING AS WELL YES
I DON'T KNOW WHEN THE JAZZ CHOIR
YOUR FAVORITE MY AGE IS ON BUT I
THINK THE ONE THAT WILL ALWAYS
BE NEAR INTO MY HEART IS NOT
SORRY EITHER.
BY LOVE RIGHT START I STARTING
THAT SONG IN SEVENTH GRADE.
WHERE IT'S ALWAYS JUST BEEN WITH
ME AND JUST HELP ME LIKE?
WE NOW HAVE A LOT OF FRIENDS IN
JALISCO.
WHERE THE CHANNEL YEAH THAT?
IS FROM SO CABLE GREAT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR I
APPRECIATE THAT OKAY -- CAROLINE
ARE YOU SINGER TO OR YOUR OKAY.
EXCELLENT -- WELL FIRST OF ALL
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE MY OWN.
CENTRAL -- ASPECTS OF HOW ARTS
HAS AFFECTED ME FIRST HAND NOT
ONLY JUST ME THROUGHOUT MY WHOLE
COMMUNITY -- SO.
I WAS AT FREMONT ALSO K. THROUGH.
EIGHT WE DIDN'T RECEIVE THE TURN
ARTS GRANT UNTIL.
I HAD JUST LEFT.
IT GREEN.
AND SO I WAS THERE FOR THE WHOLE
PROCESS OF US NOT REALLY HAVING
ANY SORT OF ART FORM. TO FULLY
BEING.
TOTALLY IMMERSED IN OUR SCHOOLS.
AND SO WITHOUT HAVING ARTS ARTS
WASN'T GIVING IT WAS SOMETHING
YOU.
REALLY HAD TO FIGHT AND PUSH FOR
IT WAS SOMETHING THAT.
YOU WERE ONLY GIVEN IF -- YOU
WERE ONE OF THE HIGHER CLASSES
ARE YOU JUST REALLY PUSH FOR IT
WAS SOMETHING THAT WASN'T
NECESSARILY DEAN DOES.
IMPORTANT FOR ALL.
STUDENTS.
AND ONCE TURN AROUND ARTS -- WAS
IMPLEMENTED IN OUR SCHOOLS IT
WASN'T JUST SOMETHING THAT.
YOU EITHER DECIDED FOR YOUR
PARENTS PUSH FOR OUR YOU WERE
JUST THROWN INTO IT WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS A STANDARD
ACROSS ALL GRADE LEVELS.
AND WITH THAT WE'VE SEEN A HUGE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF CHANGE NOT
ONLY IN THE CLASSROOM THROUGHOUT
THE COMMUNITY JUST THE OVERALL.
CULTURE IN OUR SCHOOLS AND THE
COMMUNITY THROUGHOUT.
IT'S NOT ONLY.
AFFECTED OUR GRADES EVERYTHING
JUST THE OVERALL WAY WE GO ABOUT
LIFE.
AND IT WAS IF IT WASN'T FOR ALL
OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES I'VE HAD
TO THE ARTS I WOULDN'T EVEN BE.
AT THE HIGH SCHOOL THAT I WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO TO I WAS SUPPOSED
TO GO TO A JUST ACADEMIC HIGH
SCHOOL JUST BASED ON MY LIKE
LOCATION OF WHERE I LIVE.
I WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN GIVING ANY
OPPORTUNITIES TO PURSUE THE ART.
BUT THANKFULLY IMPLEMENTED INTO
OUR DAILY LIVES I REALIZE THAT I
HAD A PASSION FOR TEACHING AND
TEACHING OTHERS.
AND TO THAT DECISION I DECIDED
TO GO TO MY CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
I KNOW I'M PURSUING PURSUING A
MUSIC EDUCATION. FOR COLLEGE
LOCAL YEAH SO WITH OUT DO YOU
KNOW WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO SEE
THE UNIVERSITY OF THE PACIFIC
OKAY -- YOU SAME THING CLASS
OKAY THINK OF GREAT BUT BEING A
FUTURE MUSIC EDUCATOR MYSELF I
REALIZE THAT.
THE ARTS AND MUSIC AND
EVERYTHING EVERY SWORD ART.
ART FORM IS MORE THAN JUST -- I
LEARNED HOW TO DRAW I CAN PLAY
AN INSTRUMENT IT'S MORE.
IT'S MORE THAN JUST THAT BEING
IN A CLASSROOM THAT PROVIDE YOU
THESE OPPORTUNITIES IT TEACHES
YOU SORTS OF LIFE SKILLS THE YOU
BUILD ON NO MATTER WHAT.
IT'S SORT OF RESPONSIBILITY
PATIENTS.
JUST DETERMINATION IT'S THE WAY
YOU USE.
YOUR EVERYDAY SKILLS TO GET
THROUGH LIFE WHETHER YOU'RE
GONNA BE THE NEXT MUSICIAN OR
THE NEXT DOCTOR.
YEAH GREAT.
THANK YOU ALL REPRESENT A WE AND
WE GOT A LOT OF MUSIC EDUCATION
PEOPLE HERE THAT WE HAVE.
BUT WE AT THE GRAMMYS HERE WE
GOT WE GOT EVERYBODY SO SO YOU
SIT DOWN TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS.
MOMENT TO DO SOME CAREER
NETWORKING.
ALL RIGHT WELL LISTEN REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE A WONDERFUL
PANEL AND AND AND ALL YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST THAT THAT'S A GREAT
SNAPSHOT OF OF THE EXCITING
THINGS HAPPENING THROUGHOUT THE
STATE AND AND HOW THE THINGS
THAT WE DO HERE AT AL THE WORK
THAT'S HAPPENING IN THE ARTS
COUNCIL.
AND ELSEWHERE AT THE STATE LEVEL
AND THE FILTERING DOWN AND
CHANGING LIVES AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL WHICH IS FANTASTIC SO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT -- WHEN WE
OPEN UP OPPORTUNITY FOR FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT -- AND ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT TO
THE THE COMMITTEE.
AND THAT IS OUR MEASURE OKAY.
AND YOU GUYS YOU GUYS CAN STAY
AND AND WELL AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL -- WILL CLOSE THE HEARING
IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR A
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARC THIS YEAR
AGO THE DS AND REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA.
MUSIC EDUCATORS ASSOCIATION AND
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT EQUITY AND
DIVERSITY IN MUSIC AND ARTS
EDUCATION.
AND WE ARE HERE TO STATE THAT WE
WOULD LIKE TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION WITH REGARDS TO EQUITY
AND DIVERSITY AND WISH TO
PARTICIPATE IN ANY EFFORTS.
IN THAT DIRECTION -- WE
ESPECIALLY ARE IN AGREEMENT WITH
THE COMMENTS MADE BY MRS GRANDE --
WITH REGARDS TO THE FACT THAT
THERE IS MUCH VARIABILITY OF
WHAT'S PROVIDED IN MUSIC AND
ARTS EDUCATION.
SORRY.
SORRY MARK ARTS EDUCATION IN OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
OUR STUDENTS ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS AND LOW SOCIO ECONOMIC
COMMUNITIES HAVE VERY LIMITED
LIMITED ACCESS OF ANY ACCESS TO
MUSIC AND ARTS EDUCATION.
AS YOU KNOW SENATORS ALLEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
TO OUR SCHOOLS STILL ARE NOT
FULLY FUNDED -- AMBER AND
CALIFORNIA'S STILL NOT IN THE
TOP TEN STATES WITH REGARDS TO
PER PUPIL FUNDING.
SO AS MR GARCIA STATED MANY
SUPERINTENDENTS HAVE TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS WITH REGARDS
TO WHAT TO PROVIDE TO THEIR
STUDENTS IN THEIR DISTRICT.
AND OFTEN TIMES IN THE TIME OF
ERA WHERE BUDGETS ARE TIGHT.
THE MUSIC AND ARTS EDUCATION AND
SPORTS ARE THE FIRST TO BE THE
FUNDED.
SO PLEASE REMEMBER OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS STILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES.
IF THEY ARE TO MAKE AVAILABLE.
A COURSE OF STUDY STANDARD SPACE
MUSIC AND ARTS EDUCATION.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR EVERY YEAR
TO ALL OF OUR STUDENTS INCLUDING
THOSE STUDENTS ATTENDING PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN LOW SOCIO CON SOCIO
ECONOMIC COMMUNITIES.
THANK YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH OKAY
WELL SO.
SOME MEMBER IF UNIQUE FOUND
QUESTIONS OR THOUGHTS OR
INTRODUCTION UNIQUE NO I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A A PERSONAL
PRIVILEGE -- TO RECOGNIZE A
TRUSTEE FROM MY DISTRICT ELLEN
ROSS SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND KARINA HERRERA LOW LARA.
OKAY DRASTIC AND ALSO THE
SUPERINTENDENT -- AND DR BAUER
HERE WITH US [inaudible]
YES.
VERY BRIEFLY UP.
THIS IS A MEETING OF THE MINDS
MY NAME IS THE LADY ABOUT WHERE
I'M SUPERINTENDENT IN A LITTLE
ROCK SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND I AM IN HERE -- BASICALLY TO
SUPPORT -- TO ENCOURAGE YOU GUYS
TO SUPPORT AB THIRTY NINE THAT
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO BE --
CONSIDERING TOMORROW AND I THINK
THAT'S GOING TO SOLVE A LOT OF
THE SITUATIONS THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT TODAY.
SPECIFICALLY WITH THE ARTS BEING
ONE OF THE DISTRICTS THAT HAD TO
FACE A VERY DIFFICULT CHALLENGE
OF CUTTING OUR BUDGET.
WITHOUT TOUCHING THE ART RIGHT
AND SO -- JUST TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW IMPORTANT.
THIS IS FOR OUR STUDENTS I LEAD
A DISTRICT THAT IS PRIMARILY
TITLE.
ONE WITH TWENTY FIVE SCHOOLS OF
WHICH TWENTY THREE OF THEM ARE --
FULL TITLE ONE SCHOOLS THIS IS A
VERY IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION FOR
STUDENTS WHO FOR WHOLE.
ART IS NOT ONLY A AND AN
ACADEMIC SUBJECT BUT I NEED IN
EMOTIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
CRITICAL THINKING SO PLEASE
SUPPORT THE RACE OF THE BASE
FUNDING FOR EVERYBODY FOR THE
SCHOOLS SO THAT WE CAN TAKE CARE
OF ALL THIS OTHER VERY IMPORTANT.
PIECES SO -- FOUR HOURS OUR
STUDENTS THEIR LIVES THERE YOU.
SEE REPORT I'M A CO AUTHOR OF
THE BILL RIGHT SO I'M I'M.
SO I GET IT THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
DR BAUER FOR TRAVEL ALL THE WAY
FROM CELLS SEEN JOINING US.
OF THE ONE YEAH SORRY OKAY GO
FOR IT OKAY YEP WAS I'LL GO BACK
YEAH I'M A FAST TALKER.
SON JULIE BAKER AND EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF CALIFORNIANS FOR THE
ARTS I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
ALLEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHIU FOR A
CAMPING THE ARTS AS YOU HAVE
ALWAYS DONE AND WHAT WHAT YOU
GUYS ARE DOING.
ALL THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND TO
THANK YOU TO YOU GUYS I'M MORE
LORNE AND DAY IN A FOR THEIR
PASSION AND COMMITMENT FOR
MAKING THIS HAPPEN.
I THINK IT'S A GREAT TIME TO BE
AN ARTS ADVOCATE INCALIFORNIA
ARE NOT ONLY DO WE HAVE A
GOVERNOR WHOSE PROACTIVELY PLAYS
AN ONGOING FUNDING INCREASE OF
TEN MILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
BUDGET.
HOWEVER IN PARENTHESES YOU JUST
BUT ALSO A TEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN THERE FOR TO MUSEUMS WHICH WE
TOTALLY -- WE DO NOT OPPOSE BUT
WE DON'T THINK IT SHOULD GO
THROUGH THE CAAC HAS THEM YEAH
FUNDING MECHANISM.
JUST WANT TO STATE THAT -- BUT
THE LIBRARY YES SOMEWHERE
SOMEWHERE ELSE -- IT SHOULD BE
THERE BUT NOT THERE BUT ANYWAY I
WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR ALLEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
LEADERSHIP AND MAKING APRIL
OFFICIALLY ARTS CULTURE AND
CREATIVITY MONTH IN CALIFORNIA.
LAST MONTH WE CELEBRATE WITH
ACTIONS TO BUILD AWARENESS OF
THE IMPACT OF THE ARTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE OP ED FROM HUMBLE
TO PALM DESERT.
PROCLAMATIONS FROM SACRAMENTO TO
SAN DIEGO AND ARTS ADVOCACY DAY
ATTENDED BY OVER TWO HUNDRED
DELEGATES VISITING SEVENTY SIX
LEGISLATORS WE HAVE OVER 65% OF
LEGISLATORS.
HEARD ABOUT THE VALLEY THE ARTS
CULTURE CREATIVE SECTORS BRING
TO CALIFORNIA.
IMPACTS STORIES FROM PEOPLE FROM
COMPTON TALK ABOUT ISSUES OF
PUBLIC SAFETY BUT THE ARTS CAN
BRING TO THEIR COMMUNITIES CURTI --
YOU SAW HER INCREDIBLE --
HOMELESSNESS PROJECT THAT WAS ON
DISPLAY OUTRIGHT.
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT HUMANIZING
HOMELESSNESS THROUGH THE ARTS
TEENAGERS SHARING THEIR STORIES
ABOUT THE IMPACTS ARE TO MAKE IN
RURAL COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR.
UP OR GIVING THEM A VOICE A
PLACE TO LAND FOR SOME LITERALLY
SAVING OF THEIR LIVES WITH A
SHARED WITH THE THE THURSDAY.
WE ARE DELIGHTED ONE TWELVE
LEGISLATORS TOOK TIME OUT OF THE
BUSY APRIL HEARING SCHEDULED TO
JOIN US ON THE CAPITOL STEPS
INCLUDING SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
YEAH AB ANTHONY RENDON WHO IS ON
THE JOINT COMMITTEE ON ARTS
CORRECT HE'S VERY VERSUS GOT IT
IS THERE ARE AND WILL BE.
FORGIVEN AND THE STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND --
WE'RE THRILLED THAT THEY WERE
THERE AT THE ARTS OFFSET
SPENDING THAT THE STATE NEEDS TO
MAKE IN OTHER AREAS TO SOLVE
SOME OF OUR BIG ISSUES WERE
REALLY HAPPY THAT THE ARTS ARE
BEING RECOGNIZED IN THAT WAY.
WE'RE ALSO DELIGHTED TO SHARE AS
YOU KNOW THE ARTS RECEIVE A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT TO WHICH IS
pUNIFIER WERE ALSO MAJOR
CONTRIBUTORS TO THE STATE'S
GREAT ECONOMY IS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY WE LIE TO USE THE
BUREAU OF ECONOMIC ANALYSIS.
NUMBERS WHICH ALSO SHOW THAT THE
CREATIVE ECONOMY CALIFORNIA
REPRESENTS SEVEN POINT 1% OF THE
GROSS STATE PRODUCT -- IT'S
ACTUALLY -- BEFORE AGRICULTURE
AND TRANSPORTATION WE'RE NO
LONGER AS SOMEONE ALREADY SAID
TODAY THE ICING ON THE CAKE WE
ARE ACTUALLY THE CAKE YEAH AND
ARTISTS ARE TWICE AS LIKELY THAT
A GOOD CAKE.
THERE ACTUALLY TWICE AS LIKELY --
TO WORK FROM HOME TO BE SELF
EMPLOYED AT ANY OTHER AMERICAN
YOU KNOW AS AS MOST AMERICANS
RIGHT SO THE JUST REPORT IS
ACTUALLY UNDER ESTIMATING THE
THE IMPACT THAT IT MAKES.
SO I JUST WANT TO STATE A STATE
THAT THE ARTS ARE GREAT
INVESTMENT WE CREATE JOBS WE
ONLINE WE EDUCATE WE INSPIRE AND
WE BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER WE WANT
TO SEE A CONTINUED INVESTMENT IN
THE STATE'S ARTS INFRASTRUCTURE
WITH MORE FUNDING FOR THE STATE
ARTS AGENCY.
ARTS EDUCATION CULTURE PRAGUE
AND CULTURAL PROGRAMS I'M HAPPY
TO BE SITTING ON SENATOR
UMBERG'S CREATIVE ECONOMY TASK
FORCE.
OF SB SEVEN THIRTY SIX BUT EVEN
WITH THE TEN MILLION INCREASE
FOR CC FROM GOVERNOR NUISANCE
BUDGET WE ARE STILL UNDER A
DOLLAR PER CAPITA PER PERSON AND
RANG TWENTY EIGHTH IN THE U. S.
YEAH WE CAN DO BETTER.
AND WE SO WE AND WE TRULY CAN
SAY WHEN WE ARE BETTER DOING
BETTER AND I KNOW YOU'RE FOR
THIS YES I'M SPEAKING TO THE YOU
KNOW CONVERTED ALREADY BUT
CALIFORNIA IS THE STATE OF THE
ART YEAH THANK GOD I BY.
SPEAKING COME TO BRING PEOPLE
YEAH I LOVE YOUR PAN WHICH SAYS
BIPARTISAN AND I WANT TO POINT
OUT WE GOT A REPUBLICAN.
STAFF HERE IN IN IN IN AND WE
HAD A WONDERFUL DEMOCRATS
REPUBLICANS BOTH HERE TODAY
SUPPORTING THE ARTS SO.
I'M I I'M TERRIBLY TO MEETING
WHAT I'M GONNA DO IS HAND OVER
THE GAVEL TO A CELL NUMBER CHU
WHO CAN MAKE SOME FINAL COMMENTS
AND I AND AND CLOSE OUT BUT
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THIS
WONDERFUL HEARING TODAY.
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF I
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN.
AND AND YOUR STAFF -- MY STAFF
FOR PUTTING THIS IMPORTANT
HEARING TOGETHER SO THANK
SENATOR ALAN I WANNA NEXT --
OKAY I GET IT.
HI MY NAME'S JENNIFER ASPEN AND
I JUST CRASHED YOUR MEETING
TODAY BUT I'M I'M ACTUALLY A
PROFESSIONAL ACTRESS FOR TWENTY
YEARS AND A MOVIE PRODUCER.
AND I JUST WANTED TO SAY I'M
THRILLED THAT THIS IS HAPPENING
I COULDN'T SUPPORT WHAT'S GOING
ON HERE MORE I'M A GRADUATE OF
UCLA THEATER FILM AND TELEVISION
I WAS ON THE DEAN'S LIST I DON'T.
JUST WANT TO KNOW IF ANY OF TEM
TO BE ENDLESS YEAH -- BUT I I
AND NOW I'M A FEMALE MOVIE
PRODUCER OF THE BIGGEST MOVIE OF
THE YEAR ON HALLMARK CHANNEL
THIS YEAR.
SO JUST TO INTRODUCE MYSELF I'M
NOT REPRESENTING ANYONE EXCEPT
TO SAY THANK YOU. FOR DOING THIS
AND ADDITIONALLY TO SAY THAT TO
GET THESE YOUNG VIBRANT AMAZING
PEOPLE YOU'RE SO BEAUTIFUL.
INTO THE PIPELINE WE MUST KEEP
THE JOBS IN CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE THESE KIDS NEED TO BE
ABLE TO BE EMPLOYED RIGHT WHEN
THEY GRADUATE AND AS WE ALL KNOW
THAT'S A PROBLEM BUT THE MORE
THAT WE CAN HAVE A FUTURE. FOR
THE ARTS WITHIN CALIFORNIA THE
BETTER OFF WE WILL ALL BE THAT'S
ONLY WANTED TO SAY AND TO THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
IF WE ARE TO JUST FOR FOR THE
AUDIENCE WOULD HAVE ALREADY
EXTENDED THE TAX CREDIT. FOR THE
MOVIE SO [inaudible]
YEAH.
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC THAT WANTS
TO MAKE A COMMENT.
WHAT WAS THAT I WANT TO THANK
YOU VERY VERY MUCH AND ALL OF
THE PANELISTS?
AND AL THE PEOPLE THAT THEY ARE
HERE -- DID MEETINGS PREDICTED
HEARINGS PRETTY MUCH YOUR JOINTS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT